[Music]
yeah
on
[Music]
oh
n
[Music]
he
Magnus Carlson was on top of them all in
Toronto Canada at the end of the 2023
Champions chess tour a deep die of
relief Magnus took there and he was the
champion is he the greatest player of
all time many people think so and he
took down everybody to win the 2023
Champions chess tour and those beautiful
flowers there everybody reenters the
field in the 2024 Champions chess tour
trying to take the flowers and the
trophy and everything from Magnus will
he do it again or will someone else be
on top at the end he's down to pece he's
down two pawns a couple of checks
magnus's King is going to dance easily
out of them take my queen and give me a
new one please he's losing now he walked
right into the and they know it they
know it turn your boards 99 952 made a
big mistake oh and the bar's going up
this is an absolute Gem of a game Wesley
saw has done it he's going in for the
attack but he's walked into Checkmate
black can play Rook takes
porn one move Checkmate two seconds oh
oh my God why an armag
in the 2024 Champions chess tour kicks
off with the chessable Masters
International Master Danny wrench
alongside grandm da naroditsky it's
Danny and da today to welcome everybody
in as another tour begins da feels like
we were just here but I am super excited
to get things started in the New Year
well time flies Danny it's a great
pleasure to be covering the start of
this incredible event uh which is
quickly becoming a storied event with a
tradition that is actively getting built
up and it is an honor to be a part of
this tradition so happy to be here Danny
to kick things off and what promises to
be an epic 2024 season it will be epic
and we've got Magnus Carlson still as
the champion I guess he's now two years
in a row if you can consider the tour
that was merged from the previous chess
24 played Magnus group acquisition we're
all one family now he took down Wesley
so who was the chess.com Global Champion
I felt like it was very fitting that the
two of them were the last two men
standing there but here we have Magnus
and we have a lot of other people who
are getting tired of it always being
Magnus Carlson at the end but let's
remind everybody of the schedule da we
kick things off as we already said in
this 2024 year of our calendar of how we
track things as human beings with the
chessel Masters that's going to run from
today till February 7th and then the
rest of the events do not have their
their their full name yet but we will
have three others May 8th through the
15th July 17th through 24th and
September 25th to October 2nd you got a
problem with event two event three and
event four Danny I think those are great
names honestly very memorable got no
problem with it actually uh we may we
may have sponsors come in we we kind of
leave those leave those where they are
but they are they are scheduled and
barring some uh some cataclysmic event
that is when they will go down so mark
your calendars and be ready for them so
da I will say that even though this
event is kind of Forgotten or the the
the chess we're about to do was kind of
Forgotten at the end of the year I
really love the play in you just get
everybody in there it's like a massive
rapid title Tuesday are you excited for
today I'm extremely excited I always say
the great thing about the play uh is
that particularly fans who are newer
chess they're able to find new players
to root for because not only do we get
all of the usual names and all of the
usual names have a big X on their back
because everybody's trying to be that
guy uh who prevents you know hikarin
Nakamura or leavon aronian or one of a
million other names uh from qualifying
but you get a lot of grand Masters that
maybe don't get as much airtime uh Danny
and I love spotlighting those really
really interesting players I totally
agree and I can't wait to see what
upsets and what what interesting players
turn our heads today uh we had eight
players turning our heads with lots of
interesting Chess at the finals in
Toronto last year as we get excited and
get pumped and as the players start
registering for the playing that's about
to go down let's remind everybody of all
the action in case they missed it at the
2023 live finals in
Toronto we have one clear Underdog one
clear favorite and six hungry
competitors looking to take this Crown
in Toronto and I think we're going to
see some blood here there's going to be
pieces flying when we do hit the
Armageddon Magnus is playing
surprisingly slowly but
Hikaru she look at that speed he's
trying to pre-move but he's running out
of time there's no mouse there's no
mouse and okay hiar resigns how do you
defend this position with no time morphe
the queen they'd all be so proud of this
effort I mean this is desperation for
Magnus Carlson you saw the shake of the
head on the camera there Magnus Carlson
resigns Wesley s takes the armagen
against the world number one Fabiano
Carana is in a form Hikaru can't believe
it today is not his day he has to win
tomorrow he gives up he resigns shake
hands and Fabiano Carana gets another
win in the
bag he's losing now he's in the net
he's in the net he walks right into the
net Bishop can and they know it they
know it Magnus Carlson gets the job done
takes it to Armageddon ala's time in
this tournament is running out ala fuja
eliminated we've just passed move 60
zero chance we'll see King versus King
Nakamura is out five doesn't knowwhere
to go but now it's winning for M he
brings his Rook all the way down rookie
he chooses the wrong Square he trapped
his own Queen and it's Handi Magnus gson
does the unbelievable he wins down a
queen he's got no time as well and lost
on the board these are the final few
seconds of nbe in the Champions chestar
finals nbec knows it he resigns wesle so
is into the the finals whes Rook is
keeping that black B Pawn under lock and
key and why is he allowed the black pawn
to run his King could have stepped
across I think we might be seeing the
last few moves of the 2023 Champions
chess tour Magnus Carson will save his
remaining Rook on F1 swing at AC cross
Black's Knight Black's Bishop a skew it
that's it and that's it Magnus Carlson
does it we have a winner it is him it
was always going to be him Magnus
Carlson the Undisputed king of speed
chess with wins the Champions chest
[Music]
finals it was him I guess it was always
going to be him you see that final call
there from T sat to pleasant memories
remembering how everything went down da
you were a fan what was your favorite
moment tuning in to the finals oh my
gosh I think I spent several hours after
the fact just analyzing some of the
games uh Danny because I think uh in in
all of the hype and there was a lot of
hype the actual level of play um is
often forgotten and the level of play in
the CCT finals was actually extremely
high that Rook F6 game um with Magnus
sacrificing the rook and defeating
Wesley so that was a huge highlight
there were some incredible end games I
made a YouTube video on all of the end
games from the CCT Danny and I barely
scratched the surface there was that
crazy rook and Bishop versus Rook uh
which was lost there were some amazing
Pawn end games Notre backck had an
incredible endgame against Wesley so
just the level of play and the level of
passion that the players put out in
Toronto as a fan yeah was really
something to watch well and it's funny I
I think it it speaks to the level of
play Given that so many matches had to
be decided in Armageddon right and the
the format was exciting because you had
you had a lot of Armageddon chess and
and getting the players to bid their bid
their time was also a really fun element
to see the gamesmanship and kind of the
meta strategy going on there but that
was because so many of the matches just
had people unwilling to budge right the
the the immovable wall as you like to
say right they they weren't going
anywhere it forced Armageddon which led
to all kinds of thrilling thrilling
chest there in time scramble so anyway I
think we're going to have a lot of
thrilling chest today a lot of time
scrambles the players are starting to
file in uh with the Swiss it's kind of
fun because you kind of think you know
who's going to show up da but you never
really know who's gonna show up who's
gonna bounce in at the last second and
uh we're we're waiting to see which
players are doing that but all right
let's talk a little bit about Toronto
maybe some of the storylines that maybe
surprised fans I think at the top of the
list was probably Hikaru everyone
circles Hikaru usually is the name right
after Magnus Carlson da and of course
you you do that because you believe in
hikaro you've seen him do it so many
times but as we all know Toronto didn't
go hikaru's way it didn't and obviously
people forget that he's human I mean
yeah sometimes I question whether he's
human I feel like he's half cyborg half
human he chooses to be human on any
given day and I guess he chose to be
human in Toronto it was a tough run for
hikaro and I think people don't always
realize how thin the margins are it's
the same thing when people ask me what
are your candidates predictions
everyone's level is so close that it's
literally a tossup and that's actually
what makes these tournaments like the
chest ball Masters finals so exciting if
it was all cut dried and it was also
easy for Magnus then what would be the
Intrigue of watching the margins are
incredibly thin Danny and Wesley so he
he as we as we moved from hikaro that
was a guy who was all smiles until he
ran in to Magnus Carlson at the end but
you're right the margins are so small
what looks like a bad tournament for
someone might have just been literally a
couple moves here or there right and for
Wesley so a couple moves did go his way
for sure which allowed him to ultimately
get to the final against Magnus and uh
even though even though Carlson got it
done I think Wesley will continue to
be I I mean I predict Magnus Hikaru
Wesley I think those are household names
you kind of think will be there at the
end of the year you never really do know
because the field is just so tough and
so many young young stars on the rise
all the time but I feel like in that
rapid format especially Wesley tends to
thrive so I wasn't surprised that in the
end he was the last one to go down
against Magnus but uh but all right we
got players coming in here I'm I'm like
you I'm just kind of eagerly awaiting uh
awareness of of who's going to be in the
field but uh give me some of your
Darkhorse stories this year da we got
some time let's chat a little bit as we
get set for the games your thoughts on
maybe somebody who's a surprise pick to
be at our live finals at the end of the
year well um you're asking for a name
kind of like Dennis lazic which
absolutely nobody could predict last
year I mean pull every single chess fan
uh in existence how many people would
point to Dennis lavic being in Toronto
and quitting himself quite well
obviously he lost a lot of games what an
experience that was what a boost to
someone's chess career to just be around
those big guys as for this year Danny um
I I'm gonna have to take a bit of a
range shck in the sense that once I look
at the names that are playing in the
qualifier I'll be able to give you a
more reasoned response but let me give
you a more General response right now I
want to see representation from this
youngest Generation Um that has some
incredibly exciting players Andy
Woodward uh who stood out in The Puzzle
Battle Championship he just become a
grandmas maybe he's going to play
there's a young Turkish uh International
master who just scored his second GM
he's 12 years old uh he's very active on
chess.com he goes by the legend is back
3,100 Blitz I want to see uh him put his
uh chips into the center of the table so
this youngest generation Cena mahad from
Iran uh who's rapidly Rising through the
ranks the 12 and 13y olds I want to see
them score some upsets and play spoiler
to the top guys but I'll give you a more
concrete answer Danny as we start
looking at the games that would be
fascinating I think Dennis lvic being uh
as young as he was was already turning a
lot of heads if we get a 12 or 13y old
at a live finals we'll just make sure
that they're chaperon by a parent
that'll be don't get lost on the way to
the B Danny yeah all right well uh the
uh the format has had some small changes
overall the storyline is the same which
is we've got four amazing events that
are going to get us at least four
players into the live finals and the
rest of the spots will be filled via the
leaderboard that's the highlevel
explanation that you really need to
remember if you ever get lost along the
way or confused by some of the Minor
Details In The Format just remember that
really four events we've got winners
that are going to directly punch their
ticket and the leaderboard is going to
get us the rest of them and there's a
ton of cash up for prices but for a much
more detailed breakdown of everything
about the 2024 Champions chess tour
format as we get set for the players
filing in we're going to let our video
explainer take it
away the year-long Champions chess tour
consists of four main online events and
one live final each event will begin
with a playin tournament open to all
Grand Masters and top finishers from
qualifying events 69 players from the
playin will be joined on the second day
by the four qualifiers from the previous
Tour event match play with 73 players
will then determine placement across all
three divisions division play then
commences with 6 days of Double
Elimination Brackets the last player
standing are your winners the winner of
division 1 qualifies directly to the CCT
finals the winner of division 2 secures
a spot in division 1 at the next Tour
event while the winner of division 3 is
guaranteed at least a spot in division 2
in each each event players also ACR
points for the season long leaderboard
the final standings will decide who
joins our division one winners at the
year-end CCT live finals each regular
season event will feature a whopping
$300,000 prize pool while the final
eight players will battle it out for
their part in half a million dollars in
prizes at the final that's $1.7 million
up for grabs in the 2024 Champions chess
tour so tune in and watch all the action
as the best chess players in the world
compete to be crowned the next CCT
champion and we are in the playing stage
da that kicks things off every time we
do this thing we will kick off with a
playin it's a nine round Swiss with a
10minute plus 2 second per move time
control uh one small update that isn't
even mentioned in the video is the 10
minutes plus 2s second per move time
control is now the time control
throughout every stage of every
Champions chess Tour event so things
have gotten a little bit faster the top
69 will advance the division placement
with the top 11 directly punching their
ticket to division 1 those are some
interesting numbers I I admit and I see
people commenting on them 69 players
will advance because we have players who
already have spots that they've
qualified with via the rollover from the
previous season giving us some
continuity and some story lines and also
to make sure that there's something at
stake even at the last event of the Year
da and uh there you go there's someone
who knows there's a lot of steak what he
was eating I mean there wasn't much left
of it but he was he kept going at it it
it was a mango or something I don't even
know I know that he uh he put it down
because the games are underway we've got
a whole lot of them which is awesome and
um and yeah well Ali resua that's a big
name who we expect Maybe to be there
again he was in Toronto at the last live
finals we'll see if he can pull that off
we're going to put da on the spot make
him make him choose some other Dark
Horses everybody don't worry I won't I
won't let him get away with with not not
picking a couple maybe maybe some new
names there but I already have uh some
some names in mind but I'm going to
share them as we go along Danny I think
we're off game one is underway and
there's going to be some really easy
matchups for the top guys Ali RZA facing
Sam shankland that should be a walk over
iar Nakamura faces Armenian grandm hovan
gaboian another very very strong Blitz
and Rapid player so this is what I love
about the the CCT Danny there's no
walkover games there's no oh you're
facing a weak guy in round one these top
guys got to bring their aame from the
very first minute to the very last yeah
it is very similar to title Tuesday in
that you get you get a lot of these guys
who who don't always get an opportunity
to to swing at the kings of Chess right
and sometimes when this when they swing
they don't miss and uh you kind of
expect those household names to always
get it done but in Rapid and Blitz chess
when you've got really hungry very
talented players who maybe sometimes
don't get those invites to your tus
Steels or over theboard events just yet
in their career don't be surpris when
they show up and the uh and the upsets
start happening early and often but all
right we've got a game up it's Aaron
Nakamura as you said versus the talented
young young player here so what do you
know about this uh gabo on playing Black
yeah gabusan has been around for a while
very strong Blitz player um his fed
rating I think is yeah it's about 2580
he was well over 2600 at the peak of his
career very very dangerous player um and
I Hikaru has played him uh in in
head-to-head Blitz matches so I'm sure
Hikaru is taking him seriously but
already a really really good position
for hikaro Danny right out of the gates
this Knight on A5 is extremely misplaced
havanas is banking on this C file
counterplay T trying to double his Rooks
on the C file but I don't think it's
enough yeah and I admit uh gabusan isn't
young I was literally saying words as I
was looking at demetrion uh Demetri
Andre and Dennis lazic Ali Resa fuja
players that I do think or considered on
the younger side Vincent CER there's so
many so many strong players already in
the field but yeah uh gabusan is a very
strong Blitz player not not as young as
some of the other players in the field
hey now and he is I think he's my age
Danny okay well you know we're gonna
talk about that I mean you are you are
not as young as you once were da all
right yeah this is a great position for
Hikaru I don't even expect him to trade
that Bishop I expect him to wait B4 B4
B4 just wins a piece it wins a piece and
the game is over B4 ends the
game that's it and the reason is that
after B4 if you move the Knight to C4
the bishop hangs because you cut off the
the rook's protection and if you take on
D2 white can take on A5 with a Tempo
sort of an intereso attack on the queen
and ultimately black will lose a piece
so this one could be over fast yeah and
hikaro can't believe his luck B4 and the
game is over this was a huge blunder by
black this is literally resign time I
mean I suppose black can probably give
up the exchange Bishop takes D2 Knight
takes C2 Knight to C4 but this is not a
serious defensive resource Hikaru
wrapping it up right out of the
opening well do do you think if Bishop
takes D2 white won't just take
A5 oh that was kind of what I thought
was the simplest oh yeah and it's a
double attack on the queen no that's
just cut and dry that's over it's resign
time well I admit we both missed
something you didn't see ba5 and I
actually didn't even consider Knight
takes D2 but it doesn't matter because
Hikaru is going to win material in the
matter what I guess he could pick his
flavor okay he does indeed oh wow gaban
just sacks the queen No
need no need for the queen apparently
and I think it might be time to resign
now something tells me hikaro uh has the
technical ability to convert an extra
Queen a queen for a rook is usually
enough although I will say this is one
of those funny positions where black is
not going to resign right away due to
some dominance over the the access
points right when you get control over
the only open file it is an opposite
code Bishop Dynamic given the black and
control the DAR sares for a while yes
this is a win for sure for white but
there is there are stranger things have
happened right there are some crazy
things like if you trade here he's
saying I'm gonna get the D4 Square for
my Bishop oh wait truear has a plan look
at that all of what you're saying is
true black has the D4 Square the Rooks
are very strong there's one very minor
problem that no matter how you slice it
you're still down a queen yeah Bishop C2
Bishop B3 he's getting his Bishop around
to B3 and that is why Hikaru sacrificed
that pawn it's actually a positional
sacrifice with a long-term aim getting
his Bishop to B3 then once he activates
his queen that F7 Pawn at the end of the
line is going to be a major problem it's
actually super instructive from hikaro
it shows that in positions of where you
already have large material imbalances
what matters is targets you can gang up
on and the ability to increase your
initiative not the objective material
and so giving away that pawn to open up
that Bishop is actually massive and
it'll it'll ultimately prove this bishop
sort of a helpless bystander if white
can get attacking attacking ideas going
on the light Square so good stuff from
hikaro there do we do we let him finish
and let the crowd go wild obviously
hikaro Nakamura probably about to get
his first win of the 2024 Champions
chess tour or do we find another game
let's find another game I think after
Queen F4 uh it's it's decided I mean F7
and D6 will both hang Hikaru sacrificing
back The Exchange maybe not the
smoothest conversion but it's more than
sufficient we have so many other Marque
matchups we have obviously wesly so
Fabiano Carana faces the German
Grandmaster Dennis Wagner also a very
dangerous matchup by the way not easy at
all for
fabbiano yeah well we could go to Favi
or Wesley oi Resa peruja as you said
taking on Sam Shanklin is a bit of a
marquee match up as well and let's go
there yeah let's go there that's an
interesting position I'm going to I'm
going to call it up
and uh Sam Shanklin as white and what
looks to be a
Catalan typical of the Catalan white is
down a pawn but but with a lot of
pressure here against the queen side if
you look at the diagonal the C6 pawn and
mounting pressure given the tension on
the a file I'll go be honest the this
position I like white a lot and I think
the fact that the engine favors white
despite being down upon speaks a lot to
the initiative here yeah Sam shankland
is not to be overlooked he's one of
those dark horses uh who's improved his
Blitz ability in recent years I actually
think 10 plus two is a great time
control for Sam who has won a couple of
title Tuesdays obviously I'm rooting for
him personally I have a bias he's from
the Bay Area um I've known Sam
essentially since he started playing
chess fun fact Danny Sam Shanklin
learned the rules of Chess at something
like 10 or 11 years old which by modern
standards is almost unheard of and he's
a late bloomer he's almost entirely
self-taught and he's one of the hardest
workers that I know that guy works on
chess nonstop Sam is a really really
inspiring
story High Praise from you and I agree
with everything you said I've also known
Sam I'm I'm a little older than than him
and you so I've known him since he was
13 14 CU he was obsessed with chess and
getting good very very fast as he
started competing in his first Norm
events I remember the the Berkeley
International and the East Bay Masters
Sam oh yeah Sam came on strong and you
knew right away that he was that he was
uh he was going to get very good despite
starting late in the game um and all
right he's one of the most well-prepared
players on the planet too right in terms
of opening Theory Sam goes deep and uh
very very often getting good positions
out of out of the gate
so we'll see what he can do here this is
a a Cataline give me give me some da
magic here what Dynamics the C6 Pawn is
now completely
hanging when he's just taken it I mean I
was about to say why is two pawns down
now he's only one Pawn down and
basically that Queen on D4 is in the
crosshairs of The Rook on D1 so I think
if ala shifts his Rook over to C8 I
think Sam wants to play Bishop C3 and
attack the queen from two different
directions Bishop to C3 the queen is
probably going to drop back to A7 and
then maybe Sam just wants to recapture
the pawn on a A4 but it feels like Ali
res is out of the woods because Danny
after Bishop takes A4 first of all you
don't want a situation where your Fen
ketto Bishop is essentially outside of
the fen kto box because your king is
going to be a little bit Airy but also
if you look at the C file black has the
move Knight F6 to D5 black even has
Bishop B7 up to B4 uh disarming White's
Bishop pair so I actually think um Sam
might have either overlooked or
underestimated this queen Retreat all
the way back to A7 lovely move oza is in
the driver seat
now yeah fantastic analysis there D
really really good point about the
bishop no matter how much you might want
this Pawn exactly Sam Sam proves the
point the bishop cannot really turn its
back on the D5 Square in particular
because of this pin of the bishop but as
you said maybe bishop B4 is is Fu's next
move and the sooner he can trade off
some of these pieces he won't be as
cramped and ultimately black is already
already feeling a lot better you see the
computer kind of agrees with your
evaluation a slight Edge shifted to
Black given that white was a little bit
better earlier and wow look at this move
going for the B3 square that is a
forking problem you got to solve it Fork
Town population one Knight B3 is a huge
threat Sam has to move his Queen I would
guess Queen E3 can be considered trying
to keep the queen active he's played it
and maybe Ali Resa now will shift his
own Queen in order to unpin the C5 KN
maybe Queen to B8 intending Knight B3
and Bishop C5 so black definitely has
the initiative here at the same time
white still has the bishop pair and if
white can essentially stabilize the
situation and eventually get that knight
from A3 into the action Knight to C4
it's still uh very much a
fight it's funny I find the tactics in
some of these open Catalin to be just so
they're just not like other positions
like I'm always worried about some sort
of just awkward blunder or or tactical
consequence to where I put my pieces
when when the Bishops are are so
aggressive on the open diagonals I feel
like one side could blunder at any
moment and now here comes the Knight
yeah if you play Knight C4 there's
probably Knight to B3 which would hit
the rook and the Knight on
C4 so trying not to play Guess the move
here but just think bigger picture about
the position what is white doing to
solve to solve problems this B2 Pawn is
backward the A4 Pawn keeps it there
if you're white how are you what is the
plan you're looking for here it's very
hard to come up with something because
black essentially has no targets black
has no weaknesses so you're just kind of
shuffling your pieces um trying to make
incremental improvements that's exactly
what Sam is doing Knight to C2 he's
heading for D4 with his Knight that C6
square is one of the weaknesses within
Black's territory so I actually really
like this move he wants to go Knight D4
and then Knight C6 or maybe even Knight
F5 uh in some situations targeting that
undefended Bishop on E7 so yeah engine
is giving an advantage for black but ala
I think has to be very very precise here
to contain wh's
activity both players now under five
minutes if you're just tuning in it's
the 2024 Champions chess tour we've
kicked off we're here we are in here as
candy would say this is the plan by the
way again hiar Nakamura as you can see
already got a dub looks like vid GUI
just joined him as a couple of big names
get their first wins and the 2024
campaign but uh you've got Fabiana
Carana you've got Wesley so you've got
leavon aronian you've got a mean Tava
toai you've got Vincent C I'm just
looking at a list here you can obviously
follow the games yourself if you go to
chess.com
events um and we we're we're just
getting started so sorry Don you just
wanted to remind everybody where they
were in case they got here
accidentally absolutely well if you got
here accidentally then you should stay
here um you will not be able to leave
just because some of these match
matchups are so mouthwatering and this
is just round one um I'm also looking at
Alexander donchenko probably fresh off
the plane uh back from Tod steel and
already back at work playing uh the CCT
qualifiers which I think is a good thing
the players who've just played a
classical tournament are going to be in
calculation mode they're going to be in
pretty good form most of the time I'm
also curious into Fabiano caran and how
he's doing maybe we can check into Fabby
just really really quickly Danny yeah
let's do it
I've got you I've got you boo right here
we've got Fabi on Carana
now okay yeah he's doing really really
well here it's a locked position but E4
E4 is
coming and Black's position threatens to
fall apart here after E4
happens loving how quickly we're able to
get the players on camera too you see
Fabby coming to us from some random
hotel room wherever he is in the world
usually um but um I I assume that's
hotel that's Hotel pictures and art
behind him I could be wrong apologies if
it's someone's
home um all right it's a closed position
as you said E4 is a move that white
would love to play but the moment you do
it D4 is a problem right so
yes interesting the
U apparently Bishop to
G4 missed an
opportunity hm I mean Fabby just trying
to I think bleed some of Black's clock I
think now is the time for E4 now that
the Knight has moved away from G8 from
E7 to G Dennis Wagner is really Flirting
With Disaster here E4 D takes E4 but
Fabby just not deciding it again to
find checking with the computer it was
E4 both times it was E4 instead of
Bishop G4 and it was E4 again instead of
King G2 that the computer wants to play
Fabiano does finally do it I guess in
Fabi in fa's
defense how was black ever going to stop
e it wasn't going anywhere and he
eventually does blow things open and
queen G6 check and queen takes H6 Dennis
Wagner just forgot about the G6 square
look at Fabby this is just textbook
conversion the H6 Pawn Falls with check
okay just be very careful because black
threatens E5 Danny it's very possible
the blunder the queen here so Queen G6
just Evacuate the queen get it out of H6
and Black's position has completely
Fallen apart at the
seams it's funny my initial thought was
that E4 but it doesn't work of E5 E5 and
white loses the queen
unbelievable my first commentator curse
of the Year someone
Mark oh my gosh he
does Fabby has to give up his Queen for
two Rooks it's not over it's actually
not over Knight takes D6 and queen takes
D6 white is still more or less in the
game but what a
turnaround yeah literally I was going to
say that 94 was my first thought but you
have to see that E5 Works anyway because
the queen is still trapped and before I
could even get the words out of my mouth
Bobby blunders into
it oh my God he does still have an
advantage on the clock as well though
now remember it's a two second increment
so any advantage on the board especially
at this level is usually converted when
you have that extra time added back with
every move so so not a good start here
for Fabiana we'll see if he can see if
he can write the ship and maybe somehow
get this one get this one anyway well
yeah Queen takes D6 only move he has to
at least get something for the queen
queen takes E5 Rook E2 maybe try to get
your Rooks active I mean this game could
turn around again Black's King is very
weak Danny maybe Fabu could Advance his
H Pawn up to H6 and try to create the
preconditions for a Checkmate or an
attack down the eighth rank so Dennis
Wagner still has a lot of work to do
Rook to D7 is met with Knight F6 that is
a nasty shot the bishop on G4 will hang
in that line but Fabby with his back
against the wall here he needs to
generate chances and get Dennis's clock
Whittle it down even further if he wants
any realistic chances to save the game
well he may have to go for something
like Rook D7 anyway because the thing
about Queen to C5 is if you don't do
anything as white I think I'm going to
start pushing the C Pawn and the moment
that becomes a problem your Rooks won't
have the luxury of coordinating on the
seventh rank or on any kind of open file
because they're they're worried about
the cwn so yeah this is one one move
that seemed like uh seemed like a great
idea to put the Knight on e4 and attack
The
Rook a huge Wonder from Fabiano although
I have a weird feeling that he uh that
he might still be able to get this one I
know right now the advantage favors
black big time but
opposite code Bishop Dynamic da the B
Pawn is also passed and in time pressure
that's when blunders happen here if
those Rooks get free yes black has to be
very careful when to push C2 I don't
like the move G4 at all that square
belonged to the Knight and Knight G4 was
a big idea in a lot of these positions
to gang up on the F2 square and look at
B6 by Fabby this was overlooked by
Dennis and this is what the top guys do
they never die now Queen takes B6 will
drop the bishop on E7 white will
probably be better now suddenly Dennis
Wagner with a minute on his clock total
turnaround once again and I think Fabby
is now uh probably okay Bishop D6 runs
into Rook E6 there's all sorts of forks
that the Rooks can engineer on blacks
minor pieces oh this is anybody's game
but I like that time Advantage agreed
agreed two seconds is enough to win and
convert making sure that the POS the
position on the board should decide most
results but it's not enough to be
excited about right if you get under 5
Seconds 2 seconds doesn't really bring a
lot of relief so uh the the the perfect
amount of drama there with the two
second increments C2 I think white will
just play Rook C1 and I think that's a
good trade for Fabby if the C Pawn is
traded for the B Pawn not that he
doesn't want more but even if that
happens then the Rooks can really start
to get nasty over here against the king
and you feel like in time pressure black
is likely to to make a mistake and the
bishop on a is such a def strong
defensive piece it's preventing any
checks to the white king it's
controlling monopolizing that diagonal
15 seconds for Dennis Wagner Bishop to
D6 good move keeping his Bishop Alive
Now Rook takes C2 no Fab's gonna push B7
he's playing for the win Fabby wants
more although that did give up the
diagonal what an awkward thing to do to
block your own Bishop
but yeah now he loses H5
but the bishop on D6 is holding White's
B7 Pawn but if white plays Rook takes C2
and Rook C8 White's going to start
making progress I think Fab's gonna win
this game 5 seconds for Dennis how do
you figure anything out in a position
this chaotic with no time on the clock
but he's found a way to hold you made a
really good point that that move Pawn G4
was such a mistake really preventing all
the things black would love to do the
way the queen and Knight work together
is often key to outplaying the Rooks in
that kind of awkward material balance
but that Knight doesn't have any good
squares makes it really hard for for
Wagner here okay Knight E4 and he's
blundered B8 equals Queen and Rook to E2
picks off the Knight but he plays Rook
E2 First bishop B8 wrong move
order although it it makes sense though
because it's oh two second no he he
moved with moved apparently with 22
seconds oh my
God
that's actually that's actually a huge
Fine By the way speaking of a move with
no time on the clock it threatens Queen
takes G3 with check the F2 Pawn is
pinned wow that's why ba Queen was
actually the key move for f that he
didn't play
first wow and now King G2 there still
Bishop takes F2 and suddenly the G3 Pawn
is going to fall I mean white could get
checkmated here but with two seconds on
Dennis Wagner's clock can Fabby find a
way to confuse him he's a move
oh oh Rook F2 KN F2 should be a draw oh
my gosh what in the world going on
here Rook e three maybe maybe get a
queen and get the bishop
back maybe suddenly you're much more
worried about White's King though
because the OBS code Bishop yeah he does
go for it this is going to be a very
tough mating net but now black should be
able to move relatively fast he's got 5
seconds on his clock which seems like a
great luxury I don't know what Bishop B4
is all about why is he giving up the G4
Pawn for no reason and now Fab's got
winning chances
again yeah that didn't make a lot of
sense and the Rooks are going to be so
nice and easy to coordinate here with no
real worries about any weaknesses put
the bishop on F3 and get the Rooks
working together against the black king
in fact Bobby does that I like
it now Rook F2 set up the threat of a
discovered check Dennis Vagner has built
up 8 seconds on his clock he's moving
fast
black should not lose this game unless
he blunders his queen or unless he
blunders some sort of mating net but the
king is in the open board the King has a
lot of Escape squares Bishop to C5 now
if you're Fabiano you're not out of the
woods either watch out a check on G1
could be really really nasty Bishop E4 K
Fearless Fearless play by Dennis I
think's gonna have to settle on a draw I
think allowing allowing this idea not
playing your Rook F2 was a huge mistake
no he wants more but this G5 such a
risky
move Rook F5 maybe I don't know I'm just
going to suggest moves he does go for it
but it's not
enough yeah Queen G5 Bishop F5 I would
try I would try Bishop F5 oh my gosh
what a move laughing in the face of
danger right
now and Dennis Wagner only moves to hold
the game 20 seconds walk the king up to
G3 he's gonna walk the king up to G3 no
he
doesn't Okay Bishop E2 apparently white
is winning after Bishop
E2 Bishop E2 and what's the idea I have
no
idea I have no idea I would I would lose
this position with either color I think
that that goes without saying no no no
one needs to doubt that okay now Rook G6
King H7 anybody could get mated here I
think it's a Perpetual check he gives up
the
awn but but black wants more if if the
black queen goes to G5 how do you stop
Queen H4 oh my gosh this is my God wild
action the a pawn is hanging Danny black
can play Queen takes A4 but Dennis is
not even thinking about that pawn queen
D3 Queen
E1 oh my gosh oh my gosh W white is
suddenly
defending yeah white is gonna be lucky
if he doesn't get mated the queen and
the dark squares are a problem for that
white king Bishop to D4 his Queen BL
Rook H3 and Bishop F3 wins the queen oh
oh my gosh and Danny Dennis was winning
there for a brief instant he had a fork
against D White's rook and Bishop but he
missed it and now he blunders his Queen
Fabby can't believe it Fabby got away
with one there he'll have time to look
at it in a moment I'm sure he'll go back
and be like what in the world was 94
that was a blunder but that was the
definition of stealing a Victory from
the jaws of defeat Fabiano Carana the
top rated American gets the job done and
uh he like Kar Nakamura as you can see
and lania Dominguez Perez speaking of
two countrymen starts off his 2024
Champions chest tour with a dub oh my
gosh that was about as as complicated as
our format da I'm GNA tell you what that
had me on the edge of my seat I I would
have lost that position with either
color five times over I mean 87 moves
both sides should have lost that game
incredible action E5 to trap White's
Queen and this is typical of 2700 chest
they never die you can blunder your
queen and they will still find a way to
keep the game going just to keep
fighting one move at a
time what a heartbreaker for the German
grandmas but that's just life um that
that's just the experience playing Super
GMS you got to be you got to come to
terms with that that's just what
happens oh man that was crazy we are
underway here is round two already
getting in it getting in it we are on it
Benjamin Bach taking on hikaro Nakamura
let's get to it no rest for the weary
here uh couple of streamers I think
they're probably both streaming I know
Hikaru is I didn't see if Bach was also
streaming
his his uh his campaign
today if not even if he's not can go
follow okay he is you can go you can go
give his give his channel a follow if
you're a fan of our many streamers oh
look at this bishop B4 Che we're going
to get some kind of old old queens
Indian bogos no we're back to a reg Goen
qgd
transposition but a very strange one
with a knight on D2 typically obviously
you get White's Knight on C3 in these
types of positions M Benjamin Bach is
very positional he likes these kg D4
openings but he's got to be a little bit
careful already burning quite a bit of
time I think for newer players Danny we
should point out Queen A4 check he's
played the move but the point is not to
win Black's Bishop yep the point is to
force the Knight to C6 in front of the C
Pawn because typically in these Queen
Pawn Le openings where you have the
furthest Advanced Pawn as a queen Pawn
you usually want the flexibility of a c
Pawn either to reinforce that protection
or to challenge with C5 typically a
knight in front of your cwn is against
as we would say against good Soviet
chess School principles right I know a
guy who wrote A positional chess book
when he was only like 12 years old you
know that guy da I've heard I've heard
his name spread around a couple times I
don't think I want to would want
anything to do with him though you
know it's actually a phenomenal book you
don't get enough credit for the fact
that you wrote a book before you could
literally see over the table you were
sitting on a phone book and you were
writing a book it was crazy um I was
sitting on my own book so I could see
the board you were sitting on your own
book which is why you had to write it
you know that makes sense right it
served two purposes but seriously uh da
is a is a very underrated positional
chess teacher if you don't know but I'm
stealing his Thunder by saying this is
the whole point of Queen A4 check not
that you were going to win the piece but
to make Black's Queen side a little
dysfunctional and then and then black
has to kind of work through these issues
later on yeah and you can see hiar
dropping his Bishop back to D6 he's
basically saying listen now if I can't
push my C pawn and well he can't because
it's illegal um then maybe he'll he'll
want to push his E Pawn the other Big
Pawn break in this type of position is
E6 E5 and that will create total
pandemonium in the center for example
Bishop to D3 here maybe black can
consider pushing E5 I mean there's a ton
of tactics there white goes C5 Black
Goes
E4 and so I mean you have to calculate
this uh if you're both sides actually
the computer quite likes this for black
because white yeah white drops a piece
black drops a piece how do you evaluate
a position like this but this is exactly
what you want if you're Hikaru Nakamura
trying to play for a win with the black
pieces against someone as solid as
Benjamin Buck you want to create these
kind of tactics out of the opening yeah
no great great stuff there and and I
love that you highlighted the purpose of
Bishop D6 because we obviously
highlighted the problems with a knight
being in front of a CA Pawn it's sort of
dysfunctional to Traditional Queen
Gambit plans but it does support E5 as
the bishop does and so you don't have to
settle on a Queen's Gambit structure as
da pointed out and if hararo gets his
way he won't be settling he'll be
breaking through although now we have
action Bach has played Queen to C2 and
here goes Hikaru not giving up on his
dreams to change the center Pawn
structure with E5 at some
point and E5 C takes D5 might have
dropped that H7 Pawn which is why hikaro
now pushes H6 but he's taking his time
he's not rushing uh this Pawn break E5
maybe it's time for Benjamin to push C5
and try to punish iaro for kind of Dilly
dallying okay no he castles and there it
is there's E5 and we're gonna get
fireworks in the center in this game
well it's funny because maybe maybe
that's why C5 was the most popular move
earlier you once The Rook had moved if
White had pushed the bishop actually had
a safe retreating Square so it wasn't as
attractive but anyway okay not an expert
in the theory here what I do know is as
Don you said we're about to get
fireworks the center has been blown open
and uh why does the computer like white
here it's interesting because
instinctively da I feel like black is
doing just fine and it if anything is a
little bit better developed because that
Bishop will join the game soon whereas
white Stark Square Bishop is still a
little bit away from developing so teach
me Teach me Teach what's going on here
there there's a tactical detail if white
plays the move Bishop to E4 which is
kind of a weird looking move and
generally Bishop E4 is always met with
Bishop to E6 with Bishop E6 in this
particular instance I think succumbs to
Bishop takes Knight Bishop takes Knight
E4 and suddenly black drops a minor
piece Bishop to E6 D5 is a fork and if
black does not play Bishop E6 um if
black drops the Knight away from D5 well
then its counterpart on C6 is going to
get under Fire Bishop takes C6 BC okay
it's not that bad for black but even D
takes E5 trade everything on E5 and okay
Black's got a bad structure White's got
a superiority in the center so I think
this is the key to the kingdom for
Benjamin Bach but
instead he has played a different move
he's played the more straightforward D
takes E5 okay nothing wrong with that I
think he's gonna trade on E5 Danny he's
gonna bring his other Knight over to F3
he's gonna Park his Rook on D1 and I
still think that white has a small edge
here but that doesn't tell us anything
necessarily about how the game is going
to go nice find there and and it is
interesting when sometimes it looks like
the positional features are favoring one
side black got what he wanted broke open
the center pushed the E5 Pawn but the
computer saying there was something had
me had me ask and you pointed out that
it was this idea of Bishop E4 that Bach
also didn't didn't necessarily find
although as you said white probably
still a little bit better but not nearly
what what maybe he could have
gotten I would say from a practical
perspective even if even if the computer
thinks White's a little better here now
you look at the clock hiar up almost 3
minutes black has sort of objectively
gotten what he was striving to do change
the center with E5 so so I'm kind of
like I'm Camp you know hikaro here on
this position as far as the direction of
the game although I would point out that
after Bishop to F6 Rook to D1 concretely
black has a bit of a hard time uh
evacuating that knight from the center
because the Knight on D5 is kind of
caught in the crossfire obviously the
white Rook is x-raying the black queen
and there's constantly this idea of
Bishop D3 delivering a check on H7 which
obviously could be really good as a
discovered attack against the queen but
it could also be really good as a way of
opening up a kind of direct pressure
against the Knight which is why hear
Nakamura is thinking before playing
Bishop F6 and I'm really curious how
he's going to handle this position C6
okay but now E4 E4 is very very
dangerous because if the Knight moves
white has E5 and Bishop H7 so wait a
second hiar will have to pull out some
magic here in order to save a minor
piece and it's he got what's he got up
his sleep because that's just
straightforward good oldfashioned family
fun there those are just tactics and I'm
I'm highlighting as da is spitting
spitting out sweet sweet calculation I'm
just going to show it again the whole
point is this tactic is not only a
threat on the bishop but renews that
Bishop H7 check as da already pointed
out
so so what is Hikaru going to do
apparently B5 is essentially the only
move here counterattacking White's
Knight but that's a huge positional
concession because then the C6 Pawn is
going to be a major weakness white can
just drop the Knight back to E3 in that
case hearo is suddenly quite a bit worse
here uh let me tell you this is trouble
for black if he can even get out of the
immediate trouble here with the Knight
on D5 he needs to save his piece and
he's played it yeah well
he finds the only tactical resource
right go figure Hikaru tends to do that
but I I agree this is still this is
still a big problem the Knight can just
go to E3 and invite a trade you could
you could switch gears and just go
positional here not even looking for
tactics and the best move on the board
da is Pawn B5 to B7 that's the best move
right and he can't iaro can't do that
pawns don't go backwards kids so so this
is a problem look for look for some
streamer on streamer crime here right
now if bot can can can put some pressure
on on Hikaru yeah but there's also ways
that white can blunder if you take the
Knight on D5 you you don't have to show
this but there's back rank problems that
white could experience if you just
gobble up all of the pawns on C4 and on
D5 black could play Queen takes D5 at
the end of the line um and Benjamin
obviously has to be very careful his
Rooks are not connected and he's doing
the right thing taking his time although
he is down to four and a half minutes
you know how good Hikaru is at putting
pressure on on clocks uh in any time
control 10 plus two seems very generous
but your clock starts to dwindle you
start getting nervous and Benjamin Bach
he will he has a very important decision
to make I'm seeing a draw there in Kill
alexenko game against Hans nean Wesley
so faces Abby Manu M another huge
matchup yep I'm looking over there you
already saw I was distracted so you
started calling it out Fabiano was
taking on Vladimir
mikov uh
Yu young y vamir iich so many other act
so many other
actions I I needed I needed a little
more caffeine this morning apparently um
so many so a lot of action going on so
many other games thanks Dan glad you're
with us um all right I actually am GNA
show that okay never mind I'm not
anymore he played 93 which was the
smartest thing to do um the computer's
favorite move and as we said Hikari was
now strapped with that positional
weakness that was necess to save his
night but there were back ring tactics I
wanted to show them but we're going to
let it go and instead let's let's
quickly look at another game we might
come back to this one if Bach continues
to press his Advantage but I want to
check out Wesley so ABI Manu
Mishra oh you've got the runner up from
Toronto lost only to Magnus Carlson at
the previous year's Champions chess Tor
finals taking on a young guy who uh well
if he's not a household name you know
yet you should get used to it ABI Manu
Mishra
broke the world record for youngest
Grandmaster ever and continues to just
have his uh his stock is uh is
rising oh his talk is certainly rising
at this point abanu Mishra is
essentially a household name for most
chess fans who who have been around the
Chess World for longer than a couple of
months he's I think over 2600 fet a
definitely super GM material and I mean
I don't know how old he is right now I
think he's 14 or 15 but it's just crazy
when you think about how much younger
these top chess players are becoming um
and how mat sure his playing style
already is at his age and if you look at
this position I'm actually not totally
sure what's going on but I do see that
black has this Pawn on D3 black is
threatening Knight takes E4 I guess
Wesley can chase the Knight away from B4
with a move A3 but it's getting very
very dicey here I guess A3 Knight C6
and then the queen attacks the Knight on
A4
laterally a discovered threat just to
point that out after A3 if the Knight
moves black is hitting both the Knight
and the pawn on
e4 but yet the computer
somehow thinks that white has an edge
here but it might be one of those
positions with an only move Wesley does
choose A3 but what happens on just
Knight to C6 I guess you can play Knight
to C5 Knight to C okay yeah and that's
what he finds and we're going to get a
Liquidation in the center Knight takes
E4 and at a minimum Wesley can play
Queen takes D3 and get into a slightly
better end game where he's got a smidge
of an advantage just because of the
bishop um being a superior piece in the
open board but I think bman should be
able to hold uh to hold the draw here
Knight takes okay yeah Queen takes D3
we're going to get Queen takes D3 Bishop
takes D3
should be a draw but you know how good
Wesley is at pressing and squeezing out
you know these tiny advantages
particularly when his opponent's clock
starts to dwindle yep yep a great town
yep yep yep um yeah you highlighted the
bishop has a small advantage over the
knight in these open Center end games
but often the Knight tries to sort of
equalize that Dynamic by by being
centralized so if a knight can find a
safe and Powerful Central Square where
it where it exerts a bunch of threats
and tactics often that can make up but
if you don't do that here's the thing
Wesley's gonna play a move like Bishop
E4 yep put pressure over here The Rook
is GNA find a file either double or even
D1 and it's easy for someone like da to
say that black should be able to hold
once again I would probably lose this
position for both sides and the point is
Wesley Wesley is going to have just
enough that that clock is going to go
from two minutes and 15 seconds to 15
seconds da and the position is going to
be very similar Bishop before us coming
you called it and black has his work cut
out for him I think abanu should be able
to hold uh maybe a kg move like Rook to
D2 trying to get active right peace
activity uh is the typical piece of
advice that you get when you're under
pressure in the end game you have to get
active you have to create active
counterplay but Rook D2 B4 to my eyes
it's one of those positions where yeah
computer's going to give something like2
um and you don't really think anything
of it but it's actually a lot more
unpleasant in in in practice than it is
on paper so maybe B4 The Rook from D2
could swing over to A2 and start
harassing white um start harassing that
A3 pawn and then you have to find the
right opportunity to get your knight
active Knight C6 can jump into D4 but if
you do it prematurely then obviously you
give away the B7 Pawn so still a lot of
questions left to answer for the young
grandmas from New
Jersey agreed with everything you said
and again just to highlight how hard it
is let's say even if black plays a move
like Rook A2 just to show it Wesley can
play I don't even know if this is best
but let's just say Rook C3 you just back
up the rook and this really highlights
that the bishop is flexing on the Knight
the B7 Pawn is a weakness on a light
square and if you give white more moves
white will get another piece into the
game and at some point you will see a
conversion opportunity where might white
might take the chance to give up the
bishop in order to have an extra pawn
and even that Rook ending if you have a
pass Pawn is not it's not so simple to
hold right if somehow white is the only
one with a Pawn on the queen side at the
end of a of a long exchange so so this
is this is a nightmare and if you're
abian Mish you only have a minute 15
seconds to figure it out it's literally
a nightmare I mean that night yeah
doesn't have all that many prospects as
The Rook comes over to D1 and Wesley so
Contin to tighten the screws Rook takes
a and black get away with it I love that
move Rook D1 because his plan on Rook
takes A3 is not to trade but to play
Rook D7 he's going all in for the
initiative and for pressure such a hard
thing to solve when you don't have a lot
of time on the clock and we should also
back into the hikaro game at some point
oh yeah okay good good call so excited
no I was getting excited about the
technical the technical end game the
chess player in me is coming out I
forget I have a job do which is remind
everybody they are watching the 2024
Champions chess tour we're underway and
this is the first day of the playin
stage and uh but okay I say we go back
yeah okay I think Wesley is gonna get
this dub Hikaru somehow tricked Bach oh
he's winning okay he now has a queen for
the rook and
Bishop well we don't know what happened
but this looks like it should be a win
for Mr Nakamura yeah sorry I thought
that this was going to be a more
exciting time screen scramble but it's
not even it's a one-sided time scramble
Karo has like an hour on his clock
Benjamin has 10 seconds and he's down to
Queen okay I apologize um I thought this
was going to be more
interesting this is you have nothing to
apologize forever and we got we got
9,000 of you with us here on Twitch I'm
checking on YouTube We Love You 9 almost
the exact same number on Twitch and
YouTube That's auspicious as uh as my
aunt would say very auspicious anyway um
but we uh we could go to a different
game we don't have to go back to the
endgame conversion of Wesley so versus
ABI Manu mistra if you have a different
one in mind a lot of exciting action
underway um I see some interesting names
Peter Sidler winning his game we could
check out alira fua um over on board
three um he is playing a very exciting
young Indian Grandmaster Barat sub Manan
very dangerous player um who I think has
made a name for himself in recent open
tournaments and look at this position
white is down in exchange change but
alza has massive piece activity with
just powerful minor pieces in the center
he wants to drop his Bishop back to D5
and deliver a devastating Fork on F7 I
have no idea what the evaluation of this
position actually
is this is one of those positions that
you feel like you get in a daily puzzle
or puzzle rush there's some sort of like
Knight G6 and Rook to the H file
Checkmate or something like that it
doesn't work but this this along with
the threat you already pointed out which
is that the moment this bishop moves the
Knight comes to F7 and even if it's not
a fork da it's a forking problem here
for the King this is this is a real
nightmare when you've got discovered
checks and and so again maybe the
computer says Ah 50/50 doesn't do
anything but an injustice to how complex
this position is um Knight I think take
yeah just take the
pawn okay now black could try to
Checkmate white by the way the move to
C3 I mean we're kind of sleeping on the
the lack of safety that white king is
experiencing there are no pawns around
the white King instead Knight to C7 also
a good move taking the D5 square away
from White's Bishop I I'm actually not
sure who's playing for a win here
obviously we're all biased in O R's
favor because he's the higher rated
player and we're so used to him winning
these types of scrambles but yeah I'm
actually not sure that White's the one
who's feeling comfortable here might be
black I completely agree with you to the
point where if I was white I would
probably play either King G3 or King
okay he actually does it I I really like
that move because from a practical
perspective this was the smartest thing
to do to get the king out of a mating
net and try to get yourself into a
mutual time scramble where maybe Black's
King is more likely to walk into a
blunder so this was a good move from mly
Resa now he'll Retreat the bishop maybe
where I don't know it's very very hard
to find a square black is threatening
the move Rook to C5 Rook to C5 is a huge
threat because it hits the Knight and
the Knight has nowhere to go the bishop
will also hang so alyza G5 okay what
does he want against Rook to C5 I think
he wants King
F4 but then black can already cash in
his chips with Rook takes C5 although in
that ensuing position Danny White's
going to be so active and white will
potentially have two two pawns for the
piece that I'm actually not sure that
white is worse here I don't think he is
I I actually wonder if Ali Resa just
missed your Rook C5 move because now
that he's taking time that's just look
at look at the clock management right
sometimes that's revealing in that would
you really now be spending 15 seconds on
an only move in the position King of4 to
guard the
Knight if you didn't see if you if you
saw Rook C5 I don't know he's about to
get down to 30 seconds wow he plays
Bishop D5 okay but that's a little
panicky and now black is definitely in
the driver's seat alza has to find the
right Square for his Knight Knight C6
though does Knight C6 win back the
exchange well black has a check on D3
it's getting dicey it's getting spicy
and I think oi Reza's uh suddenly very
much on the defensive here maybe King F4
can be tried here by white and also look
at the time situation he's under 30
seconds black still with an entire
minute on his clock Rook D4 check and
he's going to drop the a I think he I
wonder if he just missed that because if
you walk up to F5 is it even worse some
sort of
double check and then the Knight on E5
ends up being lost at the end of the
line you're right you're absolutely
right King F5 loses the game alza has to
drop back to E3 now he's completely
losing I think he missed that I think
two two King advances missed by Ali Resa
both King of4 and King of5 here this
position was really tricky to handle but
wait a second he's not
done okay it's not over
yet the Knight is coming in to one of
these squares that might be just enough
to at least hold a
draw yes especially if black plays Rook
takes H3 which is actually wrong because
of the move Knight to H6 check not
Knight F6 check but Knight to H6 check
and the King can't slink away into the
corner because of Knight F7 with a fork
yeah so suddenly Resa managing to create
chances will he hold the draw
here all right oh 10 seconds for oi Rea
less than 30
no three seconds okay wow Knight H6 he's
threatening the fork on
F7 this is this is not out of blunder
territory for either player D don't be
surprised if if if the young player from
India yet a another young Superstar on
the rise from India uh how many do they
have over there quite I thinka I think
goza has something like a fortress I
think black simply cannot make progress
ala has found an amazing square on H5
for his King and now he's just going to
shuffle King G4 King H5 King G4 and I
think maybe he's playing for a win who
knows wait maybe he wants more the
Knight comes F6 there's a mating net on
H7 wait what oh he's got Rook B7 I'm
like oh my gosh what did he just do okay
but this is terrifying Rook A8 Rook B8
is going to be a repetition of moves
yeah and that that'll probably be where
the game ends right there black is
thinking about it but there's nothing
that he can do other than make a
draw suban is going to say well I uh I
what no Rez is going for
it wow black is panicking five seconds
the okay now now we uh now we have a
rook ending that should be should be
held wow welcome to the big leagues kid
you never thought Oli resid would be the
uh the older the older man in a in a in
in a matchup but here he is doing
everything he can to push the young
player from India to the brink but
ultimately it does end in peace where
does that put us in terms of the round
Wesley so also Drew Mishra so shout out
to Ali Manu da he did hold that end game
yep he held that end game very
impressive endgame technique it'san Buck
losing to Vincent kimer we still have a
game going between SRA and the Spanish
GM Alvar Alonso Roso and looks like Alex
San will suffer a big upset at the hands
of the young Spanish GM this is a big
upset we know how much of a favorite
Alexis SRA is in all of these online
events but here suffering an early loss
of the white pieces he's getting crushed
here and he loses and it's over he loses
and uh There You Go Spanish grandm Alvar
Alonso roselli Rell Rell am I saying
that right call me out call me out on
camera I'm not really buying what what
you're what you're selling Danny LOL LOL
um all right we do have another game
still going though wait no that was from
the previous round no it is still going
we've got a king and pawn ending the
kind they write books about is this an
opposition fantasy world what is going
on just a draw apparently white was
white was winning and now it's a draw
black clearly has the opposition
now okay King B7 and there's nothing to
do but apparently a couple of moves ago
White had a winning move I wonder what
it was was it no it wasn't to sacrific
the pawn I'm actually not sure what it
was but either way Ramen man looking
back real quick it just ended in a draw
I'm fascinated it was it was right here
it was
shouldering he just should have kept
going he played King C4 instead of King
C5 which doesn't even make any
sense King C5 King D7 King B6
yeah you you just
shoulder like I like I said at the start
an opposition fantasy world if the pawn
goes to E6 you fully flanked him and
you're just going to win pushing the
king over and if he goes back King to C6
and the same thing lovely King f8 E6
yeah E6 you go back to King to D6 and
black is eventually in zwang so really
interesting just a single it was it was
actually right when we joined D like
white was winning and played King to C4
and just like that you lost your chance
to flank and to ultimately gain space
with irregular
opposition yeah it's actually
illustrates that opposition is not a
Dogma because white played King C4
technically that does occupy the
diagonal opposition but you don't just
want to indiscriminately occupy the
opposition whenever you get a chance to
do that actually Global King position is
better is more important than opposition
in many situations King C5 would have
been the way to score a victory and it
is a draw in the end good Save By seter
Ramen counting his lucky stars global
global King position
gks check your gks right that's that's
the more important fact I actually
really love that I'm gonna I'm going to
steal that on the on the rare occasion
that I still give a private chess lesson
here and there but I think I think I
always taught my students that yes this
is opposition but you have to ask
yourself what Square are you trying to
obtain with the opposition and often if
that square is already available and
there's no way for your opponent to
respond in opposition it actually often
makes sense to be more aggressive rather
than as you said dogmatically take the
diagonal opposition and in this case
make no progress so what an instructive
little King and pun ending for our uh
for our more studious viewers out there
welcome in it's now round three and we
have more action action's the word of
the day apparently man this is a this is
a a game a matchup that we see almost
every title Tuesday of course my good
friend Alexander bortnik um always does
really really well in these types of
events and I think he has what it takes
to defeat yukar Nakamura he's upset him
many many times in title Tuesday of
course Yaro is still very much the
favorite uh in this matchup but bortnik
is one of those Darkhorse players that
when he's in good form uh he can compete
with any of the top guys any day of the
week 100% especially in Rapid Blitz
bullet time controls right bortnik
bortnik strong when we first uh saw him
burst on the scene in the bullet chest
Championship a few years ago at least as
far as when he first got my attention I
was like what is going on with this guy
beating the best players in the world in
just about every time scramble he had
and uh but yeah he's not just a bullet
specialist bortnik is a monster and uh
here we've
got both sides I feel like are kind of
thinking about what kind of obscure
weird Queens Pawn trow ski verasa weird
jababa kind of thing am I trying to do
here yeah this is like a million
transpositions and now I think the
opening that this most resembles is
probably a Carl's bed structure of a
Queens gamma declined but black will
probably try to go C7 C5 in one Fell
Swoop we're probably going to see Knight
B to D7 Castle's King side hiar will
bring his Knight out to E2 so finally
um this started out as a trow but we're
going to get a more conventional
structure and we see Sasha bringing his
Pawn up to C5 challenging white central
control and this is going to be a really
really interesting Rich uh strategic
middle
game I I always like black in these
positions at when when white has
committed both F3 and E3 and tell me if
I'm wrong I guess I look at the tension
between the pawns and I really prefer
black because if white ever makes this
exchange the E3 Pawn just feels even
weaker on this open file and being left
behind and that and black is black is
kind of free to just keep building up on
this E Pawn because white can never play
the uh as we said the the the move back
to back to F2 to guard the pawn yeah and
black black is already controlling the
E4 breakthrough so what is it about this
structure where white is just fine and
everything I said doesn't matter no
you're absolutely right I think it's um
it's true that um F3 to F2 would be an
amazing move but he car is actually
taking his time here and I wonder what
he's thinking about because Knight G to
E2 is pretty much an automatic
developing move maybe he's flirting with
the idea of Knight to
H3 um although that's not an idea that
you see every day in a position like
this and after black plays the move
Knight to C6 obviously the D4 Pawn is
going to be caught under some pressure
so that's actually why you want your
knight on E2 you want to reinforce the
pawn on D4 but hekaru taking quite a
chunk of time here trying to get his
bearings and I still haven't gotten my
bearings in this position it's a very
very complicated one
y okay well I I I agree everything you
said it's complicated I think black's
plans are a little easier to follow
through with at this point the D4 oh and
there you go he reveals what he was
thinking about which is okay maybe maybe
he actually wants to get rid of that
Knight even at the expense of the bishop
pair under the idea that from there The
Exchange might be a little bit easier
for him to justify if he can if he can
take cuz obviously if you take on C5 and
black doesn't take with a pawn white
will fill that D4 square with a knight
so so hikaro trying to think a few moves
ahead here he's thinking like a chess
fler really is that that's an
interesting
analogy interesting you know like player
he's playing chess out there that's what
he's doing you know what look out he's
not playing checkers hikaro is playing
chess out there he's playing chess
you know it's it's it's interesting when
sports sports commentators make a kind
of a chess analogy and generally they're
pretty pretty
cringy that's why I feel like I've been
watching so much sports with it was it's
bowl season it's it's NFL playoff season
I just yeah you know I've heard so many
times they're playing chess out there
it's a chess game between these coaches
I I just want to say I think it's a
chess game here between hikaro and and
Sasha it is indeed and Sasha trying to
figure out how does he want to block
this check uh against this King does he
want to play Knight B to D7 does he want
to play Knight to C6 it's very very hard
to make heads or tails of this position
because also Hikaru can play Pawn Tak C5
at the right moment and open up an
attack on the D5 Pawn I mean he could
potentially get really materialistic and
get greedy and ultimately snag that big
Center Pawn on D5 so I mean not an
enviable decision here for Sasha who is
letting his clock kind of dwindled down
Knight F to D7 what a decision opening
up the potential for a trade of dark squ
Bishops and what Sasha is saying Danny
is that after the Bishops are traded
Bishop E7 Queen E7 the E3 Pawn uh is
going to be in the Queen's line of fire
really creative move which shows us why
is such an interesting player agreed I I
love that move it goes back to okay
Hikaru didn't go the traditional path
with Knight G2 but Sasha takes that
opportunity to mix it up just as much
and we already highlighted White's only
real problem in the position is this E3
Pawn but it is a big problem if black
somehow starts exerting pressure on the
E file so what a move I don't even think
Kar wants to trade but do you really
want to play a move like Bishop F4 you
might have
to you might have to but that gives
black a Tempo to Castle probably we
might see Bishop takes E7 Queen takes E7
I mean even King f is a move here and
hikaru's played it King F2 is on the
board classic Hikaru B Cloud for the win
H King to F2 how often do you see that
on move 11 actually pretty often these
days so that was actually not the worst
position I mean if you showed me this
position and and you know regardless of
the fact that it probably couldn't have
actually been reached from a bon Cloud
but close enough I would say that looks
like a pretty successful Bon cloud
yeah I mean compared to all of the Bon
clouds we've seen we have some moves
there bordnick castling kingside Bishop
takes D7 on the board so moves are being
played a trade on D7 and okay the
situation has stabilized I think the
position is about equal um hikaro will
probably go Knight G2 he will go Queen
D2 and eventually he'll probably try to
tuck his King away onto the king side
Rook E1 and and King G1 uh will complete
his
setup yeah
and I and I think this is
actually much better for hikaro than
what could have been given that the ewn
I think will find sufficient defense as
da pointed out the king will eventually
likely castle by him maybe not but
probably it does and at some point you
go back to looking at the center da and
this bishop is not a great piece staring
down at his own pawn and it feels like
white actually holds the cards now in
terms of the pawn tension that at some
point white might trade when he decides
it's time to cash in otherwise he'll
kind of leave this dynamic because it
keeps the bishop sort of blocked behind
his own his own peska there your
thoughts on that yeah I agree like
strategically I think white has some
assets that Bishop on B7 is also kind of
blocked in uh by The Pawn on D5 but from
a tactical standpoint I think bortnik
has sufficient play to compensate for
that as he situated as Queen on H4 now
Rook to E6 Danny trying to double Rooks
on the E file and really go after that
E3 pawn and also Rook H to E1 um I guess
it's technically possible because you
can't take the pawn on H2 you lose your
queen that's actually kind of a really
funny line but you don't want the
headache you don't want the headache of
constantly having to worry about hanging
pawns on various sides of the board so
this is going to get really really spicy
going into the late middle game I love
that point and you know if you do
something else Rook E1 or Rook D1 I I
don't quite know but I think black's
position is is pretty Prett easy to play
you bring the other Rook over you might
at some point try to shift get this
Knight into F6 and
uh yeah this is this is going to be
tricky trickier I guess than I thought I
was focused on the Strategic elements of
white kind of owning the tension if you
will given that that Bishop isn't great
but the truth is the other elements of
the position the pressure that black now
has make this very very spicy and look
at the clock I think that kind of says
that we're uh we're in for a dog fight
here neither player really really in
control of this one yet yeah this is a a
really rich position full of strategic
and tactical complexities we probably
will see Knight to F6 by bortnik and
then he will double on the eile but we
can definitely go to another game while
this one is still heating up jpam by the
way already won his game so he's got
three out of three um having defeated
Robbie kaves in a miniature wow not sure
how they came intoed so quickly I got I
got to show that real quick cuz I just I
scrolled my mouse over and saw the final
position
jbam busts out okay well we've got like
a weird alipin kind of Sicilian thing
but how did this go so wrong so
fast yeah this looks fine for black but
kevish vage just kind of neglected his
King side and look at Jam's Knights bang
bang bang and it's already winning it's
already made B Bishop takes H6 and
everything falls apart boom I love it
look at it that was
clinical that was fantastic and josam is
so well prepared in these delayed alipin
um that pawn structure that you had
looked totally fine for black but y
josam had it all planned out from the
very beginning what a win no you're
right I'm I'm looking at the time log in
this game
and literally I wonder if this was pure
prep da he didn't even he was still
above 9 minutes here with Bishop takes
stage six so you're looking at a
position where Jos buom clearly came to
the board with uh with exactly what he
wanted to do in mind and it paid off so
all right Fabiana Carana taking on
Rasmus Spain over here interesting
one but okay but okay ala
fua with one and a half out of two taken
on SEL T
sakin
wow we can go anywhere I'm pointing out
that we have a lot of good games that is
what I'm doing as I'm naming games
that's my only intention Alvar alono
Russell one another game against RX Sani
so that guy is on fire I also wanted to
check out Vincent kimer maybe Spotlight
the young German player a little bit um
we can just kind of go around the horn
and then come back to hikaru's game and
it heats up a little bit more um he's I
tend to agree I'm I'm trying to find
Ker's game oh he's right there at the
top taking on B off let's go over to
Ker's game here we got Vincent kimer
with the white pieces taken on vov here
also very talented player from
usbekistan
um okay ker looks like he's in a pretty
good spot though yeah kimer is gonna win
this game I I have very little doubt
that kimer is going to convert this
position this is like a dream absolute
dream scenario for white out of a
Queen's Gambit you know one of those
openings look at the Knight on C6 Whit's
pieces are perfectly coordinated Black's
position is riddled with weaknesses and
holes and look at A5 just massaging
those weak squares trying to get himself
the C5 Square for his Rook yeah okay
still some work to do Danny but I think
kimer basically has this one in the bag
agreed and I was I was fantasizing about
some sort of even more forceful way of
using the C5 Square I don't know that
there's actually a mating net there so
instead just play the solid move but uh
we also have Archer Nixon taking on the
14th World Champion Vladimir kromik
commentator both both of these players
with two points not of the new
generation these two guys this is an
interesting
one yeah um n Suns of course a very
strong LP ven Grandmaster he's been
streaming uh quite a bit recently so he
is on people's radar and he's a great
player he's just like like a career you
know solid 2600 GM um those types of
guys are they're not necessarily going
to get into the finals but they're not
an easy pairing and we have a very sharp
position here a check on C6 check to the
white king White's King probably going
to drop back to G1 and naon is going to
try to activate that Knight and situated
on F5 it's going to get really really
sharp toward the end of this game agreed
Mutual time
scramble will likely be in their future
I almost went full Yoda there um Mutual
time pressure we shall have is is is
likely likely ahead for these guys
that'll be that'll be a wild one but all
right I remind everybody you can go to
chess.com events follow the games
yourself we are still pretty early on uh
it's a nine round event in total and
this is only round three you can see the
standings there um over on our left as
far as some of the players sitting there
in the middle of the field I could go
back to Nakamura bortnik if you're into
that although it looks like we're headed
toward kind of a tame end game I don't
want want to call the uh the peaceful
result or anything white has a little
bit of an edge
but yeah I'm actually really pessimistic
here for Sasha because his last move A6
wait a second Knight to C7 will Fork The
Rook in the pawn I guess he wants Knight
C7 Rook C8 and then he wants to activate
his Rook via C2 but Karu is obviously
such a wizard at converting these small
advantages in the end game and putting
pressure on his opponent's clock Sasha's
under two minutes I don't know this is
going to take quite a bit of defensive
effort if he wants to hold a draw here
with black let's see what hearu figures
out I agree and I feel bad I didn't
immediately call out the clock because
when we left this game probably the most
equal thing in the position was actually
uh the the time remaining but that has
completely changed taru up almost two
full minutes and that's probably the
biggest issue that that faces bortnik
ahead again he is a he is an absolute
Monster In Time scrambles if you don't
know but but still not fun oh my gosh
Peter Sidler is going to win his game by
the way against Andrew hongan we have a
crazy position in the game
punov versus mlay I'm not necessarily
insistent that we switch um if people if
you're into watching this end game but
so many games to choose I'm about it
give me give me uh give me mlay that guy
that guy always
delivers board six sorry I'm I'm all
over the place there's a lot going on
there it is p of M I missed it I was
scrolling and what do we have here uh
wow apparently white is winning because
of the threat of Queen to G6 check and
wait white is also upper
Rook yeah Min lay just blundered when I
checked a little bit earlier this was a
lot more double edged so okay off we go
I guess to another game sadly mlay he is
going down yeah pabel punov is up a rook
black has a lot of Pawns but because of
the threat of Queen to G6 check which is
borderline Unstoppable by the way um
yeah I think I think it's just over so
all right sorry mlay apparently we
jinxed you good luck good luck next
round buddy yeah good luck next time I'm
gonna go over to yuong y's game versus
Alexander
shimanov this is
a bishop ending that white is pushing
just little bit likely a draw okay yeah
this one this one's a draw for sure it's
just a fortress for black all the pawns
are on the right color okay I'm curious
how the hikaro game is coming along
because we might hit our time scramble
phase just about now yeah hikaro is
gonna win hikaro is goingon to win his
Pawn is too far Advanced he's got too
much time on his clock this is kind of a
vintage vintage hikaro Victory it wasn't
always smooth it was back and forth but
then you check and he's got three
minutes as opponent has 10 seconds and
he's got you know a pawn that's two
steps away from promotion
yeah really instructive to see that
hikaro didn't panic when The Rook got
the second rank he kind of recognized
that his Rook was already developed
right where it stood and by playing B4
followed by a quick Rush of the awn we
see that that Rook is uh is helping
white win the game so what looked you
know optically at first this position oh
my God black is dominating how is white
going to try to complete compete and
challenge you realized that this
two-on-one majority was enough for white
to just rush forward with an advantage
on the queen side and uh I don't know
what car was thinking about here B6
actually a takes B6 is a very
unintuitive move it looks like oh you're
allowing F Tak G2 check but remember
White's Pawn is simply Unstoppable and I
think this is precisely what Hikaru is
calculating trying to make sure that
black has no you know sudden mating
constructions but black is too
slow4 B7 G B8 Queen
mate it's crazy yeah no this is this is
exactly what he's calculating I would I
stand corrected because there's no
Knight mates here and a knight on H3 or
F3 would mate if we were playing bug
house but the Knight is too many sores
away from this and white will get a
queen before anything happens so
actually oh wait hikaro has actually
taken and this one is moments from being
over yeah great effort by bortnik it
looked pretty appealing for him early in
the game but it's iar Nakamura and this
is just what he does okay Knight G4 one
last attempt but G takes F3 very very
important to throw that move in and go
to E1 escaping the checks and white wins
the
game hikaro has likely already
calculated all of this y the threat of
B7 B8 welcome new baby girl Britney to
the world it's a girl and
uh and there you go the queen uh the
queen comes and uh and bortnik resigns
okay we move
to any other game by the way the the
kimer game is still still a lot of fun
it looks like black is about to get
checkm at any moment I don't want to
miss
that yeah still
going as well looks like is making
progress against kramnick although that
one is pretty crazy
yeah we're going to assume that Ker's
going to get this done let's go back
let's go back to n's kramnick here both
players now under a
minute what is going on
here Rook to D5 from cnick is not to the
computer's
liking but when I look at the end game I
immediately think the C2 Pawn is very
weak so there must be something just
incredibly concrete here for
white yeah there must be some kind of a
tactic but I'm struggling to find it
it's not Knight G5 Jack n does take on
B7 and maybe just Rook C7 trying to
approach the puns from behind Rook C7
Knight takes C2 and Rook takes C5 and
maybe you just pick off the C3 pun this
is great cold blooded Thinking by n and
Rook to D5 Danny there's E4 Chasing The
Rook away from the fifth Rank and
getting to that C5 pun White's going to
win this
game in the time scramble it probably
was easy for black to CCH calculate that
if you took F7 obviously crnic was in
good shape but missing this move at the
end of that forcing complicated Queen
exchange is probably what happened and
now now Vladimir under 10
seconds likely likely going down here
the C3 Pawn's going to fall for free by
the way oi Resa fua got crushed by
samvel ter sah
hakin sville tah hakan is honestly one
of those really really dangerous players
such an aggressive attacking style at
times and it can really just shock
people I think n's is going to is going
to get this win unless Vlad konnik
somehow puts up a
fortress it's two extra pawns I think it
should be enough Wesley so is also still
playing his game against Casper porin
they were in a Time scramble last I
checked look at this Wesley has a very
powerful knight on D6 and he's poking
and prodding and trying to win this game
Knight to C4 attacking the Bishop
attacking the pawn on
B6 are there chances here for Wesley he
can take it with this que winning end
game if you trade Queens I think you
have to do it I think you have to try it
yeah I think he does
it no it's a draw it's apparently not a
winning ending because black gets active
so quickly even the E5 Pawn might fall
due to Bishop C5 Bishop D4 not sure okay
no just just active King I guess to
hold move there by
Wesley tricky tricky silly rabbit tricks
are for kids Wesley so trying to to pose
some Fork some Fork problems okay this
is actually
funny it doesn't actually win but
there's a trade in B5 and A5 but the
black king is within the box so there is
no there is no win
there yeah this is a draw Knight B3 King
C4 B takes A5 King B4 and the bishop can
stop the pawn from B8 very important
detail but Knight D4 the end still going
still going unfortunately wait well
done a draw what a hold well defended
what a hold
incredible that is some heads up chess
right there from Casper to give up the
bishop but understand that the Knight is
a bit of a donkey when it comes to
helping his teammates to pass pawns um
okay so Wesley so draws back to n's
versus crom
it looks like white is going to win this
one so n is going to move to three of
three on the day and join the other
leaders Pon crov Alonzo Sidler Oparin
paravian Nakamura I could keep reading
names in front of me Ron Burgundy style
as long as they don't feed me anything
in appropriate on that teleprompter I'm
good there you
go okay karnick let's this time run out
nakon wins a very impressive technical
game and a lot of players with three out
of three amazing how many games you have
to win and your reward is okay you're
going to face iaru you're going to face
Peter Sidler who I really think we
should watch in the next round so
impressed at how Peter Sidler is doing
um still so strong class is permanent as
Sidler is showing
today agreed tabatabai and alexenko are
still going at it oh
God why did you say that this game is
going to go on for a long time
[Laughter]
I just love your reaction to that oh
every every commentator you know is uh
is judged sometimes when they're when
they're not as excited as as you want us
to be about a game as you should be but
sometimes you look at an end game and
you just well if you're if you're okay
Don I'm gonna go upstairs and make a
snack I'll be back in three minutes
absolutely this is this is I'm not even
saying it's not exciting I think black
actually has decent uh well actually now
Rook F5 is coming so maybe wait you're
not actually making a snack that was a
joke no I was I was kidding I was
pointing out that this game going to be
I would be totally fine if you wanted if
you wanted to make his neack but yeah
this end game is I guess a draw
objectively but Black's Pawn is moving
to E4 white just keeps checking
laterally Rook to F5 e that's what I was
saying is because the Rook is coming to
F five it actually I think is easier now
black could also lose this end game if
he loses the Pawn by accident like E3
King F3 and it should be a draw yeah
yeah okay
now G6 G for the E Rook
G5 maybe Rook E6 is also possible I was
going to say or or Rook E6 could he play
Rook E6 he commits The Rook to
G5 this is actually wait little
dicey white has no moves this
on E6 I think the Rook needed to stay on
E6 King D2 we're going to have
simultaneous
promotion I think it's still a draw oh
my God I think it's still a
draw what in the world was the win there
for black I'm going to back up and look
at it cuz that was instructive but I'm
not going to call a draw yet with with
less than 5 Seconds Anything could
happen here okay now it's a draw Queen
G1 just blocked the check with the queen
no he's still going but oh my gosh
finding the win in those types of
situations is so difficult there's
generally just like one path it's it's
usually very very
narrow okay I'm back to the
position apparently it was King to D2
not Rook D7 was played in The game
everyone which is a normal idea because
you're it's the bridge method you're
shielding your king from checks but it
obviously just gives G7 and that's what
happened in the game is both sides got
Queens but the move was King to
D2 check
and apparently you can run
out no King F3 King F3 King F3 to stop
King F2 that's the key oh and that's it
Rook Rook uh E6 there's even Rook takes
G6 check and E1
Queen and white is no moves white is no
way to stop it because Rook F five sh
King E4 just zigzagging Black's way yeah
and preventing all of the checks from I
originally thought was the idea but but
if King D3 is King F2 so you have to go
here first first and then if Rook F5
King E4 and the King has literally
zigzagged the white Rook out of checks
you ever zigzagged someone out of checks
da all the time I do that every morning
and every Friday every morning you wake
up and you're just like Zig and you zag
you Zig and you zag and that's how
that's how you get your day started I I
I've seen you in your apartment
um all right well welcome to the show
boys and girls this is the 2024
Champions chess tour it's the playin
tournament we're just uh we're really
just getting
started round four has now started and
it's time for us to jump into the next
set of games you said you wanted to
follow Peter fidler he's taking on
archers Nixon maybe he can avenge his
friend Vladimir kromik and get the Dub
here and do are we seeing what I think
we're seeing is there on G4 oh it's a
Gro baby you buckle up you shut your mou
when when did he play G4 oh
it a mouslip it was a mouse slip it was
a mouse
slip oh man if if somehow fidler
qualifies and has a great day maybe
we'll get an interview with him we love
Peter I was chatting with him on
WhatsApp yesterday I won't say about
what because it's a really exciting
event that could be coming up that's
right everybody get excited might have
some fun fun times ahead for Mr Peter
fidler here but there he is he looks
like he's smiling I think yeah G4 was
probably a mouse slip it was definitely
a mouse slip now there's certain
categories of players if hear Nakamura
played G4 I don't know if oi Resa fuja
played G4 probably they're trolling you
know this is some sort of bet when Peter
smidler plays G4 he's of the old school
he doesn't partake in the whole bong
Cloud games no no no this was a mous
slip and he's actually in quite a bit of
trouble here because how bad is G4 it's
actually pretty freaking bad um because
that one is a big weakness I guess he
could play H3 uh Danny and just solidify
that pawn but black could even play H7
H5 and really chip away at White's King
side so this is actually a pretty big
problem for peace
vidy I I I agree to the point where he
might want to go full Gro right he might
not have meant to be here with a mouse
Li but going in for something with D4 or
Knight to C3 and you sort of neglect the
pawn as a weakness and try to get jiggy
with it you try to get spitty with it
there you go you get Jiggy right P Diddy
and Big
Willie joined by pe
vitty you like RG
Robson um but yeah no it's not the worst
I mean okay like probably the tactics
are just fine for black but let's
analyze what if white plays Queen to B3
just humor me what's next okay yes
you're attacking the D5 Pawn I mean if
black plays Knight F6 this is a classic
this is why the grop can be good at a
lower level white plays G5 and
everything works to Perfection it's like
oh this is why I played G4 to prevent
Knight F6 but black doesn't have to
defend the pawn from F6 black can play
Knight to E7 uh which looks like an
awkward move but remember White's the
one with a Pawn on G4 and on the next
move Danny Black's gonna go Knight B to
C6 for example H3 Knight B to C6 and the
Knight is coming into D4 this is
disgusting yeah for disgusting I
say okay so even like Knight to C3 we
don't have enough time you you make a
really good point that even here Knight
B to C6 and Knight to D4
is probably a problem this is probably a
problem probably a problem yeah
so these are the types of things that
Sidler is thinking about because to DA's
point if you don't go full grub you're
playing a move like gug three and just
surrendering to the fact that you have
have a horribly overextended kingside
and n's at any moment right away or he
can just develop regularly and at some
point this shot of H5 is actually going
to be super
irritating oh yeah H5 is going to be a
huge problem and Peter with D4 you
called it um trying to embrace the Gress
of the position and you might as well I
mean you have a Pawn on G4 you basically
have a blank check at this point and I'm
curious what his response is going to be
to E4 um maybe it's just to play Knight
C3 and SA
the G4 pawn and try to play this kind of
French style with Queen to B3 and hit
you know the D5 pawn and the B7 pawn and
that's exactly what he's doing Knight to
C3 is on the board already um yeah I
like it I think this is the Lesser evil
for Peter fidler and naon develops his
own Knight to
C6 okay it's still very bad for white
but you know that a lot of the fight is
still ahead it's not like you play G4
and you lose yep okay you know you know
what's funny
is F3 is actually not the worst idea in
the
world yeah it's
not it's it's probably the best idea
position somebody Check on Ben fold he
just spit up whatever was in his mouth
and maybe he's joking now we Hope's okay
but okay whoa called it it's not the
worst idea because at this point you're
Allin with G4 you're not even that
worried about the queen coming to check
I mean you could actually you could
actually consider this but I think even
just King F1 and the point is at least
here you're undermining the center and
renewing the idea that your pieces have
a goal which is you know to to to do
something to have a plan to put pressure
on the on the the white d uh the pawn on
D5 so anyway he plays it there you go
everyone makes sure Ben's okay somebody
Check on
Ben well I'm I'm only a three and a half
hour drive from Atlanta so uh maybe I
can you know head out really quickly
I'll be back before the show is over
don't worry hon hours all good
yeah okay this is craziness on the board
what is going on here what is going on I
like it and I think this is this is one
of those games where again Peter fither
did not want to be here but now that
he's here he might as well get spitty
with it N N na n n you know getting
fitty with
it um I like it
I I don't even want to go anywhere else
I'm so in love with this game but at
some point we probably should Dennis
lavic we've got the youngest player at
the 2023 Champions chess tour finals
taken on this has meant no disrespect
one of the oldest players an FFL if you
will a famous bleeping Legend in got a
compy yeah um this looks like a me
hanging on that no no I I'm just you
know soaking in the position I think
this this comes from a Dutch and Dennis
laic is you know for a young player he's
incredibly positional he is one of the
most strategic uh younger players it's
not that he can't do tactics I mean all
of the top GMS from The Young Generation
can quote unquote do tactics but he's
actually a very classical player one D4
Berlin with black very very solid and
he's nightmare opponent in like the
rapid time control because of that
because his style is so incredibly
infuriatingly solid no you're right I
think it is a bit of a stereotype you
assume young players you think
aggressive you know tactically gifted
and and leans tactically with the types
of stylistic choices they make but
Dennis lvic is not is not your your your
your typical I guess young player and
and especially in Rapid time controls
da he gets the same position a lot so
what ends up happening with him is he
plays the repertoire you talked about
super solid and he gets those positions
so often that he often has an edge on
the clock he's super familiar with the
tactics that will occur in those very
positional and strategic games and that
makes him even more dangerous and so
it's not it's not a typical recipe of of
someone trying to blow you off the board
with night of Sicilian prep but we've
looked at his games a lot and you see he
plays a lot of positions um just just uh
the same it's like he's playing the same
game over and over yeah and his Bishop
is always on G2 every time I look at one
of his games his Bishop is on G2 it's
truly it's truly staggering how often he
manages G you're right I honestly I
could do that just Catalan Dutch every
line his Bishop is always on G2 and to
your point Danny once you get the same
types of positions every game you're
able to play faster and you're able to
play relatively at a high level because
you essentially just know all of the
ideas and Dennis um with such a narrow
opening repertoire you do benefit from
that you know the positions that you get
really really well yep and so you're
you're actually in some ways playing
even stronger than maybe your overall
chess knowledge uh might adhere to based
on the fact that you're playing
positions more often than your opponents
are and that that can kind of close the
gap and so I think we've seen that with
players over time right obviously
someone like NBL Maxim who's a good
friend you know at some point was
criticized for being too one-dimensional
with his night orph in grunfeld right so
I do think you can argue that at some
point if you're reaching that 2800
threshold you know it could be a problem
but you deal with that problem later I
guess right right now you just worry
about winning chess games and you're
happy to get the positions that you know
better than your opponent if you're
Dennis
lvic yeah well said okay I think white
has a slight Advantage as both sides are
down to 5 minutes of course this is one
of the strategies that to employ when
facing gakamsky um relatively speaking
he does struggle more in time pressure
um and we'll see Dennis lavic with a
nice little Advantage here we can also
check into our top game between Oparin
and Nakamura um I saw that there was a
lock a lot going on there in the center
and there's still a lot going on in the
center obviously there was a trade on e4
I assume a move ago black put a knight
on e4 if I'm just guessing indeed there
we go okay but okay okay and uh yes I
mean okay it's very interesting
position black is taking D4
first I'm not sure I like it um Knight
F6 check is a possible inter is that the
idea oh wow that's an that's an in
between move you can write home about
right letters to
Mom Knight F6 check he didn't he didn't
see it I think that that was the best
move
that was a big Advantage for white I'm
actually pretty shocked instead opar is
essentially going for a draw because yes
he is up a pawn here but look at
hikaru's Rook on D2 how is black ever
going to lose a game when he's got when
first of all when hikaro Nakamura has
the black pieces but also when black has
this incredibly powerful Rook on D2 um
okay oarn is Oparin is the one is the
one who knocks here he is the one who is
going to decide when the game ends in a
draw but I think Karo has it in him to
to hold but but especially because of
the time I I agree with you I think that
we normally see this rolls revers with
Hikaru having a three minute plus
advantage on his opponent but an extra
Pawn in a rook ending right even at the
highest levels of Chess a four on three
is winnable we've seen it done before
obligatory Jaren picket versus Gary
Kasparov reference you got to do it
right it happens and has happened to the
best chess players in history so when
you don't have a lot of time on the
clock I I'm I'm I'm happy if I'm oaring
because I'm the only one who can win
right it's kind of a cozy seat to be in
when you're playing toar
Nakamura but but real quick I am gonna
show by the way that just real quick
Knight F6 check was a really great
move and the point is if you take the
pawn white just goes in for Queen to G4
here before taking back and Black's King
side has been completely destroyed so
gregori just just straight up Miss KN F6
potentially and settles on the end game
where at least he's playing for two
results I guess he's playing for two
results and maybe he can try a takes B5
a takes B5 Rook A8 and Rook A7 and all
of this is on the board so Hikaru still
has to be a little bit careful but again
the pawn on B3 is a big weakness okay
Rook
F4 probably just Rook takes
E5 Rook takes F7 and you want to be a
little bit careful if you're black there
about allowing white to double Rooks on
the seventh rank you know Piggy on the
seventh but okay rookie seven also good
yeah no this is a draw Oparin simply
cannot keep both of his pawns protected
the B3 pawn and the E5 Pawn he's going
to lose one of them and this one's going
to be a draw momentarily okay I think
it's a good result for aara draw with
hiar Nakamura but he did have that brief
chance uh to get a pretty big Advantage
with Knight F6
check
yeah well sometimes you suffer from bias
bias in your calculation when you play
the best players in the world we don't
think that aart is someone who would
struggle with that he's beaten hikaro
before here on the chess.com radio
network we've seen it but still when
you're going up against these guys I
think sometimes you settle on that comfy
cozy idea of all right well at least I
can't lose da right what is the
psychology there as I'm asking you
you're someone who's beaten Hikaru and
others like how do you prevent yourself
from doing that when the chances at a
two result position doesn't happen very
often so you go for it not even
realizing you had you had a third result
there like you could have been going for
after the king honestly I still haven't
figured that out and it is one of the
most difficult things about facing
people like iaro or Magnus when you have
this safe option it's so hard to resist
because you know that you can limit your
risk you know you can get a very comfy
position and you're probably not going
to win it but you're kind of lying to
yourself you're like well what here I'm
playing for two results maybe I'm going
to win I'm minimizing my risk if you
really want a chance to beat these guys
you have to take risk and you have to
believe in yourself and there is no
other way you can't beat someone like
Kar Nakamura without taking taking on a
great deal of risk that's just part of
it um and Y okay this one I think is
going to be a draw still a little bit of
can I go back can we go back to the game
you know I want to go back to yes yes
yes yes
absolutely this is like it's fidler's
day peace fitty peace fit's in the house
look at this guy what in the world is
going on what is happening here Peter is
up a piece now is he better is white
better
here what on
Earth he has to be right he's up a piece
and there's no
concrete
threats Queen takes A1 there C7 check
and if you block with the Rook white
actually makes another queen so that's
the Tactical component I think black is
losing this is insane this is wild this
is wild and we may have some sort of you
know uh finish for the ages when you
when you think of the the great
attacking masters of old I'm thinking
about a bishop coming to A3 and there's
some sort of you know Crossing diagonal
Checkmate here that black has to worry
about if you're just tuning in this game
started with a mouse slip we don't even
need to bring up the analysis board I
just want to quickly show that this game
started this game started with Peter
fither playing G4 which we had his
reaction on
camera we are quite confident this was a
mouse slip because it's not a good move
at all yet somehow he goes full Gro and
justifies with this F3 move which was
wild and ultimately we're sitting in
this position
here absolutely crazy black is busted
because C7 check as well as C takes B7
check both of these moves are huge
threats
n plays B takes C6 but no Queen takes E4
check and the game is over Sidler is
just going to be up a piece he's going
to consolidate his advantage and black
also has 20 seconds on his clock so I
think we're gonna see 97 by naon okay no
but but okay Queen E3 Rook B1 white is
literally up a piece and he's got the
compensation now Black's position is
also in shambles insane are we going to
see more G4 englishes in the future hey
accidentally giving yourself some
winning maybe it was one of those Gambit
Bluffs where he was trying to play a B
you know and just like made his opponent
think he messed up I don't know but
Queen E3 is a nice one I'm just gonna
show daa's idea if Queen takes A1 now
Bishop A3 is going to be checking M you
can he did it okay what a beast V it did
it
incredible 17 wow a brilliant move too
sacrificing The Rook on A1 for puzzle
Rush style Checkmate on the dark Square
diagonal but of course sakes sin doesn't
go for that he Retreats no matter white
is just simply up a minor piece now
three is three Bishop B7 and Bishop E7
is gonna trigger
res that's it he loses a resignation for
our new
nation okay Bop takes
F6 he's got Knight G4 check but the Rook
hangs at the ends so I'm not sure at the
end yeah Bishop takes d8 and now he's
going to resign it's a lot of pieces
with only two seconds on the clock n
does indeed throw in the towel or maybe
he lost on time who
knows wow what a game what a win by
Peter Siller he's on four out of four
and right now he's the only one with
four out of four because Nakamura Oparin
they drew their game true but I think he
will be joined maybe will be joined by
Vincent who is pressing against David
paravian but I don't know if he's got
enough here to pull out the win he's up
upon opposite called bishop and it
should be a draw with best play but I
don't know La ksky also is an
interesting game ksky that was one of
the games we started with earlier
loic wow this is this is actually worked
out pretty well for god lasic didn't get
the traditional things you see in a G3
fan ketto Dutch where white gets E4 or
or or is somehow prying open the light
squares instead it's wh's King side that
was torn apart where did that g Pawn go
and I hope you're happy to see the queen
here in a minute I actually like this
for a
lot this is actually really really
dangerous for white the king is wide
open yeah and okay I mean lazic has a
minute and 40 ksky has 29 seconds but
remember there is that 2C increment
which has saved got so many times white
has to find a way to get some pieces
onto the king side because Black's next
move is Queen takes H4 and you could get
checkmated really really quickly
here I don't uh I don't see it com I
mean the Knight has undeveloped itself
back to the original Square somehow a g
Pawn which should be here is
gone and again okay I was just going to
say and the thing you normally go for
his white is E4 he finally does
it okay maybe he's just going to go to
the end game and just you know fight for
a draw yeah but he takes F5 Knight to F4
threatens a Checkmate in one move on E2
Anastasia's mate in Reverse will be
threatened oh but Queen G3 check sorry I
forgot Queen G3 was a check but even in
the end game you're still encountering a
lot of difficulty because black could
trade everything and then play Bishop
takes C4
so now under a minute for Dennis lazic
he actually might this
game yeah it's not looking not looking
great I think that he played E4 to have
this sort of defensive you know Ace in
the Hole and now he goes for it not
because it's good but because he was
that worried about getting blown off the
board on the king side so now it's
kamy's game to win we'll see if he can
do it Bishop takes E4 Knight to G5
Black's Rook could slide into E3 there's
no question that white is losing
material here laic is even thinking
about a move like Knight to C3
activating his KN but kamsky could play
Knight C5 and everything is beautifully
protected there oh man E3 is possible as
well black is
winning but can he
convert can he
convert Knight C5 and it's like he
planned it All Along The Rook is poised
for greatness supporting the E Pawn the
Knight defends
A4 you can trade and push him baby here
maybe it's right B4 Knight D3 white is
losing all of his pawns I would just
grab that pawn on B3 while you have a
chance okay also
good yeah got to be thinking about it
calculating if there's anything concrete
but no now he'll probably just take the
pawn indeed he
does Knight goes right back to
C5 wow this is lovely conversion by
gakamsky just watch how nicely his
pieces are coordinated how patiently
he's converting just bringing his King
up King to E5 yeah this one should be
over
momentarily but maybe not you never know
CCT it's the CCT it's the first day of
the playin stage it's the Swiss where a
lot of the magic happens again you don't
remember this day at the end of the week
but it's one of the more exciting days
wait rookes one okay got a little bit
Knight B1 would have ended the game
immediately now you're giving Dennis
laic okay may some chances after Rook to
F3 and he finds it and you don't want to
prolong the
game
no
csky God what are you doing now he's
worse now why is playing for a win
White's gonna win White's gonna win this
game mark my
words Lo sticks with
it wow okay still a draw still a draw
still a draw the king and Bishop are
Cally located although he's not going to
give it to him he's gonna he's going to
try to work it with no digity put the
King on D4 uh I don't know how easy this
is ridiculous by the way got C or Fabion
Carana is also losing his game I think
to pav pav with a white pieces but this
is the game to watch Insanity okay this
is just a draw black just has a fortress
the bishop is guarding both
yeah okay now that now that he's
established the pawn on d32 D3 as well
white white can never really get too
frisky because the pawn will push so
this should be
holdable I uh was more worried about the
king and Rook coordinating and advancing
when that pawn was on D5 but this should
be this should be just fine wait wow
he's going to go for the king and Bishop
versus King and Rook H5 was
a yeah yeah why I don't really know what
the necessity was to play H5 just hold
on now you're going to have to hold
bishop and Rook versus Bishop which of
course gotsky should do he's got enough
time but you never know the margins keep
thin thinning and thinning and I've seen
a lot of cases where the player with a
bishop gets impatient and accidentally
blunders the bishop or accidentally
walks into a skewer it's not unheard
of not unheard of at all it's an
interesting decision to go for this as
you said objectively this is an easy
draw for black
but in time scrambles wild things happen
maybe they're just going to settle here
anded they do okay lovic says all right
all right big fella you earned the draw
you know I'm gonna give it to you
kid jeez all right what else
happened crazy results P POF does indeed
take down Fabio Carana Vincent kimer won
that opsac code Bishop end game against
P by the way so he will likely face okay
there's actually quite a few players
with four out of four josam he won his
game as well there's still a game going
bardia desar from Iran is GNA defeat
Alan pisho Argentinian GM and he moves
to three out of four leavon aronian lost
to his compatriot hike marur roian
upsets everywhere you look
Danny wow
upsets everywhere wild wild chess going
on here in the playin stage welcome to
the 2024 Champions chess tour where have
you been uh the tour is just getting
started and Don and I have had the
pleasure of calling these first four
rounds of our swiss but uh David Howell
Tanya satv Robert hes faces you know
very very well when it comes to the tour
we'll be joining and really taking the
mantle as we move into the later days of
the week but he joins us right now David
what's up man are you excited for
another year getting underway Danny
Daniel I'm pumped uh I've been with the
Champions chestor now for a while but
I'm so excited maybe more excited than
ever about this new season we've mixed
things up you guys have been calling the
shots really really well and what a
start to the day we've had so far uh I
hope you've been enjoying it as much as
I have I we've been calling the action
we've been enjoying it what what games
have we missed you you get to kind of
maybe scroll through more of the games
than Don and I as we get kind of you
know dragged down whatever rabbit hole
is in front of us so there have been a
couple results maybe you had your eye on
or performance so far to to to share
with us yeah uh I wanted to highlight
actually what I feel has been the game
of the day so far and maybe one of the
moves of the day from one of the players
of the day Peter SP here we go let's do
it let's do it and
um oh go for it dadd I'm on this game
here which game do you want to go to
Let's let's go to round two and board 22
where Peter Sidler against the king's
Gambit just Unleashed wow looks like he
refuted the king's Gambit pretty much
maybe help take it away if you if you
know how to get to the game here sorry I
didn't know I was I was fighting you for
the mouse that's my fault my apologies
we'll pull up the game uh Danny I might
have to ask you for a helping hand um
game and helping me talk through it but
Peter fidler I just wanted to say one of
my childhood hero I've been lucky enough
to work with him um as a second on
occasion and he just looks bang in form
the way he defeated Serbian Grandmaster
Alexander init in round two um in that
Kings Gambit was just phenomenal and uh
we'll try to bring that up for everyone
in the meantime but um Daniel I wanted
to ask you what's been the highlight so
far oh my gosh I just all you can eat
buffet um any game you switch to um has
been really really exciting speaking of
Peter Sidler obviously the way that he
was able to undo the damage caused by
his second move against Archer SES and
then turn it around and win that game in
18 moves that was absolutely ridiculous
um it's just great to see um such a
great mixture of kind of the Main Stays
you know hekar Nakamura and lvan aronian
as well as all of these really really
dangerous 2600s you see Fabiana Carana
he was really struggling from the very
first game he almost lost his Dennis
Wagner that was an incredible time
scramble and then just losing to pav
punov who's on four out of four uh David
so many interesting story lines anywhere
you look but I think I'm looking at the
Peter Sidler game which Danny you've
pulled up what in the
world is this game we're gonna let you
let you take it away no David apologies
for that first show of the year as we
get things ironed out here but David we
did miss this game so good call take it
away yeah start as we mean to go but I
promise it will be worth the wait it
started as a king's Gambit actually
Alexander init here with white one of
the most aggressive players out there
sacrificing a porn early on the king's
Gambit a romantic opening maybe not the
most uh sound of them all though and
look at this def4 allowing Sidler here
as black to drop in a check and I wanted
to highlight this white King's Journey
King to E2 Sidler playing the move D5
giving up a pawn throwing in another
check with Bishop to G4 castling Queen
side now and uh if we fast forward a few
more moves just hunting down this white
king and it was here I think one of the
moves of the day for me after King C3
Danel you spotted it rookie one no way
black plays rookie one oh my God
beautiful all the pins all the skewers
there's uh there's a line here the White
Knight cannot move to take this Rook if
the queen takes the Rook of course then
you get skewed in the other direction
Bishop to B4 and everything collapses
but the tactics the fun didn't stop
there white dodged with with Queen to D3
and actually Sidler after this move
found the only winning move not taking
this Rook because the Knight Falls
instead Knight to B4 and white was
obliged to give up the queen and just to
finalize uh the result here just to
finish off proceedings in style Bishop
B4 check double exclamation mark
throwing a bishop away in order to um
later after King takes B4 take this pawn
and win the white Bishop Queen up for
rook and Bishop Sidler on form today uh
he bagged this and I've got to say it J
I think he's a favorite for the rest of
the event fantastic chess I agree he's
on form David it's not every day you get
to bust the king's Gambit like this and
then win a game you saw the G4 game
right where he won a game basically with
a mouse slip right that doesn't I think
there are there are very few people on
the planet who can pull that off so uh
David you're gonna have the call
obviously you'll be with us you'll be
with us as a as a as a guest every time
we're doing this and and we'll be
touching base with you and T and Hess as
we we we have a very long week ahead
right how do you feel about this this
new format where we got eight straight
days of Showtime here yeah I'm excited I
mean last season I felt that one of the
highlights were were these play-ins and
uh to start off with them to kind of
warm up the players to warm up the fans
hopefully um I just think it's going to
shape up really really nicely and uh the
new time format 10 minutes two seconds
it's faster it's more furious and I
think it's only going to provide more
entertainment so I can't wait to jump in
um like you said it's going to be a long
week but a fun week and it's going to
get better every single
day all right well well said we can't
wait to have you back uh thank you for
bringing the highlights of of Peace
fitty as we're now calling him as he as
he as he spits the the the rap game on
the board I don't know why we're talking
about that but Peter fidler maybe the
player of the day if you believe David
Howell uh maybe the guy to beat going
forward so David thanks for being here
we'll see you uh we'll see you later
yeah keep up the good work guys see you
soon
David all right da this that uh that was
awesome that was a great game that we
missed clearly some brilliant moves
there
but so many games Danny it's just so
hard to keep track but that's a good
problem to have good problem to have too
much chess to follow we're going to take
our very first break of the day as
everyone takes a deep breath we are four
rounds underway for the 2024 Champions
chess tour more from David how more from
me more from da when we come back on the
other side of this
break
[Music]
take
I grew up in the small Forest Town of
vaa I've lived here all my
life when I was five my father taught me
the game and soon thereafter took me to
local chess
club I can't really remember my life
without chess I feel like it's always
been
there I met my wife through chess my
profession is
chess I don't play chess to win I'm not
that
competitive uh I love how the pieces
move I love the
game I love how everything arounds me
because become
still when I'm behind the chessboard
time doesn't flow the same way until the
clock runs
out in the spring of 2021 time seem to
have run out I was diagnosed with
hoskinson's disease which is a form of
cancer I was 35 and suddenly my life
changed it was a strange time and and
chess didn't seem to matter at
all but I was optimistic I uh trusted
the treatment plan and the doctors that
were helping me and I felt it was in
their hands now the chemotherapy
radiation uh at the worst I could barely
walk around
walk that it really puts things in
perspective like like uh if I have a bad
position now yeah I mean it's it's no
big deal you know so maybe in that sense
it helps that that you have a more of
a uh different kind of attitude to to to
to
life there are definitely also positive
things I take from that time when I was
not uh well um
I think it gives you kind of different
perspective on life on on on everything
actually so it's uh does definitely not
only um
negative it takes a long time to recover
but chess players are anything if not
patient it was crazy because one month
before the tournament in V I still had
my radiation therapy finished so it was
it was way too early actually to to
start playing but I
I wanted to desperately be at that
tournament I barely prepared for the
games because I I was just too tired I
just I only played the games I had
dinner went back to my room slept most
of the time I had put that tournament as
an um as a
goal best tourament I ever
played then at the end of the year after
um 16 field attempts I uh became D
champion
and that was really the cherry on on the
cake that was huge for me I was ecstatic
it was the feeling of I'm
back all those failures all those
setbacks they um never seem to matter
now what is important is that I have a
lot of Chess ahead of
me I always wait for the moment when uh
I wake up and
I realize that I well today I don't
really feel like looking at chess but it
just never
[Music]
happens my name is Adin Lami and I'm a
Dutch Grand
[Music]
Master
we are back the chessable Masters is the
first event here in the 2024 Champions
chess tour round five is already
underway we needed a break after that
awesome breakdown by David Howell some
brilliant chest being played by Peter
Fiddler but we're going to jump back
first and foremost to Wesley so's battle
that he's got underway against gakamsky
just to give a shout out to these two
these two guys here D although I also
would be happy to continue following
fidler him and Vincent kimer are the are
uh are two of the only four players
there with perfect scores if we want to
go over to that listen we're spoiled for
Choice um we'll kind of go around the
horn in a huge shout out also to ER L um
the first time I watched that video it
brought tears to my eyes um so inredible
incredible story there Irwin having a
great tournament uh in T Steel so we we
wish him uh the very best uh in health
on and off the board but Peter Sidler
has been showing his very best chess
thus far he's got four out of four he's
under I want to say a little bit of
pressure in this endgame against Vincent
kimer who's got that monster Bishop on
G2 uh pressuring Sidler Pawn on B7 he's
got the Pawn on A5 trying to freeze
Black's queenside Pawn majority it feels
like black needs to be a little bit
careful but that Sidler should be able
to hold a draw with accurate play maybe
even maybe even just Bishop takes A3 and
Bishop C6 I mean that's kind of the
Brute Force approach but I don't really
see anything wrong with that okay I was
gonna suggest yeah I was gonna say I
love this move because here at least you
invite white to uh to improve the king
position if you want to trade you're
going to put my king in an even better
spot and then something like Bishop to
C6 wouldn't even isolate the pawn you
might get in some spot where you can
trade everything and ultimately have an
active King so I I like King to E7 by by
Sidler um but as you pointed out the B7
Pawn is his biggest problem and that's
the pressure that he's
facing yeah yeah this is a little bit
nasty it feels like okay
B6 maybe I mean obviously this is in the
general realm of a draw Bishop C6 you
want to play I think just simplest is
just to try to trade the Bishops as oh
no okay simple chess five he uh he
invites Kimber for on pant right when
when in when in doubt always on pant
right always and actually I'm trying to
figure out a way for black to not lose a
pawn I think on pant if black takes back
with the pawn white can play Bishop
takes D6 King takes D6 and then Rook up
to A6
yeah it's a really unpleasant move I
mean maybe black goes King C7 there and
maybe black holds on but okay it's a
little bit
unpleasant yeah this is tricky maybe
King to C7 you're saying maybe yes maybe
okay black is holding yeah yeah it it
should be pointed out that if this Pawn
does fall unlike other Rook endings
everyone where maybe four on three or
three on two are an easy draw a five on
four is is far from an easy draw the
these types of end games are actually
much harder to hold especially without a
lot of time on the clock so it's not as
simple as Fiddler just being able to
give up that pawn and then hold with all
the pawns on the uh right side of the
board there so so that is
important but is he maybe on on assant
no I guess he must be planning on going
for that obviously taking with the Rook
is only worse because I assume actually
maybe this also works yeah this is
actually maybe this is how black wants
to play because Bishop takes D6 King
takes D6 and of course you can't take
the pawn because the Rook is going to
hang and if you take the rook in this
version okay with a pair of Rooks off
the board it's easier to hold for black
yeah I think Peter's gonna figure this
out I think he's got enough time
like just noticed I yeah I only just
noticed the live position that this is
exactly what he's gone for so yeah okay
so Sidler is he's figuring this out I'm
avoiding as much as I can just saying
just but okay like you have got me now
but okay uh this is your fault all right
but okay no once it's stuck in your once
it's stuck in your mind like you can't
stop saying it that's one of those
things okay but E4 but yes okay Rook C4
but hang on a second T but yeah this
is oh man look at look at uh kimer
rocking that secret lab chair shout out
to secret lab our sponsor everyone's got
the secret lab energy going on it's big
secret lab energy right now big big
secret lab you got it I got it listen
it's a great chair it's a great chair
it's it's such a big step up for my old
chair and I realized how much I was like
slouched over I still don't have the
best posture I admit it uh but the
secret lab chair really does promote
better posture and the the thing is it
was sitting in uh near my front door for
like six months because I don't know how
to assemble anything so I you know I had
to wait for my mom to visit we've done
all those videos with David how and
Simon Williams putting together ch we
should have had a video of DA's mom
helping can we get can we get a note
about that for the media team please
next time DA's mom visits we're gonna
we're gonna get a video of her putting
together the chair um but I still got
like six of these things in the office I
think I've given all the chairs I was
supposed to give away to the community
with all the promises I make I'm pretty
sure I'm clean Community before you
start yelling at me that's that I owe
one of you a
chair um but but okay assuming I'm clean
by uh by anything I owe the community in
regard in that regard I got to figure
out what to do with these extra chairs
around here maybe your mom could come
over and put them all together what do
you think hey a little assembly Marathon
that sounds incredibly
fun I'd be I'd love to do it um all
right the Rooks are going to be
traded draw
draw it is it is one of those things too
that I think make sense for both of them
they're leading the tournament together
not not clearly they're tied with the
other two players sitting with four
points a piece Punk rodof and Martinez
that's jpam so we'll check out those
games in just a second um in fact I
think let's back out and head over to
that game I don't know that this is the
most exciting fireworks on the board so
kimer and
Sidler likely headed toward a peaceful
result we're going to head over to the
one that whoa there's Rooks on the
seventh rank or are you happy to see me
oh my gosh Jose is this Checkmate is
this Checkmate Rook H7 King
G8 I'm looking for a mate here oh and I
think Rook G6 at the end Rook H7 Rook
G7 and then Rook G6 if I'm not
mistaken should seal the deal and it and
it threatens Rook F7 Rook G8 that's the
idea and Rook F6 in some situations Rook
takes F6 check also I mean Bishop E6
black has to play Bishop E6 I think in
this
King G but okay King G8 Rook E7 yeah
you're going to pick off the bishop no
this is over how did we get here I mean
this is insane let's let's keep the
analis let's keep the analysis board up
so that we can educate ourselves as to
how Jose Martinez is about to be the
first player maybe the only player
sitting with a perfect 50 score after
end of this round we had a French an
exchange French no
West okay okay this line has been
popular this C4 C5 line I've seen it
quite a few times recently okay this is
looking okay for
pav but maybe a slight Edge for Jose
yeah Bishop G5 very
unpleasant okay for some reason he gave
up the bishop did
punov oh oh that's
awkward yeah and Bishop D3 was a great
move it feels just like josam had a had
and often has a better feel for some of
these positions little little obscure
lines even if they're more more popular
now than they used to be he tends to be
just one step ahead on that although if
you look at the clock it's not like bu
was under a bunch of time pressure so
where did this really go wrong I mean I
think just allowing white to get the
bishop air allowing white to get this
massive pin against the Knight on F6 all
of that put together uh was just a huge
problem and oh look at this Pawn
structure by black I mean this is not
exactly the picture perfect Pawn
structure I would say on the king
side pawns only a mother could love
speaking of moms right hi moms um but
those are not happy happy pawns
jeez and then where does it really go
wrong here I'm just I'm waiting for that
oh not he's undevelop his pieces it just
doesn't work by the way we can't catch a
head rookie
seven rookie seven was the brilliant
move sacrifices the bishop on D3 three
and this is how the mating net got
started you obviously saw the live
position he did exactly what da said a
very nice little maneuver for the Rooks
to set up a mating net and then black
didn't play Bishop E6 which was his only
move to stop Checkmate and
instead gets checkm wow incredible Jose
Martinez he's on five out of five okay
pav punov that was a pretty good pairing
given that you were at four out of four
but still josam is making moves he might
be the only five out of five which means
he's going to face the highest rate at
four and a half not totally sure who
that's going to be but back we go to the
spitler game where Vincent kimer is
actually pushing for the win here trying
to get over to that A3
pawn bishop B5 okay obviously you can't
take the
bishop yeah black black would love to
have the move Bishop D5 here if the
black Bishop could play Bishop D5 black
is winning right the thechange Temple
not fast enough Bishop C6 King D3 Bishop
C6 King D3 Bishop D5 takes takes and
then the king gets to C3 the a pawn will
fall and white will be up a pawn at the
end of it so so Sidler in a little bit
of trouble here we said that josun might
be the only perfect scorer but if kimer
can somehow Swindle this one then we
know what our pairing is it's Martinez
kimer Bring It
On yes we will have two players with
five out of five and Sidler now down to
two minutes I mean White's plan is very
straightforward King D2 King C3 King B4
you just want to pick up the pawn and
maybe Peter is calculating that pawn end
game after Bishop C6 King D3 Bishop D5
it's not clear-cut that that pawn end
game is so easily winning for white
because Black's King will make his way
around uh potentially to the E4 Square
so it's there's a lot to Cal here for
black yeah are you thinking that Black's
King reaches the E4 Square before white
can get back okay okay okay okay okay
but okay uh uh okay let's I mean let's
analyze I'm too lazy to do this thing in
my head so let's show it for everyone at
home who also doesn't calculate good we
all went to that same school the point
is the point is DA's pointing out
that
the white king is here but if somehow
black could get in that be fine but I
think white has F3 just in time yeah I
thought
G5 and then H3 I think I hold you out H5
and then I take because in the end I
think I get an H pass oh fgh HG and H4
this is actually such an instructive
idea and you have the outside passer yes
very very good uh well calculated and
Peter Sidler I have a feeling this is
exactly what he was calculating he
burned a lot of clock and ultimately did
not go for it I think he might be going
down in this game suddenly I've really
soured on Black's position he's going to
lose that Aon Danny there's no question
about it he's going to lose that a pawn
will he have enough to hold the ensuing
position I don't know yeah and white
doesn't even have to protect this Pawn
any further right now King to C3 is is
is good enough the only question is
whether white okay he goes C3 but the
question was whether white wanted to
play a four in case you wanted to take
with this Pawn rather than the ewn But
ultimately kimer decides it's time to go
gather gather up this stray calf and
bring it back to the farm you know which
is where pawns go when they're taken
from the board if anyone is ever
heartbroken about a pawn don't worry
pawns go to the farm with other pawns
when they're taken from the board did
you know that very good I did not know
that but now I am fully reassured and I
can continue capturing pawns with a
clear conscience you can capture pawns
guilt-free pawns all get taken back to
the same Farm is this a fortress this is
the big question Peter is just going to
go back and forth Bishop F5 Bishop G6
now Vincent is eventually going to do
something with his pawns I think he's
gonna try to push F4 he's gonna get his
King to E3 Danny and then he's gonna
push F4 and try defending this with 28
seconds left you have to be able to
react to whatever white throws at you
and that's the problem with having you
know 30 seconds in a position like this
yep no I mean you're nailing it and and
I'm also wondering how slow
uh kimer will will will play this right
because when you're the one who's the
dictator in the position you can kind of
take your time and torture him you can
play F4 but you can also play a little
tickle with the
Bishops no I would go F4 I think get
down H4 you want it I mean I okay you're
right F4 F4 is probably the best but
what if black just sits F4 and I sit
what's your next move I think maybe F
takes G5 and H4 and I have a feeling
that that outside H Bond should deliver
the victory
it's fascinating because even with the
bishop being the wrong color Corner
you're not using that pawn to win you're
using that pawn to distract and
ultimately you win because you're going
to win this Pawn exactly exactly but he
doesn't go for it Bishop H doesn't go
for it taking his time trying to bleed
Black's clock down and then at some
point he's going to play the move F3
yeah and he might try to trap Black's
Bishop actually F3 and where does black
Bishop go whoa Bishop that's it that's
it he just the bishop that's actually
over he's got to go Bishop H3 and then
white drops back to D3 I was going to
say you you can even play G4 right away
or Bishop D3 and I think it's just over
okay holy can you play I think G4 first
is the is the cleanest because if Bishop
F1 then you go Bishop D3 he's not
getting out yes and the pun end game is
lost yeah wow exactly exactly Chen yeah
I remember the first time I lost an end
game to Mikel gavic yeah
exactly always have to come up with the
most like random
GM Robert Mel Robert hner in
1972 and what's funny about that story
is that Gary was there and Gary just
hated the grunfeld at the time I'm sorry
hated it absolutely despised he
detest
F1 Bishop F1 it's over um King and pawn
ending is easy money you bring the king
back to E3 and play F4 and just like
that there were only two left with
perfect scores Vincent kimer joins josam
Jose
Martinez that's going to be a thriller
in the next round we've got two early
favorites to win the whole thing here in
the playin stage um by the way what's
happened on the other boards hiar
Nakamura Drew
shimanov PTO Mario is not someone who
we've talked about that's an OG throwing
his hat in the
ring he's doing really well Sim Simon
Simon haime Santos latasa I don't know
where Simon came from is still playing s
t sah hakin who we were talking about
who did sell beat I think he beat ala
fuja earlier but now he's really really
suffering hi Miss Santos latasa of
course that name should be familiar to
people he did play the uh Challenger
section he did okay um he's been kind of
up and down recently but very very
talented Spanish
player and here he's uh got a position
that only he can win up a pawn another
rook and Bishop endgame is this one
enough I feel like this one is harder to
hold for black than maybe the engine
suggests makes it looks like it's close
but at some point white is going to
orchestrate E5 and things are going to
get
tricky yes although the more I look at
it the more that some is just he's
checking the bleep out of him check
check check check Alina llamba labomba
exactly and okay F five King F4 white is
maybe trying to push E5 but again
Samuel's like Over My Dead Body I'm
going to keep my Rook on A4 and keep
that pawn laterally pinned just like
Rook B4 Rook A4 okay but I feel like
White's gonna try to find some trick
here o Bishop D5 spicy but now he goes
back to
F7 how does white complicate the game
here I think it might just be a fortress
yeah I'm I'm coming around to that fact
I misspoke in thinking that it was
inevitable that E5 would happen right
you know what they say about
inevitability what's
that it's inevitable it always it always
gets you it all I don't know
inevitability that's right bit aous
Robert Frost yeah that is the truth I I
came up with that on the Fly um
but let's not let's not turn our back on
E5 because here's the thing if black if
black allows E5 white doesn't even have
to to win the make a trade like you can
sacrifice the ewn just to open up the
idea of progress and indeed now
look yeah but it's a Draw N that now now
it's enough that that's GNA be7 it's
actually just like a clean Fortress
white can't even push a single Pawn
because if white dips back to F4 with
this King black plays King F6 so
literally all you have to do is just
wait with your Bishop make sure that you
don't blunder your Bishop how many of
these games have been decided is Bishop
D1 and black pre moves Bishop B3 there's
no need to pre-move there's
increment it's just a
draw I and I agree this one is ending
perhaps with the uh with the karmically
correct result but I'll be honest I feel
like if Magnus is playing that as white
when he plays E5 and sacks the pawn da
after takes he would have had the Rook
on the sixth rank ready to play like F6
and would have just opened up the
position and and I I do feel like white
maybe white maybe made that a little bit
too easy for black I don't know I don't
know maybe that's just Magnus bitis no I
agree I mean there's a reason why Magnus
has risen has raised the level of
endgame technique to the point where now
we kind of expect players to convert up
upon particularly when their opponents
are in tie pressure but look at the
standings Danny I can't believe we don't
have anybody with four and a half we
have two players with perfect scores
they will face each other and then
there's this massive group of players
with four out of four with four out of
five it's crazy and and looks like maybe
we jinxed Peter when uh when we we
talked about how brilliant his chess was
today obviously we had David H join us
and show an absolutely awesome Victory
by Sidler as black against the Kings
Gambit and then he won with a mouse slip
so we weren't we weren't trying to jinx
you peace fitty you were playing the
best chess but losing your first game of
the day he's still sits uh with four
points though out of five not out of it
yet ums like but anyway back to this
position D my point was in time in time
pressure I wish there was some sort of
way to like play E5 and then keep the
pressure alive without
rushing I guess ultimately the king
comes in here but I felt like maybe
there was some way for white to try to
orchestrate some some counter chances of
course I'm just I'm just making stuff up
because we got no place else to go it's
a chess show
but it is show I'm I'm looking I'm just
seeing if there are any games still
going Alexander bortnik I think might
still be
playing lower boards no no he's oh he's
one wow he has one so he now has four
out of five as well he is part of that
huge group of players who are hot on the
tail of
Jose and Vincent kimer and a very
frustrating game for Peter
sidir okay I don't know what's wrong me
would you do that for the rest of the
day please
K accents I don't even know what country
is I want it all I want the full I want
the full uh menu of Da accents before
this day is through so all right if
you're just getting here the day is not
through yet we've uh we've still got a
lot of Chess ahead so yeah thanks for
being with
us wow what a round this was a very
eventful round huge shout out to kimer
and Martin
their game will be one to watch
obviously I mean we will be watching it
and uh just looking at that
mouthwatering selection of players with
four out of five Danny they will not go
gentle into that good night I'm looking
at ponomarov now bortnik has joined that
group hiar Nakamura has given up two
draws but still playing very solidly and
I think we're off I think we're off in
this very important sixth round yeah
perhaps the scariest name of the four
out of five players you see on your
screen obviously hikaro Nakamura people
his his reputation precedes him wherever
he goes but uh but that field is
absolutely crazy I've brought up the
game between our only two perfect scores
left Jo Jose Eduardo Martinez also known
as josam to the title Tuesday kids at
home taken on Vincent K as you said what
was it
Kar k k that's not even how you
pronounce it but I
we're adding to cbles that don't even
exist that's right you know
um the uh for a long time I I I
pronounced his name for for a long time
I said uh dubove for dubov uhhuh and and
I don't know why I just looked at denil
dubov and I that was I was I mean maybe
he's into it next time we talk to denil
I'll ask him like do you want me to call
you denil dubov instead of dubov let see
what he see what he
says yeah du sounds has a kind of a ring
to it right I mean it's romantic it's
like I don't know it's almost it's it's
not it's not Russian it's French dubov I
don't know I don't know where this show
went back to the position we've got
doubled and horrible looking pawns for
both players what is this line da teach
me well all I can tell you is that this
came out of a carocon that is literally
all that I know looking at this position
now this E6 idea that we saw from Jose
it is a pawn sacrifice and it is a
relatively typical idea across various
lines of the caroan but look at White's
clock he's got over 10 minutes left
something tells me that Jose is still in
his
preparation and this line was completely
unhinged if you if you rewind just a
couple of moves yeah to move seven after
Queen A5 check here the position is
still relatively normal B4 which is a
move that I don't understand at all I'm
not even going to pretend that I
understand what happens if black simply
takes on B4 but Vincent Kimber maybe
also didn't understand and didn't want
to understand and that's why he dropped
his screen back to A6 and this is where
white sacrifices the pawn E6 kind of a
classic positional sacrifice the Queens
are traded and I think it's very
instructive for newer players to see
that white actually does not play e
takes F7 check here because the point of
this sacrifice is to force one of
Black's pawns to E6 in order to make it
incredibly difficult for black to
develop his King side and yeah in
general Black's position is just kind of
riddled with weaknesses Danny so I
really like what I'm seeing here from
Jose very creative play I love it it's
also interesting because these double
pawns are are bad and dysfunctional for
black not just because of the pawns
themselves being weak but because they
they they block development as you said
whereas in in comparison to the white
double pawns these double pawns are not
in anybody's way they're not restricting
wh's development at all and they
actually hold some critical squares in
the center preventing this night for
example from maybe having an easy an
easy time so loved your breakdown B4
obviously a super interesting move if
you look at our our our opening ebal bar
it was the first move that that wasn't
that wasn't Theory basically B4 was
played and we immediately had had a game
that left opening opening oh no I guess
it didn't took a few more moves no it
was for some reason we're glitching out
just a little bit but yeah B4 was was
definitely not the most common move but
I I definitely like it for white as
well yeah and look at how Jose how
adroitly he's arranged his Knights the
Knight on F3 is holding down the E5
Square it's very very important in these
positions to make sure that black
doesn't essentially liberate his
position with e65 so right now that's
why Jose is thinking okay maybe white
and castle and allow E5 and then play a
calm move like Rook to E1 but the more
human move here is probably to either
Play Bishop F4 and try to clamp down on
the E5 square or the move that I think
will happen is Knight H to G5 uh in
order to meet E5 with Knight to E6
forking essentially forking a fork
forking the bishop on G7 as well as the
fork on C7 so a lot here to figure out
for both players it's a very rich
position and he plays Knight F4 okay
very similar move Knight F very nice
defensive response by
Vincent and black has a very active
position here all of the pieces are
essentially on white side of the
board yeah s that is s sarcasm that was
that was sarc for those who um but yeah
blacks pieces clearly developing exactly
where they want to be no this is not
ideal as you said well uh well well
explained and yeah you didn't want to
allow Knight E6 which as you pointed out
would have been a fork of a fork if you
ever forked a fork that's what it looks
like forking a fork with too many
threats so black instead had to retreat
this KN to the passive f8 Square
so yeah I mean I love it I love what's
happening here today for josam he's
clearly on form getting a lot of
positions that he's happy with up on the
clock pretty consistently as
well so yeah
yeah H6 now what an end game
but
okay it feels like subtly but
unmistakably the trend of the game is
now kind of favoring black the Knight
gets into F5 suddenly White's now
experiencing some problems with his
pawns the D4 Pawn is hanging and it
feels like Vincent has arranged his
Knights very very nice nightly nicely uh
the Knight on F5 is pressuring a lot of
Pawns the pawn on D4 the pawn on H4 now
Vincent can play Bishop F6 and he can
also open up another front on the queen
side with a move A5 so that pawn on B4
it's controlling a lot of squares but it
also kind of sticks out like a sore
thumb so don't be surprised to see the
move A5 in the immediate future for
black yeah good call the question is at
some point does white cash in the chips
and try to take back the pawn that was
sacrificed but I I I really don't want
to do that if I'm white because I'm not
after the pawn right I'm after the
pressure I'd rather I'd rather do things
like support my pawn and find ways to to
continue to bring pressure to these
squares rather than just trading pieces
but I really like your move A5 and the
more I the more I think about it the
more I agree that the direction of the
game trending Back to Black yeah Vincent
kimer so so strong he's gotten a lot
better uh at Blitz chess over the last
couple of years his chess.com rating now
hovers in like the 31 100 range and I
think we're kind of seeing the fruits of
his labor Vincent is one of those
players that flies under the radar and
then you wonder what his Fay rating is
it's like 2740 I mean that's literally
good enough to get into the tus steel
Masters he is I think number 10 or 11 in
the world and currently at his Peak
2738 is his classical rating maybe not
really known just yet as a rapid
juggernaut but I think that's going to
change um as we see him progress in the
realm of rapid and Blitz chess as
well agreed agreed Town population USP I
like it I like it here the weather's
nice in this in this town is we should
hang out here more often where we agree
no
snow there's no snow you
know there's there's
parks that are easy to access and clean
you know know wow yeah all right that
sounds like my definition of paradise
well as long as it includes Dan Danny
wrench it's my definition Paradise oh
you stop it you just you know you stop
it keep going keep going you you stop it
all right we head over to hikara
nakamura's game I guess just in time to
see what the computer thinks is a
blunder the move Pawn to C6 hiar down a
minute on the clock as well so what
exactly happened
here um D your thoughts just on the
current position the B5 Pawn is hanging
the C6 Pawn is passed but it's also kind
of surrounded so your thoughts well
there's a lot of calculation to do
because White's next move is going to be
either F2 F4 uh or in some cases even A3
A4 so I think the evaluation is very
misleading because black might have
let's play the move King f8 on uh the
analysis board if we can just to get our
sense of what is White's next move
actually going to be I think it is going
to be F4 and what is the point of f4
this forces the Knight to jump to C4 and
now White's Rook infiltrates the seventh
rank Rook to D7 and if black just kind
of continues to do nothing and play
Knight takes E3 already the white Bishop
jumps into
H5 and everything starts to collapse
Rook takes F7 and I have some news for
you F4 Knight C on the board David
paravan actually did play King f i kind
of chose it as a random move he played
it hiar responded with that
four C for some reason instead of
playing Rook D7 and look at this maybe
after Rook D7 he was worried about the
move Knight to B6 but apparently white
has this incredibly cold blooded
response Bishop to F3 what an
instructive move and if black plays
Knight takes D7
white plays C takes D7 rook d8 and at
the end of the line when all is said and
done the White Knight jumps into C6
containing black king and preparing to
promote the pawn what an easy line how
did hearu miss all of this line that uh
know that hikara missed no but I think
you're right you're right that must have
been what he missed because instead of
playing Rook D7 and going for this crazy
idea he settles on Bishop takes
C4 but that means in our current
position I mean
okay David is what going now doing
totally fine I mean David how is doing
totally fine so is David pravan anybody
whose name starts with a d is doing fine
today anybody whose name starts with a d
is having a great day we got a couple of
guys hosting the show you got a David
joining us
right um although C3 was a little bit
fast I wonder if there was an
opportunity to challenge the B file but
now we're going to get this
uh this the cwn is is going bye-bye
so I'm likeing car's chances again I am
too Rook takes C3 is threatened I don't
understand how this is
equal maybe it has something to do with
the move King to E7 but King E7 Danny is
always met with Rook D7 check King back
to E8 there are some tactics where if
the black king makes contact with the
white Rook then maybe Rook takes C6 was
possible in some moment but Rook A7 by
David prian what a move he is setting up
King E7 and The Rook is gonna be trapped
oh what an
idea that's actually how you stop it you
actually I think your only idea is to
try to protect the Rook with E4 E5 which
is actually nice
because CU if E4 black can't play E5
that opens up the F5 square and and all
kinds of problem and hikaro goes for it
E4 is like the only move I mean Rook A7
was such a clever resource but that's
not enough against iar Nakamura he's not
going to miss you know the prosaic King
E7 and suddenly black is running out of
resources because Danny after King E7 E5
black is going to lose the C3 Pawn no
this game is over hear
wins it's weird how quickly that fell
apart for black in the span of one move
in the span of one move if we if
we I guess you know Poetic Justice
served in that Hikaru was potentially
winning if he had found this crazy Rook
D7 idea earlier but let's look at your
move King E7 instead of Rook A7 because
I actually want to highlight that this
this was a nice idea Don's point was
that when you go to E8 obviously if
white repeats we have a draw and if you
do nothing black is threatening to take
on
C6 and then winning The Rook on D7 and I
and if you take
here well I guess that's what white
would have
done but
and you can understand baravan not
wanting to go for this I mean this does
not look like a pleasant position for
black at all so yeah yeah maybe Rook
takes C6 there would have afforded some
drawing chances but I think David just
completely forgot about the move E4 it
just fell out of his head this E4 E5
idea using Pawns in order to support
pieces that can be a very easy concept
to forget about and hikaro is going to
move to five out of six I apologize six
out of seven
no five out of six what am I say I
cannot count my bad hey the scoreboard
is right
there all
right hiar is going to be nine out of 17
after this round 21 out of 38 okay now
this is completely winning for white
completely
winning The Rook is protected which
means the bind remains you've got the
rook and the Knight
supporting this Pawn on C6 the C3 Pawn
is going to fall and now that the uh the
other lines have been opened up you also
have to start worrying about things like
this where this Rook slides over and and
gets frisky over there okay well if
Hikaru wins this he keeps Pace still a
full point behind the leader should
someone in the game between kimer and
Martinez get the dub we head back over
there awkward AF as the kids like to say
what's going going on with these pawns D
you said that pawn structure is
overrated explain yourself I mean I I
don't even know if you can refer to this
as a pawn structure this is this would
be an insult to pawn structures to call
what black has a pawn structure I
actually think now the trend of the game
probably favors Jose it feels like he's
kind of stabilized the situation and now
he jumps into G5 with his Knight he's
got a big time Advantage as well Vincent
basically has all hands on De
in order to protect that E6 Pawn that E6
Pawn is essentially the bane of Black's
existence moves The Rook back to d8 Jose
could sink his other Knight into E5 that
seems very tempting I was wow what want
to highlight it I'm glad you said it
because my my my mouse I wanted to
highlight it maybe maybe with some
different colors I don't know what I'm
into girl I don't know but yeah if this
Knight pops into E5 you're just you're
just like frightened about forking
possibilities in the position although
it is funny because the Knight goes to
E5 and black goes to D6 and
then maybe this and then this goes seven
and maybe black sacrifices The Exchange
but also kn5 black can play Rook A8 to
C8 and try to push C5 and if blacken
push C5 and kind of dislodge or at least
undo the support behind some of White's
outposts in the center yeah that's also
not forget that Vincent is up a pawn so
in a long distant future where he's
somehow able to improve his Pawn
structure again Pawn structure that
we're not even calling a pawn structure
yeah he does have an extra Pawn maybe
that makes its presence felt Rook B1 by
hose I'm predicting a draw I think the
likeliest outcome is some sort of a draw
but you never
know I think the time pressure obviously
will uh will be interesting if if if
Jose can maintain this Edge but I love
that you pointed out C5 da because I
know I've been obsessed with Pawn
sacrifices that don't work today but
this is something you should be thinking
about even if you can't take it back as
black because there may be ideas where
you take and then you get E5 in and and
if if possible to liberate your position
given that you are up a pawn you would
never do that right now again I'm just
I'm speaking purely hypothetically here
uh but something to something to watch
out for no you're absolutely right C5
and E5 trying to get active particularly
in your opponent's time pressure I think
is the reason why Jose is pausing and
getting his Knight to E5 and now the
move Rook to
C3 can be considered and
C5 by the way why is C5 impossible in
this very position oh I guess it's D
takes D takes C5 he's blundered it too
Pawn takes and you can't take the
night oh but will Jose see it will Jose
simply take on C5 I jinxed them Danny
just when I asked the question he
blunders with C5 and he SP into
existence we have kimer on camera right
now oh my God you see the shake of his
head he realizes for the first time that
he's blundered that was like a wait what
he took the oh and then he he he said
something explic of in his head that I
won't say out loud for the kids but he
you know it was in German it was in
German and um that's what happened
it's not over yet because now the Knight
is hanging I think Jose has to play Rook
to E1 here Danny in order to support the
Knight and the problem for Vincent is
technically he can take on C5 but I
think that just runs into Rook to B8 and
there are way too many threats against
this King there are way too many Fork
threats this position is forking awful
yeah it's forking awful it's about it's
about it's about forking time you
brought one of those one of those
references you know it's been it's been
all forking day with you
um that was pretty good Rook Rook C to
A8 kimer realizing that c Pawn is
Untouchable probably because of the
exact idea you highlighted The Rook will
go to B8 and the floodgates open so oh
my
gosh
dude I think this is Josh's game now oh
my gosh Danny there are some incredible
lines here that we might have to show
after the game but Rook takes A1 Rook
takes A1 and C6 was actually a
possibility but instead Jose simply
drops his KN back to F3 there was a
possibility mates there oh my God that's
crazy but this is still good this is
still good for white agreed looks like J
from Rook G8 that's made on G6
is I hope you're uh I hope you're happy
to see me right here's Johnny Rook to oh
my
gosh it's over and josa moves to six of
six we are going to show that line you
just said because I soon as you said it
I calculated it in my head and I
realized your whole point was that the
Knight goes to F7 and guards D6 right oh
wait no no I C7 actually you go C7
because if black plays Knight D6 now you
play Knight F7 check deflecting the
Knight so you're right Danny it's just
one move later but here's the other idea
if black plays Rook to C1 if I'm looking
at this right Rook to
C4 intercepting The Rook Rook takes C4 D
takes C4 Knight D6 and again Knight F7
check is just gorgeous and look at that
Knight on f8 and how out of the game it
is you just can't play an entire game of
chess with a knight as bad as the one on
f8 but this would have been a gorgeous
he wins it in a more utilitarian fashion
let's see it oh yeah boom boom goes to
Dynamite
there you go all right wow well josam
moves to six of six he benefits from a
blunder there by Vincent kimer We we
forgot that it really all fell apart you
were predicting draw you jinxed it and
kimer blunder
C5 we'll
uh we we'll throw that one into on your
tab I I have I have plenty on my tab you
have plenty on your tab so I've got
plenty on my tab already in regards to
game of jinx but Wesley so beats Gregor
O parin So Wesley keeps Pace with the
leaders we see with Five Points Nakamura
still playing hear Nakamura is still
playing which means something went wrong
here potentially he just has
okay I think we expected that one to be
over
earlier Sidler versus bortnik is another
interesting game that seems to be
entering the time Scrabble phase no they
just made a draw just as I say that they
made a
draw and what about F versus pamario
which is which is actually a rematch
they played in the Isle of Man
tournament just recently as hikaro wins
his game let's do it fuja Pon Maria
hikaro Nakamura wins now also in that
massive group of people with five points
or it's going to be massive here as I
say it look how many draws there were
this Danny look at that tactic Rook A7
check King D6 King E8 King King takes E6
this is Sexy Can I even say that I think
I can you can earned it it's legal to
say it look at this he sacrifices The
Exchange and grabs the mating net before
before anything happens wow that's
actually gorgeous that is that is one of
the best games of the day so far fuja
gets
up I think that's a secret lab chair
there he's uh taking a taking a quick
break and to stretch it out but uh fua
with a massive Victory there incredible
game alaza fua trying to recover from
that early loss he moves I think to four
and a half out of six I still can't get
over this is just some lovely endgame
tactics here but look at that big group
with five out of six that includes vid
by the way who we haven't given the
attention that he's deserved do maybe we
can at least keep an eye on his game in
the next round FD it with five out of
six no rest for the wary straight off to
of Steel two and a half we tournament
doesn't matter these players right back
in the office speaking of the office is
this a
draw
oh or did he just
blunder I think white is winning in this
game between Anton and
lavic lavic throws actually no these I
think this thing might have already been
winning for white um The Rook on A1 was
sort of outmaneuvered by the Black part
there I've lost end games like that oh
man those are painful um you think it's
an easy
draw but not so fast and here white
white is gonna block the checks and it's
over lovely lovely conversion David Anon
still very much in the conversation he's
got four and a half points out of
six what a
tight yeah go ahead I'm just gonna I'm
just going to show how instructive this
is because I think
okay this this this move here
immediately points out the problem when
when The Rook goes to B2 that in these
Rook endings this is such an easy
mistake to make that you you sort of
assume that both Rooks will have plenty
of chances to to give checks but this is
actually a very common problem because
now the white Rook has the ability to
create the L the Lucina idea the Lucha
idea where it can Shield the king from
checks either on the E or the G file
while also keeping an eye on the pass
Pawn whereas the black Rook has no other
purpose besides guarding the pawn and is
helpless in stopping white from
advancing so take a good snap shot of
this for those of our our our students
out there in in the chat this is an a
game that is that is uh easy to Mis
evaluate but is almost always losing
sorry very well explained Danny not I
think this is a very pertinent Point um
you know these tournaments are a good
opportunity to brush up on your endgame
Basics and anytime you see rook and pawn
versus rook and pawn it's so easy to
assume oh it's just a draw by the way
just wanted to point out Fabiana Carana
having himself a really difficult event
he's lost three games in a row and
that's not a testament to Fabiana Carana
and how bad he is this is a testament to
how incredibly brutal this event is if
you're having a bad day it's just like a
nobody is safe right nobody's safe
nobody's afraid of anybody this
tournament these top GMS they sense
weakness and they pounce Fabiana Carana
will have to live to fight another day
um he is just getting
destroyed just like that we move you
said we need to take a look at vidit who
did it he's now number one vid it you
did it you're the number one player in
India congratulations on all the success
you've had this year we hope it
continues as you prepare and roll into
the candidates tournament but now he has
the white pieces against AAR Nakamura
but on the point I was going to say like
obviously it's tough because one of the
things that changed about this year's
format is we went from six events
qualifying for a seventh live final now
there's only four events and so less
chances less room for mistakes and so if
you don't get yourself on track into
that division one cycle where you're
able to consistently compete for the top
prize it's uh it's gonna hurt so tough
day for
Fabby tough day for Fabby indeed and vid
um he and hikaro both with five out of
six this is a big game not a game I
think that vid just wants to give up a
draw and he's got the white pieces vidit
so good at putting pressure with white
and hear Nakamura playing kind of a tame
opening a I think this started out as a
BOGO Indian now we have this kind of
very traditional uh Queens Indian setup
with the bishop faneto on B7 we will
probably see E5 from Hikaru Nakamura and
a lot of central tension here can black
take on D4 and start harassing that pawn
on e4 with Knight to C5 m or has vidit
foreseen everything vidit did it did it
vid it vid did did it right now he looks
like he's doing it in a uh like a like a
like a cell of some kind that is like a
looks like a wall of of gray
cement a dungeon let vid it out vid it
blink twice if you're
okay oh man I'm
worried yeah okay um well as you said
it's a BOGO Indian E5 strikes at some
point the tension will break and black
plays this move C6 which at first kind
of looks ugly you block your own Bishop
but is really really sort of key to to
keep the White Knight specifically out
of the D5 square but it does surrender
space to White and if if vid it wants to
be all in here da at some point I mean
you're just you're just at some point
you're going for
it okay Queen G5 threatening Knight to
F5 this is a very important very
important trick that everybody should be
aware of anytime there's a queen
that's x-raying the king like that and
there's a knight on H you have to think
about Knight H Knight F5 he car offering
a queen trade I actually think Viet
should be happy with a queen trade here
trade those queens and maybe push D5 and
there's a big problem for hiar Nakamura
Danny that we have to show if VD plays
D5 here black cannot play the move C5
which is obviously what you want to play
because after a knight B5 there's no way
to defend the D6 pawn and vdet misses
the opportunity but okay he's still
slightly better I still think White's in
the driver seat in this end
game that's a massive point though that
was a massive Point D5 was a was a huge
opportunity missed there by
vidit and yes still in the driver seat
but the tension is a lot easier for
black here now if you take they will
always recapture with the D Pawn
eliminating that D6 weakness and hikaro
trying to go after some dark squares for
his own
Knights wow yeah why why is is still in
control
but but you hate saying those things
when you're playing hikaro you never
want to have a butt you never want to
say like my position's still good but
right well you just never know around
you know you can turn it around in any
position at any moment it doesn't matter
if he's worse hikaro is always thinking
about playing for a win but I'm
impressed with the time management both
players have plenty of time here so this
is going to be kind of a Slow Burn uh I
don't think anything's going to be
decided in the next couple of moves I
think we're in for a long long end game
here we also have that uh Jose versus
Wesley so game Danny I'll give you the
call shall
weer we did we checked in with vid it
now we're gonna head over
to to
josam whose birthday is it it's Jose's
birthday happy uh Happy Birthday to uh
Jose and what a birthday present to be
able to play in this tournament
and to have uh to have six out of six he
is turning hey uh 25 today happy
birthday to Jose happy birthday to Jose
not a bad way to spend your day if
you're six of six right now you'd be
happy with a draw at this point against
Wesley
so it's always funny to think about what
score will be needed to uh to guarantee
yourself action but at this point you
really just don't want to be completely
eliminated because if you if you get
yourself into division two or even
division three you have a chance to to
to upgrade yourself directly via
knockout play on day two and that of
course is tomorrow if you didn't know
what you were
doing now you do now you know if you
didn't know now you know you're spending
tomorrow with me and da because that's
right we've got match play it's gonna be
awesome yes it's going to be awesome Yes
um if it's anything like today we're
going to have non-stop action and
speaking of non-stop action we have a
similar structure here as with the
hikaro vid game except the Queens are on
the board I would say that white is
maybe a tiny bit better but honestly
vid's position is very or sorry Jose's
position is very very healthy Rook fd8
I'm just impressed at the confidence
that he's playing with it just seems
like he's always in control of the game
this game included if he's able to push
D5 Danny that eradicates the final
weakness in his position the D6 Pawn
as long as that pawn remains on the
board white can pretend that he has a
slight Advantage Wesley is trying to go
Knight B1 and Knight C3 which is a very
very typical maneuver in these types of
positions trying to fix that pawn on D6
and if Jose can get D5 in I think he
basically solves all of the problems of
his opening he's not even in a rush I
think he's going to wait for the proper
moment to push D5 this game might fizzle
out pretty quickly into a draw if that
happens yeah well said I love how you
kind of you know you you painted the
canvas there for everyone to understand
the Dynamics of if white prevents D5
then white has long-term winning chances
based on the weakness of the D6 Pawn
highlighting some ideas like doubling
Rooks if black gets D5 all structural
differences go away and you've got two
pawns on the king side two Pawn sorry
two pawns on the queen side four pawns
on the king side for each player so but
now now it's getting a
little there's other the thing about the
position is there's other ways to kind
of uh yeah play you can also keep an eye
on the C4 Pawn which kind of stops
Knight to C3 right
um yes that's exactly right you could
play Rook to C6 for example Knight C3
rook dc8 and the C4 Pawn is essentially
simultaneously a strength and a weakness
it's a strength in that it holds it's
counterpart on D6 it essentially fixes
that pawn but it's also a weakness
because you can not defend the C4 Pawn
with another Pawn Danny as long as
White's Queen is sitting on B3 you're
not able to play the move Pawn B3 and so
black could also pile up on the C4 Pawn
but Jose he goes for the more
conventional approach and I think we're
just going to get liquidation and very
very likely we'll get a draw in this
game yeah which would be a very
successful result for Jose josam given
that he's currently a point ahead of the
entire field so he would remain at least
a half a point ahead of his nearest
Chasers and we get down to these final
rounds remember there are nine rounds in
total and so we're getting down to it
we've only got a few rounds left after
this wow um actually this this is the
seventh round so we've got two rounds
left after this oh my God the day went
by so fast damn
girl damn
girl I mean time is flying Jose with
every draw he inches closer and closer
to an incredible performance in this
tournament and I would even argue that
he's almost drawing this from a position
of strength I mean he's got the defile
there's no reason that black needs to be
begging for a draw here and there it is
a draw has been
agreed
repetition repetition killed the cat I
think that's what it was or was a
curiosity either way the moves repeat
josham holds on to his lead Wesley so
probably not super unhappy either he
slows down the tournament leader and
keeps himself in Striking Distance we
could go anywhere we can I'm going to
quickly flash some boards before for
your eyes we've got vidit and Hikaru GUI
still pushing a little bit kimer as
white trying to rebound from his last
game remember he lost to josam this
doesn't look
great repetition he's on a
mission he's got Wesley so on the down
low
Vincent uh you know
ferer and the dier and Casper porin
uh I this is the wheels are coming
off very very quickly all right Don
you're too weak too slow on the mic
speaking of which let's go to Lauren
fres and see how he's doing we've got
we've got fres here those Rhymes Danny
they were flimsier than the DOR and a
Boeing
737 I just it's not
even it's not even a relevant reference
right
now that's true do I ever make relevant
references when was the last time I made
a relevant reference okay let's look at
the
game Lauren FR for those who don't know
the reference too weak too slow just
Google the video uh but uh right now
fra not a bad position here against
Yu yeah I mean Knight takes G5 Bishop
takes D1 okay what does white
do yeah I okay he goes for
it
I I really wish there was some sort of
crazy tactic going on here but it just
doesn't look like it's it's in the cards
but I don't understand if black plays
Bishop takes
D1 what is why oh Knight takes
F7 ah this is actually really
interesting Knight F7 Rook F7 Bishop F7
and okay black cannot take on F7 with a
queen because he drops
The Rook on d8 and if black plays King
takes F7 laon's idea is to play Queen
takes H6 and suddenly he's got a ton of
threats he's threatening to win Black's
Queen the bishop on D1 is very flimsy
maybe black can hold this position but
this is actually very very dicey and I
really really like the creativity that
the French GM is playing with here
doesn't look fun at all uh and note that
you kind of have to take on F7 before
any other moves likely because of Queen
takes H6 I'm assuming there's something
nasty there although I do not see a
Checkmate I admit but the point is I
think that line Don you just gave is
kind of forced although Rook takes D2 in
in between also doesn't work CU yeah
because then the bishop hangs in the end
so wow what a creative little line here
from the Frenchmen we see the position
on the board by the way it's happening
it's happening it's
happening wait is it happening what's
currently on the board it's happening
Bishop takes up7 is on the board wowza
and after King takes F7 Queen takes H6 I
think that is the position in which
yuang will have to figure out some
defense against Queen H7 check
apparently King F7 Queen H6 Queen to E7
holds on by the skin of Black's teeth
but will he be able to spot this move
Queen E7 Queen H7 King F6 wow look at
this line Queen H4 now if you step back
with a king white can play Rook takes
x-ray defense for newer players very
important how the queen is actually
defending the Rook but black has the
move
G5 insane Queen H6 check King F7 and
it's a Perpetual check
Jesus what a draw what an
absolute insane an absolutely insane
position here Yong is going to going to
think think about it for just a minute
before he enters the fry of those crazy
t ICS but I like the creativity from
Lauren
fres uh having a good day playing decent
chess again if you're just tuning in you
can see it's josam Jose Eduardo Martinez
the birthday boy if you didn't know he's
turning 25 years of age today so I
remember when I turned 25 20 years ago
you know um
that's that's how old I am you mean
three years ago not exactly
but um feels that
way okay well josam is the is the clear
leader aor Nakamura we haven't checked
in with him and vid GUI in a minute
that's a name that's a game of two very
big names wow vidit is completely
outplaying
Hikaru I mean if my first impressions
are halfway accurate just look at look
at the domination that white has exerted
in the center that KN Danny the PA D6 is
a hug
for and vid continues to press now A7 is
hanging black is on the cusp of falling
apart yeah this is a really tough
position to hold it it it almost I would
say it feels even worse than it looks
right like how do you keep finding moves
here obviously hiar Nakamura is someone
who we've seen do it a lot
but what a what a
nightmare but how does white
keep pressing I mean this is a situation
that everybody has been in against hiar
Nakamura you feel like you should be
winning you feel like it must be there
where's the win you start looking for it
and suddenly you end up in time pressure
and
Hikaru I mean hiar is probably thinking
about how to play this for a win and
knowing him with black he's not only
thinking how do I survive this he's
already thinking how can I try to
Swindle this game and turn the tables
let's see what videt comes up with here
yeah I I agree and I'm I'm thinking on
that note what exactly is vid going to
come up with because as bad as the
position looks for black I'm having
trouble finding I mean the
obvious five was an idea that I had to
create a past pun but it's probably not
good I feel like why can do better than
that but now three minutes for vided you
see this is what I'm talking about it's
very very easy to get bogged down in
these situations hi Caro always poses
problems
in any V drops to C3 excellent move
keeping all the assets of
his and oh Danny Knight C2 Knight B4
Knight C6 is a huge manuver that's the
plan okay I was sitting here racking my
brain with where's the progress what's
next and you just solved it Knight to C2
Knight to B4 Knight to C6 that that's
lights out you put that pony on C6 and
and black black will will say put me out
of my misery
taking C6 is never an
option you find it he's still thinking
two minutes 40 seconds he's got to put a
move
on go for it Knight C2 Knight B4 Knight
C6 this is it the problem with the
Knight on C6 everyone is you can't ever
take it and be happy to to talk about it
because then you get a protected pass
Pawn on the sixth ranked regardless of
how white captures back I don't even
know which one would be better so this
is this is
devastating I'm looking at his clock
though still plenty of time right not to
overly sensationalize it and he's slowed
down he's gone back to E4 I feel like
we've been here before I think we have
literally I think we been here before um
not figuratively literally literally no
maybe not actually The Rook wasn't on B1
it was over on E1 maybe anyway but he
doesn't see this plan this is this is
actually really working in hi Caro's
favor because your idea of Knight C2
Knight B4 Knight C6 clearly not
something vidit saw or he would have
gone for it yeah he just didn't spot the
maneuver it's one of those things Danny
when you point it out you can't unsee it
you're literally you see the Knight
beckoning to you I me please put me on
C6 but it's harder to spot that maneuver
when there's like six or seven different
options and I'm starting to get
seriously worried now for vid's clock in
his position he's down to 90 seconds he
has to trade on F6 and that's a big blow
to his winning chances because that
night on e4 that was a big night yep and
okay Rook A6 excellent move attacking D6
still trying still poking still prodding
and he might put a rook on C6 rather
than a knight on C6 which is the next
best thing yeah agree you like it you
gotta put a rook on it that's it that's
what you do um that's right we should we
haven't even talked about the fact this
is a little bit of a mini candidate it's
preview both of these guys will be
playing in Toronto at the FED candidates
not exactly the same time controller
format but still interesting to see vid
and hikaro throw down
um vidit I think feels confident again
about his position Hikaru on the clock
Rook to C6 is actually a really a really
tough thing to deal with
extremely good no no yeah go on I I just
the A7 Pawn also very weak
that's another problem that's another
enemy at black
skates
Y no I was going to say once that Rook
gets to C6 it's just so permanent you
you don't even really want to take it
with a knight if you're black because
that might even open up more more
problems so this is going to be super
painful vid it probably follows with
another Rook maybe the idea of putting
the Rook on C6 da opens up his eyes to
the idea of bringing the Knight around
to C6 or even A6 at that point if
somehow black is still holding on so I'm
I'm back in the camp of thinking this
this looks like a game that vid it
should be able to get this is going to
be super tough even for hikaro to
hold yes white is still in the realm of
probably being technically winning hearo
investing essentially his entire time
Advantage trying to figure out the right
way to defend the D6 Pawn he plays the
most obvious move which is Rook to D7 I
think Karu his saving chances are tied
in with using his Knight and jumping
into E4 but he can't do that yet because
he's got to defend all of the weaknesses
in his position I think we might see
Rook to C6 by vidit and maybe Hikaru can
just essentially ignore okay F3 but now
he's allowed maybe the move E4 and maybe
Hikaru can create some counterplay on
the king side I'm not sure that F3 was
really a necessary move it might
actually have the opposite effect of
helping black create counterplay but
hekaru goes passive he was completely
passive with Knight E8 and I think Rook
C6 okay I think you're right I think I
think E4 was E4 was the key hikaro going
for different
way is coming E4 is coming but not I
couldn't tell if you were joking about
hikaro playing for the win now but you
know what I wouldn't put it past him if
this KN gets to E4 now you're really
you're really struggling he car Mo he
missed that Knight H6 was a threat
trying to earn himself a Tempo Rook to
F4 no of course hear was thinking about
how to play for a win here as well but
Knight F2 coldblooded defensive move by
vidit preventing E4 and hikaro has to go
Knight F6 I think he has to go Knight F6
and push E4 at all costs and hope that
he gets some sort of Perpetual check in
the resulting Rook end game yeah Knight
F6 is risky everybody because it loses
the D6 Pawn but to DA's Point Knight F6
Rook D6 E4 let's go right okay nope
G5 okay H3
H5 will happen H3 H5 also I guess if the
D6 Pawn is no you can't take C4 because
the Knight would hang on F6 so yeah no I
was right if Knight F6 Rook D6 E4 really
would have been Black's only
option Rook to A3 vidit defending
laterally he wants to situate his Knight
on e4 I think Rook A3 is actually a very
understandable move apparently there was
the immediate C5 and D6 but try breaking
through like that with 50 seconds on the
clock you want to minimize your risk if
you're white yeah still also human being
perspective it's it's usually good
practical advice that you don't want to
change the nature of a position when
you're much better until you're 100%
concretely sure that you've calculated
it through because otherwise you know
shuffle Shuffle around let your opponent
suffer usually that's the better
practical approach especially when when
we're getting under time
pressure okay Rook D7 maybe hikaro had
the move Knight to F6 I think he's got
to deploy his Knight Knight F6 and I'm
not sure what vid is doing here vid is
shuffling his pieces back and forth but
he's made absolutely no progress Danny
over the last couple of moves and I know
we were laughing about it but if hearu
plays E4 under the right circumstances
it actually becomes a very double-edged
game yeah and now hikaro plays Rook to
D4 I'm not sure black is
worse and and I think AAR probably knows
it too that he's gotten his chances
vidit let the grip slip vidit he did it
he let it slip uh oh to
many now black is definitely playing for
a win this is just unbelievable like
honestly how Hikaru does this is just
every time every time it's literally
Insanity it's insanity but yeah I mean
it's still very double-edged I mean
black could also lose this game H4 very
risky move trying to go Knight H5 and
Knight F4 and here comes aaru's Knight
wow wow V it did it he's gonna actually
I don't know which which check he wants
he could do Knight G3 or Knight of4
depending
on yeah I mean depending on what white
Does vid is trying to calculate taking
the D6 Pawn he doesn't go for it he
backs up now King F4 it might be a
problem and the King infiltrates The
Rook infiltrates the second rank Black's
going to win this game this is insane
this is insane takes takes and King
takes off three and White's King is
under a Monumental attack Here Comes
Knight to G3
check Rook D2 is a huge C4 Pawn is also
hanging by the way it's over Rook
D2 Rook D2 picks up the Knight wow Rook
Che is met with Knight F4 now did I call
it or what I told you he was playing for
a win it's it's crazy it's absolutely
crazy that that happened and hikara
Nakamura does it again a position where
he's at at one point almost lost right
not just clearly worse like it's almost
a lost position with acurate play like
it was it was
over but clearly apparently apparently
Vincent kimer won his game I forgot who
he was playing and VD it you can just
send the exasperation there like really
I lost that one I let that one slip away
and he joins sing porin oh he beat porin
okay fua
won jeez David Anton won Dominguez Perez
is taken on bordnick that's one of the
only games still going so we'll head
over to there although it's over Sasha
wins opposite Cod Bishops but too far
apart there is no blockade here Magnus
doesn't believe in him anyway no such
thing as a fortress black wins and bort
also keeps Pace beats Dominguez in an
Aline with the black pieces huge win but
unfortunately your reward is that you're
stuck in that massive group of players
with five and a half out of seven yeah
taking a look at the standings you see
obviously Martinez was the only person
who hasn't lost no longer perfect but
six and a half out of seven is is
usually pretty good especially on his
birthday birthday again happy birthday
to josam But Here Comes Hikaru obviously
with six of seven along with Vincent
Kimber who's only lost is to josam right
so
uh so I don't even know what else to say
I'm sorry that round just like took took
away my logical thinking there for a
minute that was crazy that round spoke
for itself I agree the round spoke for
itself and now we're going to let
someone else speak for us because Donny
and I clearly need a break with how that
thing came to an end we are now once
again joined by grandmas David Hal you
know him you love him not just because
he brings you the uh the amazingly
instructive anecdotes in our game review
section but because his accent is just
so
sexy oh Donnie so much pressure now
you've made me self-conscious but uh
thank you for the kind words I've been
listening to your delet tones for the
last few hours and I've been loving it
so thank you for bringing
us you know what I'm gonna I'm gonna say
you're welcome that I haven't butchered
an English accent today I think only
once so you know I did it because I I
could see you in our studio here kind of
listening in the background and I didn't
I didn't want you to you know get too
frustrated with that bad accent a I
caught it just after Dan Dan's
yaser either well
David yeah we're going to turn over to
you let you bring us some game review
obviously we can't follow all the games
especially in this play in Swiss format
so take it away good sir let us know uh
let us know what what we missed yeah I
mean there's so many story lines there
are so many great players that
unfortunately we're not able to cover
all of the games I wanted to uh just
mention that Christopher Yu won in 12
moves earlier in the event a brilliant
win for Christopher U there a bit of a
blunder by his opponent uh but uh also a
shout out to jam on his birthday and
xuen Jun uh women's world champion who
also played on her birthday today but
this game comes from uh one of the
players you mentioned just towards the
end there of this round l Dominguez who
did just fall to another defeat and I
wanted to highlight the uh just the
cruel nature of Rapid chess how things
can turn around so quickly in this
position black is totally winning and he
could have played one of the moves of
the day if he had spotted the cruel the
cunning Rook takes A6 a deflection if
White's Rook takes then it's all the
checks in the world you start with a
bishop and then you zigzag your way
towards the white king the white king
can go nowhere you edge closer and when
the time is right you strike you check
and you pick off this black uh this
white Rook sorry in the corner black is
simply winning upper bishop and multiple
pawns but chess is so harsh and he
missed this lenia Dominguez a few moves
later if we fast forward to the end game
it was the same move Rook takes a s A6
which cost him Rook takes Pawn If
instead he had found uh the move Rook to
E4 or F4 he would have had a winning
Advantage but Rook takes A6 and look how
brutal this is a check from White on G1
black king moves The Rook comes in and
the final mistake Bishop to G5 this
bishop was whipped off and an
Unstoppable Bor promotion chess is so
harsh especially at this time
control rapid chess breaking hearts
right there you're breaking it down
David I could get I could get used to
this game review segment I appreciate it
um you got any other you got any other
jokes for us or
anything uh I'm not as spontaneous as
you Danny I'm not I'm not as smooth as
Dan either with the Impressions but how
about this a Spanish magician uh said
that he'll disappear on the count of
three he went uh one two and disappeared
Without a
Trace W someone mute mute D's microphone
please David we love you we'll see you
we'll see you later I don't know if we
have you again today but we'll catch up
with you tomorrow either way uh
D you know what you know what is
interesting and great though is our
official browser sponsor Opera is the
browser for chess players if you don't
have it download it use it today it
comes with chess integrated that's right
chess.com is integrated in both the
mobile and desktop version and Opera
guarantees that the chess Community is
only a tap away with that integration
it's free to download use the command
chess browser and chat now to be taken
there that looks pretty sexy I love
seeing that green pond as a default
built-in browser option appreciate your
browser we appreciate your support we
appreciate that we still have two rounds
ahead the drama is very real hikaro
Nakamura is storming storming back right
now who's going to win it all don't go
anywhere more from the playin and our
final two rounds when we
[Music]
return
a
[Music]
1 2
and
[Music]
oh
two rounds to go and wouldn't you know
it's hikara Nakamura there at the end
right now of course competing against
the leader of the event to this point
the birthday boy josam Jose Eduardo
Martinez Danny wrench alongside d if you
enjoyed the break thanks for sticking
with us
da I saw you were eating some chips I'm
Jelly I'm Jelly for I'm starving I am
having some New York Bagel crisps Bagel
Cris not sure what about them makes them
New York but specifically what yeah yeah
you throw New York on it and I don't
know it's a little more desirable for
some people who are into that I don't
okay Queen to G6 is on the board it
looks like Hikaru was trying to give Jos
a bit of a taste of his own medicine
with one of these kind of obscure French
kocon approaches with the white
pieces yeah and we have a very strange
endgame Josh has had his share of
unconventional Pawn structures uh this
tournament he's had that insane Caron
game against Vincent kimer and now he's
sort of on the receiving end of some
pretty bad Pawn structure and it's an
interesting moment now Danny will he
take on C3 which is sort of the
conventional French move but I actually
think in this particular end game my
inclination would be to keep the bishop
pair and drop my Bishop back to E7 but
then again I ain't josam josam ain't
me and uh yeah that's it that's all I
have to say I will clarify real quick we
don't need an analysis board but I'm
just going to Thun run everybody through
the fact that it was actually a Trum
palski the games started right as we
were returning from the break so we
missed the opening move which is funny I
didn't see the position until I was
looking at a French structure this was
the first position I saw and I admit not
putting the move order together I
recognize now that this this clearly
came from what what had to be some sort
of obscure not exactly French move order
although it could have maybe been like a
McCutchen kind of Bishop G5 Bishop B4
French anyway doesn't matter it was a
chowski we have a bad Pawn structure for
black and Hikaru Nakamura trying to win
and overtake the
leader yeah and this is the way to do it
you get an unbalanced position I think
hear is probably pretty happy
bose2 but I'm not sure that I would rush
with B4 in fact I definitely would not
rush with B4 because the bishop wants to
drop back to B6 anyway and later on
black could start chipping away at that
queenside pawn chain with A7 A5 so you
actually don't want to throw this move
in until you have to maybe H4 uh having
played Hikaru a million times Hikaru
loves
to play moves like H4 in order to slow
down the progress and immobilize the G6
Pawn make it a lot easier to attack I'm
voting for
H4 yeah hikaro also prefers the okay
right as I say that he takes the more
direct approach I I was going to say I
really like your move and I think Hikaru
often prefers a little bit of mystery to
his magic because in a lot of practical
moments fast time controls the more
opportunities you give your opponent to
go wrong often do so hikaro right as we
say all that actually took the most
forcing approach rather than a move like
H4 which would have maybe threatened
Bishop D3 and instead we're getting a
very very forcing forcing L maybe he
just wants B4 and Knight E2 and and King
up and he's just going to get really
aggressive here with a with a rapid
development yeah I mean H4 is possible
even now uh the point being you're
inviting a trade which seems to be
desirable for black but on the other
hand White's really expanding on the
king side and later on um if H4 G takes
H4 happens white can expand with the
pawns F4 G4 F5 later down the line that
kingside pawn storm might be really
really really unpleasant so a lot of big
decisions uh to be made here for Hikaru
which is why he's investing uh so much
time in these early opening decisions
this will really dictate the subsequent
course of this queenless middle
game yeah I like it well said and
go for H he likes your plan it it is it
is funny cuz it's it's counter to
whatever you would say conventional
wisdom at least conventional wisdom you
would try to pass on to students or
beginners that you don't want to UND
double your opponent's pawns but I
really like your point that after the
capture if we want to just show the
line the point is this structure is
still so advantageous for white because
F4 G4 the Knight can be behind the pawn
eventually you're probably punching
through with F5 this PA PA here is going
to be so strong
so you sort of gain one massive
Advantage by giving your opponent the
opportunity to liquidate the weakness of
the double Pawn so so I like it I'm just
I'm just validating and agreeing and
adding my own way to say the same thing
you just did but worse happy that's
validating is good and what a validating
performance bar Hikaru who comes back in
the previous game against vidit from a
miserable position where we thought he
had no winning chances it was a just a
chef's kiss of a game by vidit but
that's not enough Yaro needs to be
beaten you know 15 times in order to
actually win and get that one on the
cross table in the end vid gets a zero
on the cross table he doesn't even pull
out a draw and that's just what heura
does to
you well as you see there there's
there's uh only one player with six and
a half out of seven that of course is
josam the guy playing the black pieces
here hiar Nakamura in control of his own
fate let's go to Vincent Ker's game
versus Wesley
so yeah go ahead don't tell us how you
really feel simplification
simplification riveting riveting
position riveting CH no this one looks
like it is headed toward a peaceful
result and it is one of the Dynamics of
this event remember we are here all week
if you're just tuning in it is an 8-day
extravaganza that is about to go down
with the chessel Masters the first event
of the 2024 Champions chess tour we
start with the play and then you move to
match play so it is I I'm just
justifying a little bit of once the
players have a little bit of their next
goal in sight which is really to qualify
to the next day keep things alive I'm
not surprised that some of them are
choosing slightly more peaceful chess
and maybe not not mixing it up
unnecessarily long-winded way of saying
a draw probably secures for both of
these guys better chances that they're
going to be competing for top spots
tomorrow yes it's a mutually beneficial
result and it's not like they're not
playing it's not like they're repeating
moves out of the opening I mean this is
still there's still some meat on the
bone uh in this end game I'm having a
hard time understanding who actually is
playing for a win here because visually
Black's Pawn structure is a lot uglier
Black's got the doubled pawns on the E
file an additional Pawn Island on H7 but
on the other hand it's not enough to
look at the pawns you also have to
compare the relative peace activity and
if you compare the relative peace
activity Black's Rook is a lot more
active than its counterpart it's sitting
on f8 it's staring down the barrel of
that F2 pawn and now Wesley brings this
King up to D6 so my guess is that all of
these factors essentially cancel each
other out it's like football penalties
that cancel each other out the result is
I don't know replay third down
hey the result is there will be no
penalties on the Play Everybody Take
Your Marbles and go home um yeah well
said I think that the doubl B pawns are
also something to keep an eye on if
somehow White made the mistake of
trading the E for the F Pawn because
even though this H Pawn is weak black
has a past E Pawn in that case and maybe
the B pawns are targets but anyway
likely all these things the good and the
bad canceled each other out so
um again there's a lot of other games
going on you can go to chess.com events
no world where we can follow all the
action but I admit I mean it's the game
of the top two players so far in the
tournament and it's also one of the most
interesting ones of the round I unless
you have another one I would just take
us right back to hikaro Nakamura versus
Jose Martinez let's go back to hikara
I'm also keeping keeping an eye on
bordnick versus fuia but let's let that
game heat up a little bit and let's
check back into this end game this is
still our board one matchup this is
going to determine the top of the
tournament standings this is a game that
Hikaru really has to try to win and I
think Hikaru is making really good
progress on that front it almost seems
like he's played four or five moves to
improve his position and Jose has
essentially Stood Still which is Al
essentially what happened because black
has no good moves black is
paralyzed yeah the Knight blocks the
bishop the bishop blocks The Rook which
keeps the Rooks in in no communicado as
they say yeah
and and yeah he just playing quickly
here you see hikaro is also commentating
he's streaming he was on Twitch earlier
I think he switched back to kick for
those who want to see hikaru's firsters
po view you can head over and check out
hikaru's stream
although it will be
delayed um I
actually we're all on the same delay
actually for fair play I
think Hikaru had a hard time deciding
which platform he wanted to stream on so
he decided to Kick the Can down the
road yeah all right we proceed with the
commentary f
what an amazing move byar nakab
advancing his kingside
pawns it is an amazing move and he's
going to put the Knight behind the pawn
and then he's going to continue to
launch the plan you already talked about
earlier which I love G4 F4 maybe F5 if
he's into it he's controlling all the
cards although I will say like as bad as
the position is or I will say this I
actually think this is a better position
than josam had a few moves ago I mean
the trade of the the Knight for the
bishop opening up The Rook is is
somewhat helpful it means that the lack
of communication between the Rooks is
not as big of a deal because the A8 Rook
has kind of developed where it
stands also a few moves ago we had
nothing going on and at least now black
is trying to maneuver and prepare some
sort of activity so josam holding on and
and that's a good thing but if you look
at the clock as well he's uh he's
probably not looking forward to this
time scrim if he's the first one under a
minute no he's struggling this move
Bishop E8 he's hoping for G4 a premature
G4 which would have been met with Knight
to G6 and that would have forced hikaro
to give away his light Square bishop and
that is one thing that hikaro does not
want to do he does not want to give away
his light scored Bishop for Black's
Knight because it will make it very very
difficult for white to continue uh the
kingside pawn storm because the light
squares are going to be really really
weak but you can just sense the
confidence hearo believes that he can
win this game he knows that he is very
likely to win this game just because
Black's defensive task has no end point
you're just going to be defending for
forever and hekar is gonna continue
milking your clock down you know how
these games tend to go if you're
familiar with how hearu how good he is
at converting these small advantages in
end
games you're you're right I'm just
trying to keep the drama alive you know
no I'm kidding it's it's true but at the
same time josam obviously the guy knows
his way around
uh you know some online chess on
chess.com I don't know if you heard the
stat we shared recently there are only
three grand Masters who played more than
100,000 games on chess.com and you know
who one of them is it's josam it's josam
that's a that's a lot of Chess D you
that is a lot of Chess I I wouldn't I I
can't possibly relate I'm not a big fan
of online
chess the guy has played
100,000 plus games on chess.com so it's
insane there's I we'd have to do some
sort of math in terms of things you
could have done in 100,000 games I let
me tell you there's quite a few there's
a lot of things you could have done
right um okay here he commits the pawn
to G to
G6 that's a tough move because now H6 is
weak you've opened up a new
Target yeah asual Hikaru goes right back
to it G4 I think G4 is finally coming
and the worst thing is that why does it
know her
I mean you could even for example play
King C3 King B2 to reinforce the A3 Pawn
in to get your Rook into the action with
Rook H1 of course you could potentially
sacrifice the A3 Pawn but there's
absolutely no need uh for tactical
Shenanigans when you have all the time
in the world here if you're Hikaru
you're enjoying your life um I'm
expecting the move G4 and then I'm
expecting him to kind of slowly but
surely push black off the board I mean
that's the only way of putting it yeah I
really like this plan by the way
bringing the king to B2 protecting the
A3 Pawn so that the other Rook can help
in the king side efforts Knight G5 is a
fancy move as well takes advantage of
the pin you can't take okay and now Jos
from I guess from a practical point of
view recognizes that he doesn't actually
enjoy getting squeezed and he's going to
lash out and here he
comes okay but simply C3 kind of
disarming the immediate threats Maybe
this benefits black that additional
tension on the queen side I'm also
looking at his clock he's under 2
minutes okay Bishop B8 is a great move
getting the bishop out of the knight's
line of fire I'm kind of waiting for
this move G4 by hikaro he been kind ofay
stop your plan how do you stop just King
C2 King B2 guard the a pawn and then
bring the Rook over and just win this
Pawn Al totally possible I mean H5 Jose
will have to play H5 at some point but
that will only be more kindling for the
fire and G4 will only be stronger once
he plays
H5 well you're right maybe maybe that's
a reason to also play G4 ahead of time
to just stop it so J trades what's he5
Knight D7 Knight B6 is a plan but it's
very very
slow well now is where you start
considering whether you want to give up
the Aon you said no Tactical Shenanigans
is not necessary but if you break
through with go Gusto over here and the
Knight comes to G5 and E6 falls again
I'm literally drawing colors I'm like in
a coloring book right now I'm not even
calculating but I'm pointing out there's
a lot of options oh wow this move B5
okay that's
like that's so chess that's so classy
right there that's carop style chess
that is why Jose should have started by
playing B5 himself and Hikaru says that
opportunity train is not going to come
around twice get back to F he is
literally sing the life out of black on
both sides of the board and he's very
likely to get his King to B4 just like
the cherry on top now he could go for
the king to B4 and I don't see any way
for black to stop it but with the pawn
on A4 you could also Play Bishop C2 okay
you have to watch out for Bishop takes
B5 that could be a blunder noted
absolutely something tells me he's going
to spot it though
yeah maybe just King C3 and King up yeah
he goes for it it seems simple and this
is
instructive computer says he doesn't
like wh's play but I think from a human
perspective we can all see the writing
on the wall that by Jose though yeah
this good practical chances you got to
try to mix it up and that's why the
computer wanted to put a knight on G5 in
order to prevent this move G5 now people
watching this might be like G5 what is
is he doing why is he giving up a pawn
he is trying to get the G6 Square for
his Knight and potentially jump to F4
with his KN Jose is saying wait a second
I've got some peace activity if Hikaru
trades on G6 it's actually going to be
quite difficult for white to break
through so I'm expecting Rook H2 Knight
F4 and if he can get Hikaru low on the
clock maybe Jose starts getting some
practical chances here maybe we buried
him a little bit too
early okay all right yeah Knight G5
apparently was important to stop this
Hikaru goes for the line you said white
still in control but yeah Black's pieces
are uh are
suddenly breathing they're breathing
they're alive yeah sort of sort of but
with 50 seconds on the clock there's
just no way that Jose is able to
negotiate all of the the landmines and
avoid stepping on one king to D2 hikaro
goes to B3 okay
but now G3 hits the Knight where's the
Knight going KN is essentially trapped
The Rook guard C2 by the way G3 a dual
purpose
move rug D1 now what this this Knight is
running out of squares I mean what if
you just go yeah go gather it up rook D2
Rook D1 Knight C1 check and King B2 no
it's over that's it hearo calculates it
to the end smooth Victory and a big
victory oh Knight C1
she put the wrong Rook on the
defile Knight C1 and Rook f8 Knight C1
and Rook F and suddenly White's Bishop
on F1 is gonna be under Fire The Rook is
disconnected oh my now wait a this
bishop this bishop is actually in a
dominant position over the Knight on H4
this is
suddenly this is suddenly not yeah you
see Hikaru shaking his head frustrated
with Rook to D2 so stupid he said Rook
D1 was is just winning sorry I can read
oh my gosh no Rook D1 was winning but
Jose has to figure things out here
Bishop G2 Knight D3 check Knight C1
check can he repeat moves here no I
don't think Jose is going to figure this
out he's got not enough time apparently
Rook to G8 is the only equalizing move
here can you imagine finding Rook to G8
with 5 Seconds on the clock Rook to G
why can't he play he's got it my God he
found it oh my God he found Rook G8 he
found the move and Point uh Danny is
that if he had gone Knight C1 check
immediately I think there would have
been a rook takes C1 with Bishop takes
C4 and then a knight Fork on
G6 wow can Jose keep it going one second
left work C4 he
blunders oh my gosh Bishop takes C4 now
now Bishop
E4 and the
idea
takes oh if Bishop be4
takes what is white playing G6 there The
Rook is hanging oh The Rook is hanging I
was testing you you passed over Bish
Bishop takes E4 and if Rook to B4 check
you can even just move the king and you
can't guard everything at the end of the
line you get checkmated if you go to A3
you get checkmated with a rook A8 you
got to go to C3 you were testing again
oh my God crazy Rook to C8 check oh and
the Knight hangs that's what I was
missing is if Rook C8 check the Knight
hangs okay
in the end Hikaru solves it that's why
he's the one calculating and I'm the one
commentating but looks like white is
going to get the job done
here as usual
Hikaru is able to figure everything out
he's got just the right amount of time
I'm also looking at bortnik versus fuja
which is heating up that was it was so
full of landmines there like that the
whole idea that white could get mated
with King A3 that was
hilarious and again lucky for hikaro I
wasn't in control we're going to let him
finish the job here looks like hikaro
will Leap Frog and take the clear lead
after beating josm and we're going to
head over well we'll let it we we'll see
it's almost
over it's almost over and okay Jose with
a heroic heroic defense he did his best
but it's just impossible there were too
many issues he came pretty close he was
maybe a couple of moves away from
figuring everything out but Hikaru
always finds a way to keep things comp
that's it okay this is just over it's
over we're heading over we're heading
over to bortnik FIA where Ali Reza is
coming storming back this guy started
off with an early loss if you just got
here but he didn't throw in the towel
nor did he lose his mind and he has uh
he's gotten himself all the way back in
it with a win here looks like he's
yeah yeah this this one's looking bad
Rook takes C6 E3 and Rook e won made I
like Sasha he's so resilient maybe Rook
to E6 can be
tried still not over I mean black needs
to be a little bit cautious here Bishop
E2 and Bishop D3 maybe 10
seconds where's the win for alaza tickle
plain tickle less than 10 seconds oh my
gosh he had a he had an incredible move
E3 and Rook H1 Rook D1
mate but that ship has sailed
oh my gosh what an idea The Rook or
Bishop take away the king's Escape
Square that's a that's a daily puzzle
right there we'll show it in a second
okay Bishop B2 and Bishop D3 yeah it's
over it's over yeah Bishop takes B5
simply and Bishop D3 pre moved Rook B4
King
A3 Rook B4 check for good
measure but uh fuia going to take down
bortnik and be tied for third with a
large L group of other other people I
believe after this
round yeah it's a brutal event doesn't
matter how many games you win it's I
want to quickly show this idea because
it reminds me of of a of a daily puzzle
you play E3 threatening mate and
regardless of how white takes it when
you check and play Rook D1 the white
King has no Escape square but I'm being
told that the hikaro game has gotten
away from him who Mora what what in the
world what is happening is he Caro
losing it's a draw not it's a draw but
how did this happen that that is not the
ending we saw coming this game was this
game was over we left it was literally
over and he had like three minutes to
josman's two seconds he bled a piece go
to move 55 on there move 55 he played
King to D4
D4 no way why why and
how Knight takes D5 and black resigns
was that like a mouse slip like honestly
he must have he must have misclicked oh
my God I'm sorry I I kind of I feel like
I'm responsible for us not catching the
end of this game I just thought it was
over hey he was up a piece let's see
what hik Caro's reaction was in real
time we turned away but just so the fans
don't feel like they missed it we're
going to go back in
time wow yeah I mean he can even win if
he wants to be tactical you can go E6
King D6
E7 and King takes E7 Knight G6 this must
have been some sort of a mouth slip or
some sort of a completely
uncharacteristic brain fart byar
Nakamura this never happens to him
seeing his reaction I I don't know that
it was a mouslip I think he just
legitimately had a brain a brain lapse
there I mean he just blundered the night
straight up and just like that the
birthday boy gets a gift josam holds on
and ultimately they go on to draw this
Rook ending show you the final moments
but there really wasn't anything to it
hikaro blundered a
piece and uh maybe he forgot to say
happy birthday I don't know he might
have just forgot to forgot to tell josam
it was his birthday gift but either way
unbelievable Jose Martinez is still in
the lead by a half a point over a large
group of players now was six and a half
and then even more of them was
six it ain't over till it's over I mean
you you know all the cliches but when
the game is in hikaru's hands you really
do think it's over because this just
never happens to him he's always on the
defending side of games like that where
he's able to pull a win out of the jaws
of defeat or pull out a draw he did that
against vidit but he's never on The
Winning Side of these types of games and
that was a huge game was J Martinez
seven points out of eight no losses and
a crazy Miracle save against Yar
Nakamura I guess you manufactur your own
luck interest chest Danny well I mean I
I think yes and I think josam while he
may not be hikaro he's one of the pesar
uh just trickier he perseveres with the
best of them here especially in the
online format but he just got a gift
here I mean this was literally Hikaru
just straight up under the night like in
one move like there was there wasn't
even like a Swindle hikaro just put the
King on a square that gave away the
night for free so like I said it's a
birthday gift at this point but yeah it
doesn't take anything away from what a
fantastic day he's had as you said he
hasn't lost a single game he's drawn two
to sit seven out of eight as we head
into the last round it was a donation as
H as dark tiger says here in twitch chat
shout out to everybody tuning
in and we're getting set for the ninth
and final round here we've got YouTube
and twitch chat both pretty active just
kind of waiting for the next games to
begin because I
uh you know I'm already I'm already in
the future tomorrow I'm already thinking
about the match play that's going to go
down as these players duke it out for
spots in divisions one two and three my
brain is already what is tomorrow a
Tuesday where tomorrow is a a Friday I
think no Thurs Friday th Thursday
tomorrow's a Thursday
is it a Thursday it is a Thursday I feel
like I've lost track the days of the
week ever since you know like Co
so okay here we go for those asking
Magnus is not playing in the playin
because he has already qualified for
division one part of the okay here we
have a uh what looks to be a Berlin will
it be a qu D the most exciting game in
chess oh my God oh my God oh my goodness
what a position he Berlin with D4 on the
board on the board
B6
the Steph Curry driving to the rim and
lay up in is on the board here's Lamar
Jackson with the ha Mary pass C3 Rook
trades on E8 Queen to E8 and a draw
Green what a game okay
sorry yeah it's it's like that only one
open file all the pieces will be traded
symmetrical Pond structure you heard it
everybody anyway Magnus will be playing
tomorrow uh joining him already having
confirmed spots into the top division
are Maxim bash LV and Vladimir
fedosov and then there are some other
players who will also be joining
tomorrow yanomi Anish giri vladislav
timv Sam
seian um
sorry um but uh yeah timv seian giri and
nepom nesi that was
correct yeah and uh looks like we're not
going to have a lot of fireworks here in
this last round battle the players
are rapidly headed towards
simplification and
peace yeah I mean I'm a little bit
surprised that Jose maybe his conscience
did not allow him to to go for the
traditional Berlin draw you know the
queen E4 Queen D4 repetition but I would
say that the rookie one variation it
strikes a good balance it's good for
pretending that you're playing for a win
but in reality the vast majority of
games that enter this line and precisely
along the lines that this game is going
to end just a bunch of Trades um it's
just a wideopen position with a
symmetrical material so what you know
what do you expect
right well but okay uh but okay and
uh yes we will uh we'll have more more
top players joining as the week goes on
Don and I will be here tomorrow of
course for match play before we hand
things off to David and Tanya and Robert
hes and we will we will join them as
guests as well we're throwing we're
throwing five commentators at you pretty
consistently all year here for the
Champions chess tour and
uh for a second I thought G3 no I five
G3 blunders the night and then I
realized that's how chess works there's
something called a pin very obscure
device and that pin that the black could
not take an F3 okay we're going to get a
draw here it's a matter of seconds I
think I I just decided we're going to go
on that queue head over toar Nakamura
versus sville tan I think I think this
one will not end
quickly I think they're following the
game van Forest versus we from to of
Steel move for move I'm pretty sure we
had this exact position and I'm pretty
sure Hikaru himself has played this
particular chowski variation with white
um against Fabian Carana I want to say
so he knows these positions really
really well White's idea is to quickly
push C4 and open up the center and bring
a rook to D1 but Sam is also responding
by playing very very
fast so they both know the game they
both know what's going
on they
do
okay what a frantic pace of this
tournament can't even
breathe
hikaro is still shaking his head I feel
like he's probably still talking about
that last game that got away from him
but no question about it he needs to
focus on this one because it's starting
to look a little bit better for seld
with the rook and Queen on the C file
maybe there's some action to break
through here or no no we're just going
to get a big trade on C6 and close
things up oh we might Bishop takes C6
yeah looks like black is completely fine
here I mean white has a very pretty
Knight on D4 but at the same time black
has the bishop pair and White's got this
very discombobulated Pawn structure with
a pawn Island on the C file and I would
just go Bishop to D7 if I'm sfil and
eventually try to surround the C5 Pawn
with a well-timed bishop G7 back to f8
so maybe Hikaru is still reeling a
little bit from that crazy game which
does have major standings implications
yeah and again lucky for Hikaru and
josam and pretty much everybody you see
at the top they've already they've
already likely secured their spot you
know again I I can't speak for all tie
breaks or what would happen if if if
terrible terrible things in the last
round allowed people to overtake them
but they will be competing with
opportunities to secure a division one
placement and if they have division one
placement then uh hey that's what that's
what the show is all about that's true
everyone is competing to immediately
punch their ticket to the live finals
they don't want to they don't want to do
this all year and no one wants Magnus to
win every event I don't even think
Magnus wants to win every event although
he actually not even Magnus wants Magnus
to win every event well yeah probably
does but Magnus actually does want to
win every single event
but okay there we go Bishop f8 by the
way the plan that I outlined it's on the
board and I think yaru I mean his
opening experiment not necessarily A
great success here I feel like he's the
one who has to be careful in order to
maintain the balance although to be fair
Bishop takes C5 is never really a
problem for white because he could trade
everything on C5 and play Rook takes B7
and there I think you have a slight
Advantage because you have the good
knight versus bad Bishop yeah in fact
that's something that sville wants to
avoid if everything is traded here and
white wins the B7 Pawn this Knight is
actually pretty dominant compared to
that Bishop as the dark squares are
completely controlled and that Knight is
securely outposted in the center um yeah
so yeah that means that sbell is kind of
kind of like all
right how do I make my position better
you see he slides the queen over hikara
might even just quickly play a move like
G3 I don't know but I'm curious like
what is black doing next
right are are you gonna yes are are you
going to no no maybe but I think given
the tournament circumstances he
eventually he going to wait I mean queen
E7 Queen C7 by the way Jose and ala have
officially drawn their game so
congratulations to the birthday boy Jose
Martinez finishes with seven and a half
out of nine that's going to be clear
okay not necessarily clear first but at
the very least a tie for first and
obviously a ticket into division one and
it's amazing to me Danny that there are
players who we haven't even talked about
who are Inc contention I'm looking at
Ralph mov and I guess Ralph maybe has
already drawn his game but I'm not
totally sure but hiar Nakamura might end
up repeating the position if he's happy
with the draw M already Drew they were
actually the first ones done yeah um
so so yeah there you have it Martinez
gets the job done an absolutely Stellar
performance today securing a division
one placement and uh everyone else is
going to be duking it out in match play
tomorrow I can't wait I'll be there da
are you going to be busy tomorrow are
you going to be you going to be around
tomorrow you know I will be busy but I
think I can make some time to to cover
the match play okay anything for you
Danny I'll make some time you know what
I appreciate it um yeah well I don't
know what tie breaks would be if Hikaru
wins and ties
Martinez
yep maybe we shouldn't speak I don't
want to speak directly
to what is so just yet Wesley taught me
that oh my
gosh gonna pretend nothing happened
there how is Wesley doing can we check
in on Wesley's position against de onon
because Wesley can win and also catch
Jose and so can deid Anon of course very
strong player from
Spain but okay Wesley very good position
here Bishop PA and the Knight coming to
four the Knight is coming to C4 B6 is a
target uh yep yeah uh actually
yeah actually yeah this is a very
unpleasant position for black of course
you can try to solve your problems
tactically with the move D5 instead to V
onon he takes on B4 that's a really
interesting move and I think he is
trying to push D5 as quickly as he can
in order to open up the center and kind
of dull the influence of White's light
squared Bishop which is otherwise just
slicing through the entire position
maybe white can jump his Knight into C4
anyway Danny I don't know what happens
there Knight C4 D5 Knight takes B6 Rook
a to d8 and I think black is actually
surviving there I was gonna say we're
gonna find out because it's those are
the moves that we now see on the board
Knight to C4 D5 and if Knight takes I
think you're right I think just fiding
The Rook to d8 everything is simplified
if we just
exchange I keep wondering if there was
something else like like a D4 or
something and if you take Taking E3 and
then trying to trap the Knight but seems
unnecessary tactics likely don't work
out so probably just play Rook
ad8 yeah rook ad8 and I wonder what the
pause is caused
by is it something after Rook ad8 e
takes D5 Knight takes d is Deon not a
big fan of the center opening up and
look at that D takes C4 a drastic
measure taken by dvides sacrifices The
Exchange and I don't like this at all I
think this was an unnecessarily drastic
measure D takes C4 and where's the
compensation I think he I mean he's he's
got big dreams about the fact that if
the diagonal opens up and the Knight and
Bishop get working on G2 this bishop is
suddenly out of place right the bishop
wishes it was there defending everything
so maybe he throws in Rook d8 here for
good measure gain a Tempo on the queen
before
cap but the problem here is this move
Queen G4 Queen G4 is a very concrete
problem for black because it threatens
Queen takes G6 and it just feels like
Black's initiative I can see what you're
saying I mean Knight H4 maybe find a way
to activate your queen if you're de onon
but after Queen G4 and maybe even F3 to
just chase the Knight out of E4 it feels
like it feels like Black's attack is
very ephemeral here okay that's
fair
yeah
okay big moment here for Wesley will he
play Queen
G4 he
will what a suspenseful
moment you asked the question he
delivers very true
yes yes
exactly
okay Queen to F6 by Dev Anon defending
the Knight on G6 and maybe Wesley will
play that move F3 just blunting the
bishop on C6 chasing the Knight out of
E4 I think Wesley's very likely to take
this game
yeah and and it's a game that David Anon
helped him I guess with this uh
unnecessary exchange sack I got excited
at first you know I like to think that
there's always a chance to root for the
underdog but
no Queen to G4 F3 is a really nice idea
kills all the diagonal pressure and at
some point you're even just looking to
maybe put a rook on D1 trade off that
light score Bishop simplify everything
the extra exchange should be good enough
by the way B4 is hanging right if you
just play F3 maybe you just go okay he
doesn't what I was going to say maybe
you just go take the pawn absolutely and
he's just biting his time he's just
basically saying listen black has no
good way to improve his position I think
Danton is just going down in the next
couple of moves that exchange sacrifice
was a good thought it was a creative
idea but that kind of stuff just doesn't
work against players of Wesley so's
caliber and yeah I think he's taking
this last game and I think he's going to
catch up to josam at seven and a half
out of
nine there's also Tera
hackin against Hikaru Nakamura can we
check into how that game is going yes
sir how that end game is proceeding and
I think hikaro is trying to make a
serious push against Black's clock
primarily
yeah but
okay please feel free to take
that h f
uh if the Rook comes to h8 does the king
have to go to G6 feels a little
awkward it
does although this might be one of those
pawns you don't really want to take with
the Rook if
you're I mean Rook H you can actually
want to take are there pawns you don't
really want to take ever that every Pawn
that is taken goes to the pawn Farm
where pawns are safe forever um Happy
I was looking at Rook h8 King G7 Rook H5
and then Bishop E8 The Rook is kind of
Trapped but there's Knight takes E6
check and that seems like a mess and
good for white so why not just Rook
h8 why not just Rook h8 I think iaru is
trying to figure out the same thing I
think here's one very important detail
after Rook h8 King G6 if we could play
the moves on the board white can try
this maneuver Knight F3 and now let's
make a waiting move for black such as
Rook C7 after Knight H4 check King G7
Rook takes H5 all pawns go to the pawn
Farm where do Rooks go in their tra did
they go to The Rook Farm well I don't
know but either way I think this is the
defensive
mechanism all Rooks do not go to heaven
okay that is they don't that is actually
true um that's good to know and uh good
line to show the potential dangers of
getting off
track so Hikaru
calculating still hasn't moved
considering Rook h8 it's it's obviously
an
option but he's probably trying to think
about the next window right I think this
is actually really instructive in terms
of clock management
because it's important to try to not
just think about the next move but what
is the next idea that you want your
opponent to have to solve when they're
about to get under two minutes right so
try to actually not just play moves that
allow for quick and forcing reactions
what is the problem keep the game
open-ended you want to keep the game as
open-ended as possible for as long as
possible we have some Moves In the
meantime I'm pretty sure um we have some
moves after H5 not okay the position
basically has remained the same and
maybe black just has a fortress maybe
there's just no way to create any
practical problems but Hikaru always
finds a way to create practical problems
always if there's a will there's a way
for Hikaru to create problem for his
opponent if he plays Knight to C5 is
there a way that he he wants the king to
come here maybe that's his idea he in
fact here he goes yeah he removed the
Knight he's decided that maybe the king
and the Knight are better positioned
this way and then perhaps we can start
to create other problems again as I'm
saying this it it does look to be a
fortress it's hard to see a concrete
plan for white but but like we said iaro
usually finds a
way yeah he's trying to get his King to
D4 potentially for the time being black
is essentially in a holding pattern just
like Bishop D7 Bishop B8 what does black
has to be careful about of course the H5
Pawn is a long-term weakness but it can
be pretty effectively defended whenever
necessary by Black's Bishop from E8 of
course black also has to be very careful
not to allow for example Knight to come
to C5 and then the white Rook to come to
A6 so there are some situations when you
could find yourself essentially
paralyzed because of the weakness of the
E6 pawn and this is what worries me SEL
has to find the right defensive setup
and he's running out of time his clock
is dwindling he's down to 90 seconds and
when you're playing Hikaru Danny all of
the enemies that are at your gate that
are at your door are blown up 5x
everything that otherwise you wouldn't
be scared of you're now like terrified
of
right but again even if we establish
let's say the king moves back you get
the Knight to C5 and the bishop is on D7
I haven't really actually calculated the
Rook ending yet so let's just for now
ignore that worst case scenario that
position is black to play again and they
can put the bishop on C8 and in worst
case scenario again if it's black to
play can't they Shuffle the king to F7
so I'm having a hard time like give
white the dream position put the Knight
on C5 put the Rook on A6 and and my
Bishop is on C8 and then what I mean
Knight C5 basically reaches the dream
setup your point is well taken Knight C5
black might even play Bishop D7
obviously black does not mind a trade of
Knight for Bishop and then what what's
the followup in that position s Bell is
under a minute but can Hikaru continue
to create practical problems for black
to solve or has he found essentially the
foolproof setup that will allow him to
pre-move his way to a
draw oh you know I think I have an idea
now Okay so let's say Hikaru gets the
the the rook and the Knight here and the
bishop is defending in some in some
space D7 or C8 I actually wonder if part
of the idea will be to trade the C for
the D pawn and then play E4 and at some
point open up the idea that I'm actually
I'm actually going to trade the C for D
I'm GNA I'm going to trade the E for f
and at some point I'm going to pry
things open with a move like F5 where in
a future State I now I've created new
opportunities for my knight on F four
where I'm hitting H5 I've got Knight D5
Knight G6 so I didn't think that pushing
the pawn to C4 was really an idea but
now now I'm thinking it might
be I think Hikaru is going to try to
exhaust all of the resources in this
structure but yes C4 can definitely be
considered it poses a new set of
problems to Black maybe he'll also try
H4 just to fix the pawn on H5 look at
Black's clock he's down to 25 seconds
and seeming hikaro hasn't even done
anything and yet that is the magic of
his play he makes you think I would try
Rook B in this position okay he plays C3
all right but King D6 and where to from
here 15 seconds he's got to move a
little bit faster here he can't burn all
of his clock before any tactics have
occurred on the
board I think he will
eventually okay now he's threatening the
the the seventh rank entry if the Rook
moves
off okay but still what's next is he
going to play
H4 maybe but then King D6 and what's
next yes I mean black is just confident
that he can sit with Rook C7 and Rook C8
and Rook C7 what to do
now big question going down the list of
results by the way it feels like every
single game was a draw besides our boy
peace FY shout out to the rapper making
a back he's been here for years don't
call it a comeback Peter spider he did
get a
dub great performance by P viy what
about Wesley so can we check back into
his game just to make sure that yeah
it's all cut and dry Wesley so is wait a
second whoa David Anton he's showing why
he sacked The Exchange I told you check
on G2 you know and White's White's
missing a minor piece black now has two
pieces for The Rook Queen B8 King e s
Queen
G3 can be
tried but okay this is very complicated
double-edged position now wlea might
have to go for
draw it's funny because with the past a
pawn if if you do trade on G3 the Knight
has to move to safety white quickly
swings The Rook to A1 and pushes baby I
think we're about to see exactly that or
even even just A5 first yeah Bishop B5
though sticking the bishop on a really
really nice Square to stop the pawn and
black could park the bishop on A6 and
Danny it's a three res game black has
also a pass Pawn on e4 and that pawn
could also potentially squeeze through
but five seconds for de Danton can he
figure out where to put his Knight two
seconds Knight
D6
okay King F2 maybe just kind of a slow
move Wesley's gonna repeat once yeah
then king of two next or this is a total
three res game by the way I don't know
where Wesley Let It Go
but King F6 excellent response if you
run the king up black meets you with
King E5 I think black is yeah black is
the one pushing here don't go Rook e
three that would blunder a fork to
Knight D1 now F5 is coming black is
starting to push his Pawn Wesley's time
Advantage is gone yeah
seconds
F5 oh my gosh
Panic Knight D5 check I don't like that
move you can't tell you why though you
don't really want to make that tra I
agree you wanted the two knights I feel
like there were more tactics there for
for black but but okay still here comes
Knight C4 check and then what I mean
Wesley just gives up The Rook for the
Knight not a bad call he's got three
pawns for the bishop I think white might
be playing for a
win wow I'm actually not sure who's
playing for a
win
I have no idea maybe they're white what
is he
doing now who's now who's winning I have
no idea who's winning in this s him it's
got to be black
apparently okay but King E4 how does
black make progress though I understand
the eval bar shows that black is winning
but Wesley's just going to shuffle
between D4 and E4 David Anon is
apparently finding all the best moves
but what does he do now no he's not
going to find it what is the win I don't
even understand how does black win this
it's probably some like weird sequence
of King and Bishop moves to get white
into zong but wait a second he's
actually making some progress now Bishop
A6 and the great thing is that the G6
Pawn is on a light Square so black can
defending with his Bishop he's gotten it
and if you move black plays King C5 and
David Anton is going to go on and win
this game what an absolutely crazy
turnaround oh my Lance and Wesley should
have just repeated moves and he had a
chance he even had a chance when he was
down the bishop he
resigned onon
wins what a crazy turnaround that was
Wesley so looked like he was the only
one who could win David Anton's sacrific
as a dubious as dubious exchange
sack
but shout out to S by the way if he
holds this against sakaru this isn't an
easy thing to do
no that was a very impressive hold and
actually you laugh but black is okay at
this point black is not worse Black is
maybe even in the driver's seat okay of
course black will not mind a draw here
but hikaro has to be a little bit
careful all of a
sudden yeah seriously five okay now it's
a draw okay it's it's it's a draw now
but wow both both sides could lose
trying to win but they won't do that
everything will be
simplified
and David Anton with the victory by the
way comes from behind to Ty josam Jose
Martinez for first place in the play
regardless of what happens in this game
well it's going to be a dry
wild incredible just non-stop action
today what a win for David Anton not
without some luck but hey good players
are always lucky and you need some luck
if you want to do well in the CCT
qualify there's no other way you need to
have Fortune smiling on you now wait a
second Hikaru has to be careful he's
about to lose this if he's not
careful dude H6 Rook H2 already might be
losing Danny I think he's got to give a
check on E8 and give up a second pawn
and it is a draw it is a draw but it's
not going to be easy yeah this is one of
those draws that okay it's it is a draw
but there are weird tricks where the
pawn the extra Pawn is crucial in terms
of keeping the king shielded from checks
on the f file so this is not going to be
super easy no but hiar knows the
technique you basically have to keep
your Rook on the eighth Rank and black
cannot make
progress yeah I would try
F3 but it's just a
draw yeah
okay there the same position he not
trying to repeat
moves
is zaru trying to win what is he doing
he has no business trying to win why are
you thinking just play King F3
dude this is hilarious I mean King F1
probably also draws but I think hearu is
just gonna slow roll and then play King
F3 when his clock is about to run out
it's just what is he even doing Hikaru
is like Leela you know the uh the Leela
engine he's trolling his opponent when
he has has no
business no business trying to pretend
like he's going to win this King F1 here
he goes I'm telling you he's flirting
with it no it's a drw no he doesn't that
is hilarious debating whether or not he
would invite his opponent to try to win
maybe lose on time I don't know I mean
hikaru's better judgment wins out and
ultimately he
draws uh and there you have it those are
the final standings you can see there on
the left of the board
given that all the results are in the
books I don't believe we have any other
games coming so
josam Jose Eduardo Martinez on his
birthday congratulations he does get
first on tie breaks but David Anton
comes all the way back da with this
crazy victory over Wesley so to tie him
for first in our plan wow Crazy Action
up until the very last round lots of
players taking big risks we thought
Wesley had it in the bag every time we
switch away from a game crazy things
tend to happen Hikaru blew that extra
piece position against Jose um so once
again big happy birthday uh to Mr
Martinez and a big congratulations to
him uh and David Anon and of course all
of the other players who qualified to
the various three divisions it's going
to be an action-packed day tomorrow if
it's anything like today today was
awesome I cannot wait some of these
results just were surprising down down
the Finish Line here but okay we're
going to confirm that every result is in
the books and that there are no other
shakeups coming via tie breaks or
otherwise so don't go anywhere we're
going to take our last break of the day
it's been the playin we're going to
confirm results here for the chessable
Masters don't go anywhere our final
moments on today's show when we
[Music]
return
I'm here with Magnus Carlson world
number one and to many greatest chess
player of all time we're going to ask
him a few questions I'm going to name a
sport you have to tell me the greatest
of all time mhm sounds good yeah
basketball LeBron
James soccer Messi I agree with both
baseball Barry
Bonds what did he say Okay football like
American
football Tom Brady I guess okay yeah
good one uh tennis jovic
golf
tiger Fair poker dog
bson that's a unique one
chess gar Kasparov are you allow to say
yourself I don't know if I'm allowed but
I think Gary is the best all time still
chess
boxing I'm on Hamilton I agree we're
going to play this or that would you
rather go on a cruise or a road trip
road trip comedy or thriller comedy
coffee or tea tea but only slightly
preferably neither how do you get
energized the sun cats or dogs cats but
I like dogs too it's like a this or that
is a little bit tough with you you like
everything shower or bath oh shower for
sure okay I don't have the patience to
take baths are you a morning person or a
night owl Night Owl for sure would you
rather get on a phone call or text
message text probably I feel like the
answer for you is neither feel like it's
just usually
yes just go sunrise or sunset sunrise
winter or summer summer how many beers
would it take for you to drink for me to
beat you in a classical chess game
that's a very difficult question uh cuz
I'd probably sober up during the game so
I'd probably have to keep drinking
probably start with 20 and take it from
there 20 okay how what's the size of the
cup um pints wow okay 20 name your price
if you have to chess box um $10 million
do you prefer to play chess on a
computer over the board or on your phone
I rarely play on my phone I I would say
I prefer to play on the computer in your
entire career have you ever had a day
where you went I think this guy might be
as good as me in
chess
no uh well I mean not not not you know
since not the last 10 years for sure
okay has it ever
been this guy might be kind of close to
me if I have a bad day yeah uh I would
say Fabi to his best was um very close
in In classical for sure my other
question was going to be who do you
think is the second best chess player in
the world so I suppose yeah I think
Fabian corana is the is the second
second best player thank you Magnus for
sitting down with us and doing these
rapid fire questions now get out of
here
[Music]
the playin stage is underway the first
day is now in the books and we are
joined by the winner the guy on top of
the mall at the end of the day it's his
birthday josam Jose at watermore
Martinez happy birthday man thank you
thank you dny
hello was was there something going for
you early today where you could feel it
and and how do you how do you
historically play on your birthday I
know that for a lot of chess players
they actually don't like playing on
their birthday but you seem to have
everything cooking today normally in the
last years uh like in Peru or Mexico
where I am like living um there there
are no tournaments in these kind of
months January February so maybe in some
year I could play a title Tuesday or
Arena Kings at the 31 of January but I
don't remember actually this is the
maybe the most important uh tournament I
have in my uh day of
Birthday Jose what was your proudest
moment today obviously you had quite a
few highlights you had that incredible
early win against kevish I think that
Bishop takes H6 game with some really
nice opening preparation but uh what
moment are you proud of proudest of is
it the comeback against saru or is it
one of your
wins I think uh in this tournament I I
like to to say like it's a many moments
I need to to do good to to have a good
performance like the second round I play
against darar Yan he's usually a guy who
beats me 80% of the times in title
Tuesday so the fact I I beat him in a
really f fighting match fighting game it
was a boosting me to have more
confidence also the four round the same
case like a guy who beat me in this kind
in this actually CCT last year uh for
sure I don't know if the the game
against Vincent ker or the game I just
say by Miracle against Hikaru was the
the best I think maybe against Hikaru
because that happens once in a million
times it's not my um like um how to say
in English I don't have the word
actually but it's his fault it's not my
uh my own action I I hold this game but
okay I can think it I can't think it
kind of weird right Hikaru hikaro gave
you a gift on your birthday right
because like you said we we were we were
pretty shocked you don't you don't see
him make mistakes like that very often
but you but you capitalized I agree with
you your game with k with ker was uh was
also fantastic what what is it about
this uh this event that is maybe the
most the most difficult obviously so
many strong opponents it's also a very
long event for Rapid chess right you
don't normally play this much rapid
chess tell us a little bit about how how
grueling it is to keep your form in nine
rounds against this level of
competition I think uh I have a really
a unique I don't think it's Unique but a
clear strategy I play like my my lines
my openings I play 99% of the time so I
don't don't waste energy to calculate to
to make a novelty so I am in my own uh
territory so I I know maybe a bit better
than anyone when I play some some
position that's uh actually give me more
confidence uh and it's difficult because
sometimes I just want to play like I
have the bullet mod when I when I want
just I find a easy move I want to do it
but I remember in more longer time
control games I need just to focus to
just decide check some moves and decide
who is what is better and that is
complicated because I always play bullet
always play Blitz and I don't have the
the kind of system uh to continue and
continue on I'm not a classical player
most of the time but I play like five
tournaments six tournaments OTB last
year in classical and B I played like
two or three or four
OTS go d
I was just going to follow up on would
you say that um when you play a
tournament like this do you think of it
as a blitz tournament or do you almost
think of it more as a classical
event uh actually 10 plus two it's uh
more like a blit I think but H you know
everyone it's well prepared so I don't
know if the many of my opponents will do
some novelty do some
uh prep preparation against some opening
and I just play like Blitz actually but
I try to take my time in some critical
moments I when I when I need to take
time is that is that hard by the way I
mean you said you're you're someone who
plays a lot of bullet online you're
known for that you play a lot of Blitz
online successfully known for that and
you said you have to remind yourself not
to just take the first move is there is
there anything you can share with the
audience like is there like a trick for
that how do you how do you force
yourself to have discipline when you're
typically playing a lot faster time
controls
online there's a good example
in he plays so fast the opening he
played the French defense so fast and he
just make a lot of mistakes he he gave
me the chance to play Queen Queen F4
Bishop H4 and he just have the the the
the chance the only option to get in
that end game with the all the structure
really bad and actually I was playing
fast in that moment but then I realized
has as is not end I was looking a lot of
mates a lot
of really best options but then I just
take three minutes I think and I find
Rook e s i I see Rook e s that that move
and I see should it that should work and
then I really calculate if he has some
kind of three kind of counter play and
also miss the bishop E6 Bishop E8 he
played or Bishop D7 I I think oh I I
just ruin it no but then I continue to
think and then oh I have some if okay at
at least in the worst case if I lost the
piece I have a lot of uh compensation my
my Rooks is continuing making making
threats and also I have five pounds
against two so is not it's not bad but
uh it's difficult like when you think
you are winning and then you realize oh
I miss this move and I need to
continue it was a great move I mean a
great move a great mating you found
there and that victory over punr up I
forgot about that game that was also
great we we we covered a lot of your
games today early on and worked out
because you ended up being the guy who
won we're getting some comments from
chat can you hear like the truck noises
behind you and and what's going on out
there is someone stuck in traffic yeah
actually I'm U this apartment is in um
like how to say
it it's in the middle of two big Avenues
so it's a lot of traffic and also Lima
is well known for the top five top 10
most
traffic cars in environment in the world
it's it's not easy to partly just
teasing does it help you play better
chess with some distractions around
heighten your focus actually I play a
lot all most of the time with music or
Ren with music title Tu with music but
this tournament I just drop off my uh my
my headphones when I was playing and
think that helps me to
to play
better it's logical to do the same thing
every time but I just I like to listen
music because I I'm not a quiet guy a
calm guy so I need some uh energy behind
to to maintain my
rhythm speaking of energy any birthday
plans for the rest of the day I guess
now you also have to celebrate your
fantastic
performance um yeah I will be I will
take a dinner with my family I guess and
in the night and in the weekend I will
do something with my friends improve
that sounds awesome that sounds awesome
well while we have you here you know I I
heard a stat recently that I don't know
if you know this but do you know that
there are only three grand Masters who
played more than a 100,000 games on
chess.com and do you know who one of
them
is yeah actually I was in the Stream
when you say it okay or someone someone
told me and then I check and yeah I
don't know how I play a lot yeah I think
that that's a lot of chess games you
played man that's a lot four uh almost
four or three years when I try hard in
online when pandemic comes I try hard a
lot so yeah I guess a lot of bullet a
lot of I don't play Ultra bullet but
sometimes a lot of blit once in a
while it pays off though I mean honestly
obviously you know the results kind of
speak for themselves you you perform
very well and and very welld deserved
you you you put a lot of work in but
it's like I even go back to the game
with Hikaru you have you have a
mentality a bit of a Never Never say die
kind of approach where you always feel
like you're in a game and is that you
think that partly you attribute that to
the fact that you've played so many
games literally tens of thousands that
there's a part of you that never gives
up even if you're losing a position I
think I learned lot from hikaro when I
watch
his games the way he beat me a lot of
times or other players he just not most
of the time but many times he just get a
worst position so he tries to uh don't
make his position worse try to just
defend don't the open and increase the
advantage and then in that position
improve improve improve I like that way
sometimes I don't have the focus to do
that but I I learned about him and
actually was almost resigning in that
game or I was almost flag in that game I
I have actually a huge uh huge uh luck
in that game I I don't know how I do
that well it's amazing and like you said
you learned it from hikaro so you're
learning from the best of them and I
having watched you guys do this for so
many years you just you see a certain
mentality that players have to kind of
persevere and you definitely emulate
that D does the same uh he just like
play really fast really tactical he
never resign he just is is a fight guys
so I actually watch all of his games in
these years like 2021 2022 so I improve
mostly watching experience but watching
the the best of the the best thing
online so to become maybe one
sometimes well I've got a question from
chat from Matt J Leonard um says what
will happen first your 100th title
Tuesday Victory or 200,000 games played
on chess.com
how how many title Tuesdays have you won
I think it's eight or seventh in
the in the year where which the the
title Tuesday was Knockouts okay first
eight and then Knockouts I get first but
was not first in knockout was first in
Swiss but then seven or eight I think I
don't have the exact number but it's 100
the title Tuesday Wing is almost I need
to I need to leave really long if I want
that'd be a pretty tough task I agree so
at the same time 200,000 games is a lot
although at this point I wouldn't doubt
it given given what you're doing so
you're only 25 years old you got a lot
of Chess ahead of you congratulations
today uh Happy Birthday again go go
enjoy your Victory and um we'll catch up
with you of course later in this week
and best of luck for the rest of your of
your chess here at the CH Masters thank
you then thank you
then bye Jose
all right da that was our winner of the
event and those are the standings as you
can see now that everything is clear in
the books those who've already qualified
for division one four of them didn't
even have to play today to do it one of
them played fantastic chess that was
Jose
Martinez any uh any other major
takeaways for you there well it was such
a tightly contested tournament Yar
Nakamura he's happy uh to be in division
one and we talked about it before the
start of the some of these dark horse
names like svil Tera honin I'm looking
over at number 13 lucky number 13 py of
course Dennis Lac manages to squeeze his
way into the top 15 as well those are
the names that are really trying to play
spoiler and trying to show that wait a
second it's not all about Magnus it's
not all about hikaro we can also do some
damage and Dennis lazic he will face off
against thear Nakamura he will have to
do some damage that's going to be a
tough match for the B Russian youngster
yeah one of the cool things about the uh
the placement stage right this this
playin followed by the match play is we
we work with all the players before they
disappear we know they're tired after
the Swiss to make sure that we know
who's choosing who the top seeds do get
to choose their opponents and so now we
actually know who's going to play who
this is interesting uh match up to
Circle you obviously recognize Nakamura
versus LC those are two players who were
in Toronto I think Oli Resa fuja versus
you e is also a very big one and then
okay Wesley so Vincent kimer I mean okay
I'll just keep listing the match ups
they're all good da no these are
mouthwatering matchups anywhere you look
fua versus Yu yangi lavic versus
Nakamura Danton versus Ralph mov two
really exciting players as well so I
think it's going to be an awesome day of
matches
tomorrow can't wait for the division one
match play Let's also take a quick look
at the the placements how they will be
throwing down in division 2 you got
David paravian right there at the top so
many big names gosh I'm reminded every
year we do this I'm like this is a
second division this is division two
this is insane players we didn't even
get a chance to talk about today like
brish Marty rosan so many strong players
here yeah I can't even believe Alexander
grishuk was playing in the tournament
this is just a testament to how many
incredible players we have speaking of
which even division three you got names
like Alexis s we're used to them being
in division one Ivan sarich kill
alexenko that guy was in the candidates
tournament by the way so anywhere you
look there's going to be amazing names
an amazing action Twan mlay wonderful
time as well so many Grand Masters
Christopher you he's not from Papo New
Guinea but that's what his flag is gonna
be okay that is an interesting flag
there for for Christopher you I love it
all right but there you go all the way
down to the 4 look at your boy Anton
demchenko shout out to demchenko right
after Tod steel holding holding it up
shout out to the Snowballs OG proess
League team throwback but all right
we've uh we've got so much chess ahead
you and I of course will be covering all
the action all the match play is g to is
going to continue and uh you and I are
going to be there tomorrow to have it I
don't know which first matchup I'm most
looking forward to back to that early
early slide we looked at division one I
think Wesley so Vincent kimer that is
going to be awesome so all right well da
this was great this is it the 2024
Champions chess tour is officially here
and day one is in the books for the
chessable Masters so for you for the
crew for the team for everybody crushing
it working super hard Don and I are G to
go enjoy the evening we're going to
celebrate Jam's
birthday ourselves you know we do it our
own way um and we will be back of course
tomorrow so enjoy your evening everybody
tune in for day two it is match play we
will be back it's the chessable Masters
it's the 2024 Champions chess tour here
we go
[Music]
again
he
[Music]
a
he
[Music]